GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING IS CALLED TO
ORDER. WE WILL BEGIN WITH SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS. FIRST- WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT H. T. T.
P. S. A. P. S. F. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT C. A. DOT GOV PLEASE NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM ITS LIVE
STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
AT W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT C. A.
DOT G. O. V. SO LAST TODAY'S
EVENTS T. O. D. A. Y. S. E. V.
E. N. T. S. THE CAPITAL WILL BE
OPEN. FOR ATTENDANCE OF THIS
HEARING. ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC CONTINUE THE HEARING IN
THE CAPITOL WE'LL NEED TO WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN
THE BUILDING. BURKE IS STRONGLY
ENCOURAGED TO PARTICIPATE VIA A
WEB PORTAL. REMOTE VIDEOS
TESTIMONY STATIONS ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS LOCATED ON THE
NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL OR
PHONE USING THE NUMBER PROVIDED
ON THE SCREEN. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES. IT IS CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW TESTIMONY. OF FIVE
MINUTES PER SIDE ON EACH. BILL
WE ASK THAT ALL PARTICIPANTS
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND STATE AND STANCE THIS IS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE TESTIFYING
FOR AND AGAINST AND THE REST
ARE WE CALL ME TOOS PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO ADD ON- AND- TOLD TO
GIVE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY BELONG
TO. IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE
GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH FROM
THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF
OUR TIME WILL NOT. WE WILL NOT
PERMIT CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS.
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE
EVEN WIELD THREATS THE BILL'S
THREATS SORRY COULDN'T RESIST
MORE PLEASE BE AWARE THAT BY
LEGIONS OF THESE RULES MAY BE
SUBJECT TO YOU. BEING REMOVED
FOR FATHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
I'VE ALSO BEEN DIRECTED- BY THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
DISRUPTIONS STARTS WITH PUTTING
DISRUPTION IN THE CONTEXT OF
RELEVANT LAWS AND RULES
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE SECTION
FOUR THREE AND GOVERNMENT COAT
NINE ZERO FIVE ONE MAKE IT A
MISDEMEANOR TO DISRUPT AND
ASSEMBLY MEETING. ASSEMBLY
RULES. TEN TWENTY SIX THIRTY
THREE AND ONE OH EIGHT POINT
ONE PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK FOR
PRESIDING OFFICERS AND CHAIRS
TO MAINTAIN ORDER AND DECORUM
IN ASSEMBLY PROCEEDINGS THESE
LAWS RULES PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR CHAIRS MOVING
FORWARD THE CHAIR HAS THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ENFORCING THESE RULES AGAINST
DISRUPTION. TO ENSURE THAT ALL
VOICES CAN BE HEARD ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS SHALL ASSIST THE
CHAIR AT THE CHAIRS DIRECTION
PROCESS PROCESS TO PROCEED TO
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR. THE CHAIR
ONE TEACHER MAINTAIN CONTROL OF
THE HEARING BY RESPONDING
IMMEDIATELY AND CONSISTENTLY TO
CONTACT IT DISRUPTS. DISTURBS
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE
REMOVING THE MASK AND REFUSING
TO PUT IT ON. BE TAKING OR
MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE C. R. A. LAUT.
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
D. SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE
TIME ALLOWED IT. HE EXTENDED
THIS DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF A
HEARING OR BILL. AND HAVE OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS TO IF A PERSON
ENGAGES IN DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
THE CHAIR SHALL WARN THE PERSON
TO STOP DISRUPTING THE HEARING
OR THAT PERSON MAY BE REMOVED.
IN ADDITION TO CHAIR MADE DO
ONE OR MORE OF THE FOLLOWING.
GAVELED THE HEARING TO ORDER.
B. PRESS THE PRIORITY BUTTON TO
SILENCE ON MICROPHONES C. MOVE
TO THE NEXT CALL WHEN PHONE AND
TESTIMONY BECAUSE TO FRACTION
OR MOVE TO CALL IN. TESTIMONY
IF THE DESTRUCTION OCCURS IN
THE HEARING ROOM D. RECESSED TO
REGAIN CONTROL OF THE HEARING.
THREE BIG CHEER MAY CONSULT
WITH CHIEF SERGEANT OR HER
DESIGNATE A SECURITY SUPERVISOR
DETERMINE WHETHER TO TRUST THE
PERSON SHALL BE REMOVED AT ANY
POINT. NUMBER FOUR IF REMOVAL
IS APPROVED BY THE CHAIR THE
CHAIR MAY DECIDE TO CONTINUE TO
HEARING OR TAKE A RECESS TO
ALLOW SERGEANTS TO RESTORE
ORDER. B. THE CHAIR SHALL MAKE
CLEAR ON THE RECORD WHICH
CONTACT IN WHICH PERSON IS
DISRUPTING THE PROCEEDING. SEE
THE CHAIRMAN HAS TO START IS TO
REMOVE TO DISRUPT A PERSON D.
D. CHAIR MAKES STATE LET'S MOVE
ON OR- TAKE. TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS E. THE SERGEANTS SHALL
ESCORT DISRUPTIVE PERSON OUT OF
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. AN THEN
LASTLY WITNESSES TODAY. OP WILL
SPEAK FROM THE MICROPHONE WITH
SERGEANTS STANDING NOW WHICH
IS. DOT TO MY LEFT AND TO YOUR
RIGHT- AT THE MICROPHONE STAND
JUPITER. SO WITH THAT. WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM JUST YET SO
WE WILL BEGIN AT AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. AND SO THE FIRST.
ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS SPECIAL
ORDER NUMBER ONE SB SEVEN FOUR
TWO PAN ACTION NATION SITES
UNLAWFUL ACTION UNLAWFUL
PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTION
INTIMIDATION OR PICKING
PICKETING AND IT HAS AN URGENCY
CLAUSE TO. DR PAN CENTER PANEL
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU CHAIR
AT THANK YOU MEMBERS- OFFICIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO A BILL THAT BALANCES
ARE RIGHT TO ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. PRIVACY AND FREEDOM OF
SPEECH. FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE OVER THE PAST
FEW WEEKS AND I'M OF COURSE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SO THANK
YOU. FOR OVER A YEAR WE'VE
WORKED SIDE BY SIDE TO FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE AND DATA TO SAVE AS
MANY LIVES AS POSSIBLE DURING
THE COAT. NINETEEN OFTEN AT A
COST TO OTHER PARTS OF
COMMUNITY AND LIFE. IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW OF OVER
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION CASES
A CO BID AND UNFORTUNATELY.
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND DEATHS.
WE'VE EXPERIENCED THE PAIN OF
TRYING TO GRIEVE FOR LOVED ONES
FROM THE FARD STRAIN. ON
FAMILIES TO WORK OFTEN FROM
HOME SUPPORT THEIR CHILDREN'S
LEARNING THROUGH A COMPUTER TO
STRUGGLE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
PUSH TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN
EVEN WHEN CUSTOMERS CAN COME IN
AND THE WORSHIP VIRTUALLY KEEP
EACH OTHER SAFE IN FACT LAST
NIGHT WE TOOK ACTIONS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS. THESE ISSUES. ALL OF
THE SACRIFICE THAT WE'VE BEEN
GIVEN IT'S BEEN ABOUT BUYING
TIME TO FIND THE MEDICAL
BREAKTHROUGHS WHAT SCIENCE
COULD HELP US BRING AN END TO
THE DARK MOMENT STAFF CALLED
US. GIVE MORE THAN WE EVER
THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE.
THANKFULLY BECAUSE OF DECADES
OF RESEARCH AND SCIENCE RON
IMMUNOLOGY. WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
BRING THIS PANDEMIC TO A CLOSE.
WE'RE FINALLY. STARTING TO
SAFELY REOPEN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT THAT OPPORTUNITY MAYBE A
LOSS IF WE DON'T GET ENOUGH
PEOPLE VACCINATED. AND WHILE
THE FEDERAL STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING BETTER
AND BETTER EACH DAY AND
DISTRIBUTING COVER NINETEEN
VACCINES IN EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC. ABOUT THE NEED FOR THE
VACCINE. FORTUNATELY ANTI
VACCINE EXTREMISTS THAT WE ARE
ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH EVEN VERY
HERE IN THIS VERY BUILDING.
HAVE BEEN ESCALATING WITH THE
DISRUPTIVE TACTICS. TO STOP AND
DISRUPT THESE EFFORTS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS. AND
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING YOU
SUPPORT SB SEVEN FORTY TWO SO
WE CAN MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
STILL HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICE FREE SPEECH. AND WE
CAN MAKE SURE PUBLIC OFFICIALS
HAVE MORE TOOLS TO ENSURE
PATIENTS SO OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND FRONTLINE WORKERS A VACCINE
CLINICS ARE SAFE THEMSELVES
SOME INTIMIDATION HARASSMENT
AND PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTION. MANY
OF YOU HAVE BEEN AWARE OF THE
SHUTDOWN OF THE VACCINE CLINIC
IN JANUARY AT DODGER STADIUM.
WHERE A MOB OF ANTI VACCINE
EXTREMISTS STOP THE CLINIC FROM
OPERATING JEOPARDIZING THE
SAFETY OF PATIENTS AND
FRONTLINE WORKERS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT A
SINGLE. EPISODE THESE
EXTREMISTS ARE CONDUCTING
SIMILAR OPERATIONS ALL OVER THE
STATE OFTEN TRYING TO BLEND IN
AS FRONT LINE WORKERS
INDESTRUCTIBLE RATIONS AND EVEN
RESORT TO TACTICS LIKE
TARGETING FARMWORKERS JIMMY'S
THERE ALREADY BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY COVE IN NINETEEN
AND NEED THE VACCINE THE MOST.
ADDITIONALLY WELL WE ARE JUST
GIVING VACCINES IN MANY
TRADITIONAL HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS LIKE HOSPITALS AND
DOCTORS OFFICES PHARMACIES. WE
ALSO KNOW WE NEED TO USE
NONTRADITIONAL SITE LOCATIONS
WE NEED TO GO OUT COMMUNITIES
BE ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES PARKING
LOTS PERHAPS- MALLS OTHER TYPES
OF PLACES WHERE WE- ARE-
CREATING. NEW LOGISTICAL
SITUATIONS THAT MIGHT BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS. THE OPPONENTS
OF THE BILL WELL ARGUED OR
TRIED TAKE AWAY FREE SPEECH
HOWEVER THIS IS A FALSE CHOICE
THEY WANT TO BOXES INTO. WE
CERTAINLY CAN CREATE PROPERTIES
OF FREE SPEECH AND ENSURE
PEOPLE OF ACCESS TO VACCINES
FREE FROM INTIMIDATION. AND
BOSS OF THE PRIVACY. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I'M PLEASED TO
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE TESTIFIED CATHERINE MARTIN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MUSICIAN
COALITION AND HERE PRESENT TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON BENJAMIN SELL
UP. TO NAVIGATE REPRESENTING
GENERATION UP ESPECIALLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND YOU HAVE- TWO WITNESSES
UGH. FIVE MINUTES TOTAL THAT
WILL SPEAK I HAVE A CATHERINE
FLORES MARTIN WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S IMMUNIZATION
COALITION THAT'S ONE BY PHONE.
AND A BENJAMIN SAY LAW STUDENT.
ADVOCATE WHICH GEN UP. SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE IN PERSON WHO CAN
SPEAK FROM THE MICROPHONE THANK
IN NEEDS THEIR- MR SAY WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO FIRST
CENTURY HERE IN ROME. PLEASE
THANK YOU. GET CLOSER TO THE
MIKE OKAY ARE YOU IN UTAH
ALRIGHT. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
AS THE MEMBERS OF THE STAFF AT
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC. SAFETY MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN SALEM AND I AM A
STUDENT LIVING IN B. FIFTY THE
FAMILY DISTRICT. I TEND TO OPEN
A TECHNICAL HIGH SCHOOL IN
OAKLAND I THINK YOU ON BEHALF
OF CHEN APPLE TO THE STEELERS.
COULD YOU SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE SURE GAVE THAT'S A
LARGE BRICK I AM NOT ON BEHALF
OF JENNIFER ADVOCATING FOR
STUDENT EDUCATION REFORM.
KUWAIT HAS. NEARLY ALL PASS OF
HOW EDUCATION. STUDENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING FULL OR HYBRIDIZE
ONLINE SCHOOL AND NOT CRUCIAL
INTERACTION WITH THE CLASSMATES
AND EDUCATORS. I PREVENTING IN
PERSON EDUCATION THE PANDEMIC
HAS IMPEDED MEANINGFUL LEARNING
EXACERBATING THE EDUCATIONAL
DIVIDE. THIS SPRING I RECEIVED
THE HONOR OF BEING OFFERED WITH
THE FIGHTER BY WINTERKORN ABOUT
STOCKS NATION. TO BE HONEST
RECEIVING A SHOT WITH A PRETTY
EMOTIONAL MOMENT FOR ME AND
MANY OTHER STUDENTS. OUT OF
BACKING IS KEY TO US REGAINING
A SEMBLANCE OF NORMAL THING
NEXT YEAR. I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO RETURN TO SCHOOL NEXT YEAR
AND COME TO THE CAPITAL FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE. BUT
RIGHT NOW I'M RIGHT NOW WE KNOW
THAT SCHOOLS ARE HANGING ON BY
A THREAD. THE PANDEMIC IS
WINNING BUT IT'S NOT OVER. I
KNOW THE RIGHTS TO PREVENT TEEN
VARIANTS AND STOCKING
VACCINATION RATES. ARE IN
KEEPING MY RETURN TO CLASS MANY
OF MY PEERS WERE FORMALLY
ECSTATIC TO RECEIVE THEIR SHOTS
ARE NOW HESITANT BECAUSE OF
ACTIVE. INTERACTING EXTREMISM
AND. PRESSURING BY PEOPLE OUR
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF THIS IT
OF MY FOR. INTO IT LOOKS NATION
RATES BETWEEN TWELVE AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS HOW ARE YOU
DECIDED TO RETAIN AN ONLINE
ONLY SCHOOL. MISSING OUT ON THE
CRUCIAL EDUCATIONAL ACCESS. I
ALSO A NUMBER OF ANY TO
COMPROMISE FRIENDS AND
CLASSMATES AND EVERY SHOT
DECLINING CALIFORNIA. THREATENS
THEIR HEALTH. EDUCATION IS ONE
OF THE INTEGRAL RIGHTS IN
MODERN SOCIETY BUT OUR ABILITY
TO RECEIVE A STATE OF EDUCATION
ACTION TRYING TO THE
INTERNATIONAL COVENANT ON
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
RIGHTS. IS BEING IMPEDED BY
ANTI VACCINE EXTREMISTS. IS
EXTREMISM IS HARASSING AND
ATTACKING CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVING A CRUCIAL VACCINES.
THE RIGHT TO RECEIVE
VACCINATION WITHOUT THREAT TO
OUR SAFETY OUR PRIVACY AND OUR
HEALTH IS INTEGRAL WITHOUT IT
WE CANNOT RECOVER ECONOMICALLY
AND SOCIALLY. I SUPPORT SB
SEVEN FOUR TWO BECAUSE IT
PROTECTS OUR ABILITY TO GET THE
VACCINE SAFELY BUT THE THREAT
OF ANTI VACCINE HARASSMENT INTO
INTIMIDATION. I SUPPORT SB
SEVEN FOUR TO CHECK THE PRIVACY
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS PERCEIVE
THIS CRUCIAL SHOT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AN OPERATOR HERE YOU
HAVE KATHERINE FLORES MARTIN ON
THE PHONE. YES GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN CLARK MARTIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIMTATION COALITION
AND WE WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR MANY YEARS AND CREATING
STRONG AND EFFECTIVE LAWS THE
RESULTS AND PROTECTING MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS. ANY PARTICULAR
CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS FROM
PREVENTABLE DISEASES. THIS YEAR
WE KNOW HAS BEEN REALLY HARD ON
CHILDEN AND FAMILIES WITH
SCHOOLS CLOSED IN SEPARATION
FROM TEACHERS AND FRIENDS. AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOLS
ARE GEARING UP TO TAPER YOU'LL
PLEASE CALL. PRODUCT OF ACTING
CHILDREN TWELVE YEARS NOTHING
KOBE WILL BE HELD OVER THE
SUMMER AND THE FALL AND WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE GUIDELINES
WOULD BE ESTABLISHED BY SB
SEVEN PORT YOU ARE PART OF
THAT. IF YOU PLAN. WHAT CLINICS
OR HEALTH. IMMUNIZED AND
FAMILIES WHO CHOOSE TO
VACCINATE. THEY SHOULD NOT BE
OBSTRUCTED OR THREATENED BY
PROTESTERS THE CONTENT. THE
MONTANA LOOKS RECENTLY PICTURES
WERE ACTUALLY FOLLOWING TEENAGE
STUDENTS ON THE SIDEWALK NEAR
SCHOOL GROUNDS. TO ARGUE THEIR
CASE AGAINST ACTING. AS A
PARENT I FIND THE FOR FINE. THE
ANSWER THAT THE NETWORK FOR.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE MEDIA
ABOUT MATH AND ASKING. FOR
ACTIVITIES RANGE FROM SETTING
UP CABLES WITH ANTI BLACK
LITERATURE TO PROTEST IN
COUGHING BUT MATH FACTS
CLINICS. SOME OF YOU WITNESSED
THE SCREEN BRIGHTNESS IN THE
NATION FROM GROUP THERAPY
CAPITAL ONE BILL RELATED. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HURT. IT'S HARD
FOR US TO WATCH BUT IMAGINE
BEING ISSUED CHILD OR TEEN AT A
CLINIC. THAT'S. COMFORTABLE AND
FRIGHTENING. I WOULD ON THAT
ALL OF THE OVER TWELVE YEARS
WOULD NEVER LIKE THIS BEFORE.
IN THE PAST MONTH OF WHO TOOK
PAINS HEARING OFFICE AND WAS.
OPPOSE TURN PERFECT EVENTS HE
SOMETIMES DANGEROUS OF. IT'S
NOT LIKE THESE PROTESTS THE
CENTER OUR SCHOOL AND
NEIGHBORHOOD YOU NEED TO PAY IN
CLINIC. SO WE CAN AND WILL
THREE OF SPEECH BUT YOU SO IS
THAT UTMOST. OUR CHILDREN AND-
HAVE BEEN. UP THEY NEED SCHOOL
I MEAN IT IT STATE PLACE YEAH
THIS COURT. THANK YOU FOUR
MINUTES AND TWENTY NINE SECONDS.
RIGHT UNDER. NOW IN THE ROOM
FORTY OH TWO THIS IS FOR SURE.
FOR ANY MAY. INDIA AND FORTY OH
TWO. THE CAPITAL BUILDING.
THERE WOULD LIKE TO SAY THEIR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION
APARTMENT. IN SUPPORT. NOW YOU
GOTTA CARRILLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALLISON CHAN I'M A
STUDENT IN THE TWENTY SECOND
DISTRICT AND A MEMBER
GENERATION UP AND I SUPPORT SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS IN FORTY TWO OH TWO IN
SUPPORT. DID BRING IT BACK TO
THE- ANY MEMBERS INDEED IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM- IN SUPPORT. C.
N. NINE UP EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF- SB.
SEVEN FOUR TWO. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN FOUR
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY I HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY TWO IN Q. WILL
START WITH LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIS MERE
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO- I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL- THE VACCINES ARE NOT
VACCINES THEIR MRNA
EXPERIMENTAL TECHNOLOGY AN
ORGANIZATION BANKABLE ALSO
OUGHT TO BE HARMFUL NAME IS
ATION NECK. BUDGET YEAH
MEXICANA FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SYDNEY ADDITION. TO ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE ALIGN
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
ACTUALLY. AND THEN DRAWN. IT'S
A- FOR YOUR I THINK I'M IN A
LONG YEAR OKAY THANK YOU YOU'RE
COMING UP NOW THANK YOU LINE
ONE HUNDRED. ONE ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD.
PHILIPPINE WOULD HELP NOT IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND WELLNESS.
STARTING OVER TWO MILLION
MEMBERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. AT THE ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LAURA. TWENTY AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE COMMUNITY. AND I MEAN
DRAWING OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MA'AM. THIS IS IN SUPPORT THANK
TO THIS IS IN SUPPORT I'M
SORRY. I'M JUST SAYING AND
GENERAL MANAGEMENT THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IS NEXT SO
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY SO
EVERYONE IT'S IN SUPPORT THAT'S
ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW THIS IS
YOUR UP TO NEED TO SPEAK.
OPPOSITION WILL COME IN JUST A
LITTLE BIT. DO I PLAY ON THE
LINE YEAH. YOU FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. NOW PLAYING TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR BIT GO
HEAD. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM ACTUALLY AGAIN. NOT
WORSE SO I'M IN FOR THE NEXT
ROUND. OKAY THE NEXT CALLER.
THANK TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I WAS
I'M ALSO IN OPPOSITION I HAVE A
FEW WORDS WITH MICHELLE BACK
INJURY AWARENESS YOU CAN COME
IN THE NEXT. ROUND. CRYING TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY A LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ABOUT A LACK TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WOULD ALSO PUT
DOWNLOAD SUPPORT YOU BUT I'M AN
OPTIMIST. OKAY BUT I TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHILE I'M ALSO
NOT POSITION I DON'T KNOW HOW
THE SYSTEM WORKS JUMPED. ON THE
OKAY YOU CAN COME IN LIKE.
ABOUT ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M ALSO AN
UPDATE THE NEXT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
KATIE SATAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORTED BY
FORTY SEVEN FORTY KILL THANK
YOU. ALTHOUGH LINE. TO EIGHTY
THREE. I AM ALSO NOT THE- THANK
NEXT CALLER. DO I NEED TO WAIT
YES IT WILL GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTY- I TOLD THE OPERATOR
THAT I WAS IN OPPOSITION I'VE
NOT SURE WHERE WHERE WE'RE ALL
BEING PUT IN THE QUEUE AND-
WE'RE STARTING TO BE CONSIDERED
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET A
HOLD. I'M NOT SURE WHY THIS
HAPPENED WILL GO TO. WE'LL GO
TO LINE. THIRTY NINE. NINE
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. TWO SIXTY
NINE. NINE TWO SIX NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SORRY I'M NOT
OKAY. YOU. WE'LL GO ON TO LINE
TO FORTY ONE. TWO FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS R. HUNTER CLEANING I'M A
STUDENT AMBASSADOR ROUTINES
RELAXING CALLING ON BEHALF
STUDENTS TOMORROW TO VOICE MY
STRONG SUPPORT IT'S BUILT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME. FOR A VACCINE AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF STATE
COULD PUSH FOR STRONGER SUPPORT
FOR THE- THANK YOU. ALTHOUGH
LINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY KING AND
I'M A STUDENT AT UCLA AND A
MEMBER OF UNIVERSITIES ALLIED
FOR ESSENTIAL MEDICINES I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS
TO VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ALTHOUGH
LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALEX SONG
COMES IN WITH SOME **** LOOKING
TEAM FOR ACTION I'M CALLING ON
THE BEHALF OF STUDENTS TO BY
CHRIS ROCK THE PARK PLAZA.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO ON TO LINE
ONE. TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
CARRILLO AND AS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YEAH I WILL GO ON TO LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
WORK. IT BORN UP. REPRESENT NOT
AND WE APPRECIATE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN
STRONG WHAT. I WILL GO TO LINE
TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DR DONALD LINEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
PREVENTIVE MEDICINE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. GO
AHEAD I'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS REASSURED IN A MACHINE
THAT UCLA AND NUMBER OF
UNIVERSITIES ALLIED FOR
ESSENTIAL MEDICINES I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS TO VOICE
MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ON THE LINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS. HI MY NAME IS RED WATCH FOR
THE MINOR I'M A STUDENT
AMBASSADOR TEAM BAXEEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF. THE
FORMAT STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. CONGER LINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I AM ACTUALLY IN THE
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU. ONE TWO EIGHT
SEVENTY LINE IN OPEN I'M IN THE
OFFICE AND YOU HAVE LOVED.
WE'LL GO ON TO LINE TO GOING TO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M
SORRY I OPPOSE- ON APRIL TO
TAKE A APPROACH- WELL GO AHEAD
AND GO TO LINE TWO FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COME UP WITH
THE OPPOSITION WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS OUR CHARGE THE
STUDENTS AND THE FOUNDER OF THE
ORGANIZATION KEEP CRACKING I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS
HIS VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. I WILL GO TO LINE
TWO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M A COMPOSITION. WE'LL-GO TO LINE TWO NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
MERRY HOW IT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI. I'M NATALIE
ALLEN SAN DIEGO THE THIRD FIGHT
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONER ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND ALL MY
TEAM. SURE IT'S CLEAR OPPOSED
TO AT ALL AND- OKAY TO LINE
THREE OH PLEASE GO. THREE OH TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M IN
SOLIDARITY WITH REAL CONCERNED
YEAR GOAL KEEPERS OF NUMBER
CODE A FAMOUS DOCTOR OKAY NOW
DAMON ORGANIZATION YOU FOR OUR
OPPOSED. NO I'M REPRESENTING
REAL PRESENTABLE MANY OTHER
DECISIONS WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THREE OR FIVE. NEXT ELEVEN
THIRTY REAL PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS IN THE
LOBBY SENATE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TEACHER
OF TWENTY THREE YEAR AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. WELL TO ALIGN NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M WITH THE
OPPOSITION. NEXT CALLER. YEP I
GOT A LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON. TO
THREE FIFTEEN ONE THREE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I STRONGLY MY NAME IS
THE NEED TO THINK OF ALL AND
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO CALL GO TO
LINE TWO TWENTY SIX. FIND TO
TWENTY SIX EUROPEN. I'M SORRY
I'M NOT COLLECTED. YEP WELL GO
TO LINE THREE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. I THINK
WE LOST. HELLO OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COURTNEY NEED A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL WILL GO TO LINE THREE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MATTHEW WRONGLY OPPOSED
BOTH THE BORDERLINE OF THREE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SHANNON I CURRENTLY
HAVE OPPOSE WE'LL GO TO THREE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FIVE ANAKIN COUNTY SHOT
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL WILL GO TO
TWO SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S CLAUDIA
ADDRESS UNLESS SIGNED WITH LOS
ANGELES AND I OPPOSE THE BILL
PLEASE LET ME A LITTLE LINE
THREE FIFTY POLITICAL OPERATOR.
BUT LET ME MAKE A SUGGESTION.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE AGAIN
OPPOSE AND- AND FLORIDA SUPPORT
OPPOSED. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
LISTEN TO THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE I GUESS ON THE LAWN THERE
OUTSIDE BETTER SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSE GET THEM OUT OF THE WAY.
AND THEN. LISTEN TO THE
WITNESSES I THINK WE HAVE A
MATTHEW. MAKE REYNOLDS FROM THE
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE AND
JOSHUA COLEMAN WITH THE FOR
VACCINE LISTEN TO THEIR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. AND THEN
JUST LET EVERYBODY JUST COME IN
OPPOSE IN AND JUST DO IT ALL AT
ONE TIME OTHERWISE THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT SAID OPPOSE ARE
GONNA COME BACK AGAIN WILL BE
DOING. DOUBLE DUTY SO THAT
THAT'S- LET'S JUST DO IT THAT
WAY SO RIGHT NOW THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING FOR SOME PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING THAT MAY
WANT TO TESTIFY. AND WE NEED TO
OPEN UP THOSE LINES DIG IT
LEASE GET THEM. BECAUSE THEY'RE
OUTSIDE YOU MIGHT GET HOT WE
NEED TO HEAR TESTIMONY. ON BOTH
SIDES FOR AND AGAINST THAT WAY
WE- GET THEM DONE. HI I'M
RACHEL GATES FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I DROVE ALL THE WAY UP HERE
JUST TO SAY I OPPOSE DISAGREE
JUSTLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL.
NEXT OUTSIDE. AGAIN IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE OUTSIDE OF
THE CAPITAL ON THE LINE. FOR
AND AGAINST OKAY SO- MY NAME IS
MIKE MATTINGLY I'M WITH THE
FUNKY FATHER'S ORGANIZATION I
REPRESENT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MILLION PEOPLE ON THE PLANET
IT'S AMAZING. AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL- BECAUSE WE LIVE IN
THE DORM CONTINUES AND I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHO ARE THE SAME
EASY TO SEE IF WE CAN STILL BE
FREE. SO.
ANYONE ELSE OUT ON
THE LAWN. HELLO MY NAME'S DAN
COLLIER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH STAND WHAT
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH. OKAY
NEXT.
THE DECISION SUBSTITUTION
OF THE CONFERENCE ROOM PEOPLE
ARE OUT ON THE LINE NOW THAT
WITH MY UNDERSTANDING. CHAU
WHO'S EVER. IN CHARGE OF HAVING
PEOPLE TESTIFY IN LAWN. ARE YOU
DONE IT WAS THAT IT. THREE MORE.
THERE'S NO MORE TESTIMONY OUT
HERE BECAUSE OKAY THANK YOU- SO.
WE'RE REAL ESTABLISH A QUORUM
RIGHT NOW MA'AM SECTOR CRITICAL
ROLE. JONES SAWYER HERE LACKING
POWER CAN LEAD. WORK HERE
SANTIAGO SEE OUR TEMPERATURE
WICKS. EVERYONE PRESENT IF YOU
IF YOU JUST BEAR WITH ME- WE
HAVE A PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
THREE TWENTY EGGMAN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROTECTIVE ORDERS
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWO ONE FIVE
LEYVA IN DNA EVIDENCE ITEM
NUMBER TEN. S. B. TWO NINE SIX
LAMORNE COMMENT OUT CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SAFETY
STANDARDS AND ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B. TWENTY THREE RUBIO
DISORDERLY CONDUCT DESTRUCTORS
TRADITION OF INTIMATE IMAGES
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS. THE
SUPPORT PROCOPE CONSETT
COUNTERINTUITIVE. IN A SECOND
THAT WAS ITEMS FIVE SEVEN NINE
AND TEN NO SIX SIX EIGHT YOURS
SO HANS SIX IS SB THREE FIFTY
EIGHT. IDM SIX FIND MY ITEM SIX
SAYS. TWENTY THREE TWENTY OH
INTERESTING NINE DOESN'T JUST
REFRESHED IT TOO SO ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SOSUS ITEM SIX EIGHT TEN
ELEVEN UP FOR AUCTION. MAGICTR
CALL THE ROLL JONES SAWYER. HI
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY
HI BARRICADE HAN LI LI I WORK.
CORRECT I SANTIAGO THE
TERRIFIED I LICKS WHICH I.
CONSENT COUNTIES ADOPTED AND
THEN FOR INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES
OFF CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB TWO BRADFORD PEACE
OFFICER CERTIFICATION CIVIL
RIGHTS POOL BY COMMITTEE. AND
WITH THAT READ NOW WILL HAVE
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MATTHEW MAKE RENTALS THE
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE HE'LL
BE IN BY PHONE. AND JOSHUA
COLEMAN V. IS FOR A VACCINE
WHO'S HERE IN PERSON FROM WHAT
I UNDERSTAND. YOU MAKE GO TO
THE BIKE WILL WILL BEGIN WITH
THE IN PERSON. IN PERSON
TESTIMONY HERE TO REJECT YOU
BOTH HAVE IS FIVE MINUTES
ALTOGETHER SO WHAT. PLEASE
LEAVE SOME TIME FOR. COMMITMENT
RENTALS. HI MY NAME IS JOSHUA
COLEMAN AND I'M A CO FOUNDER OF
V. IS FOR VACCINE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST VACCINE RISK PUBLIC
EDUCATION ORGANIZATION. WHAT WE
DO SPECIFICALLY IS PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND FACT BASED
MESSAGING TO ACTIVISTS ACROSS
THE WORLD THAT WANT TO GO OUT
AND EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT
THE REAL RISKS OF VACCINATION.
LIKE EVERYTHING IN THIS WORLD
VACCINES OF DO HAVE A RISK AND
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLETO
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING INTO
BEFORE CONSENTING. THE NEWS
ORGANIZATION PROJECT VERITAS
RECENTLY HAD MULTIPLE
WHISTLEBLOWERS FROM FACEBOOK.
COME FORWARD EXPOSING INTERNAL
DOCUMENTS SHOWING THAT FACEBOOK
ACTIVELY CENSORS CONTENT THAT
IS CONSIDERED VACCINE HESITANT.
MEANING THEY CENSOR ANYTHING
THAT IS CONSIDERED NEGATIVE
ABOUT VACCINATION. OR COULD
MAKE A PERSON VACCINE HESITANT.
AND FACEBOOK SPECIFIED IN THESE
DOCUMENTS THEY DO THIS WHETHER
THE INFORMATION IS TRUE OR NOT.
I BELIEVE THE ACTUAL INTENTION
OF THIS BILL IS AN EXTENSION OF
THE SAME CENSORSHIP THAT IS
HAPPENING ON FACEBOOK AND OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. I DO
NOT THINK THIS BILL HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH PEOPLE
INTIMIDATING OR BULLYING PEOPLE
AT VACCINATION AREAS. THE
INCIDENT THAT CENTER PAN KEEPS
BRINGING UP AT DODGER STADIUM
DID NOT HAVE ACTIVISTS BLOCKING
THE ENTRANCE. THE CHIEF OF
POLICE IN L. A. COUNTY MADE IT
A POINT TO ISSUE A PUBLIC
STATEMENT AFTERWARDS SAYING THE
PROTESTS DID NOT SHUT DOWN THE
VACCINATION SITE. ALL
APPOINTMENTS WERE MET. EVEN CNN
SAID THE GATHERING WAS PEACEFUL
NO ARRESTS WERE MADE. SENATOR
PAN HAS SHOWED HIS CARDS HERE
BY DEFINING THE WORD HARASS IN
SB SEVEN FOUR TWO. AS
EDUCATION. DISPLAYING A SIGN TO
FOR PASSING A LEAFLET OR HAND
BILL. THOSE THREE THINGS ARE
NOT HARASSING. IF SOMEONE TAKES
A FLYER FROM AN ACTIVIST IT IS
ACCEPTED. NO ONE CAN FORCE THE
FLYER ON TO SOMEONE AND FORCE
THEM TO READ IT WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL WALKS AWAY WITH THE
FLYER FROM ONE OF OUR
ACTIVISTS. IT'S BECAUSE THEY OF
THEIR OWN FREE WILL HAVE
ACCEPTED IT. THE BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING. I BELIEVE THE TRUE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS TO
JUST LIKE FACEBOOK BLOCKED THE
DISSEMINATION OF INFORMATION ON
VACCINE RISK DESPITE ITS
VALIDITY. IF THIS IS NOT THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL I WOULD
KINDLY ASK THE AUTHOR TO REMOVE
THE PART THAT DEFINES
HARASSMENT. AS EDUCATION.
DISPLAYING A SIGN TO AND
PASSING A LEAFLET OR HAND BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. IS TO
MAKE BACKGROUND. THE PHONE YET
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BASS MAKE REYNOLDS IN
THE HALF- PACIFIC JUSTICE
INSTITUTE'S CENTER FOR PUBLIC
POLICY- FIRST WANT TO COMMEND
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
RECOGNIZING A NUMBER OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBLEMS WITH-
THE BILL AS IT EXISTED PRIOR TO
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- FALL FAR SHORT OF
CURING THE SIGNIFICANT AND
CONSTITUTIONALITY THAT WE FIND
IN THIS BILL. IT IS
SUBSTANTIALLY OVERBROAD WE SEEN
IT SHIFTING RATIONALES WHERE IT
BEGAN BY RELYING ON FUNERAL
PROTEST LAWS AND NOW HAS
SHIFTED TO- LARGELY ABORTION
RELATED JURISPRUDENCE AND BUT
EVEN IN RELATION TO THE
ABORTION CLINICS THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT HAS NEVER UPHELD
A BUFFER ZONE AS RESTRICTIVE AS
THE ONE NOW BEFORE THIS BODY.
NOR AT TO UNDERSCORE THE POINT
MADE BY THE PRIOR OPPOSITION
WITNESS HAS A SUPREME COURT
EVER COME CLOSE TO UPHOLDING A
DEFINITION OF HARASSED THAT IS
AKIN TO THE ONE BEING PUT
FORWARD TO THIS COMMITTEE NOW
AT THIS BILL WOULD REACH FAR
BEYOND THE COVERT CRISIS WOULD
REACH FAR BEYOND IT BEING
ALLEGED HARM IS ITS PURPORTED
BASIS AND WHAT EVEN RESTRICT-
EVERYTHING FROM LABOR PROTEST
TO BLACK LIVES MATTER PROTEST
ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISM. AS WELL
AS PRO LIFE SPEECH OUTSIDE OF
CLINICS AS WELL AS IN
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC FORUMS WE
JUST URGE THE COMMITTEE IN
CLOSING TO LISTEN BEYOND THE
EMOTIONS AND THE HEATED
RHETORIC THAT OFTEN CAN
ACCOMPANY THIS TOPIC AND TO
LOOK CLOSELY AT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS BILL
AND- WE BELIEVE YOU'LL. FIND
THAT THIS MEASURE CANNOT
SURVIVING THE COR AND SHOULD BE
THERE FOR RICH THAT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MCREYNOLDS MISTER COLEMAN YOUR
WITHIN THE FIVE MINUTES OR
COMMITTEE APPRECIATES THAT UP
WE NOW WILL GO. TO THE PHONE
LINES WELL. WELL AS WE SHOULD
GO IN THE ROOM FOR OPPOSITION-
THEN GO TO THE MIGHT STATE YOUR
NAME. AND ORGANIZATION ONLY
FOUR PEOPLE WERE IN FORTY TWO
OH TWO RIGHT NOW THEY WANT TO
VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION. TO SB
SEVEN FOUR TWO. RIGHT MY NAME
IS A GREAT BURKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR HAVE A GOOD. MY
NAME IS JULIE HOMOTOPIC I'M
WITH AMERICAN FRONT LINE
DOCTORS OF CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM. YES
MY NAME IS NICOLE YANG I'M WITH
AN ORGANIZATION CALLED MOMS FOR
THE GROUP. AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A VIOLATION
OF OUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. HIGHLY SHOW
HERNANDEZ I'M A NURSE OF THIRTY
YEARS VACCINE INJURED CHILD I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED OF THIS
BILL. AND IT IS STUMBLING ALL
OVER OUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT
HE'S. HI MY NAME IS DANIELLE
AND I'M OF MANY LIKE MINDED
PEOPLE AND I AM VERY AFRAID OF
THIS. HORRENDOUS BILL ON IT I
VALUE MY THANK YOU MA'AM AND
SIR YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSE THANK
YOU. BOLIVIA MICHAEL'S CO
FOUNDER OF YOUR CERVIX SCENE I
OPPOSE THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DON PACE AND
I AM A PUBLIX RETIRED PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER OF OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AND- OF LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS OF THIS COMMUNITY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SENATE BILL
SEVEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. MY
NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRONG. AND
MY AFFILIATION IS. A VACCINE
INJURED PERSON MOTHER OF 41100%
VACCINE FREE CHILDREN AND DICK
PAN YOU NEVER TOUCH THEM THERE.
THE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO- TO IN
OPPOSITION. DAN I BELIEVE HER
ALL THE WITNESSES I OUTSIDE
INSIDE THE ROOM ON THE
TELEPHONE IS LEFT. SO AT AND T.
OPERATOR- WHETHER YOU'RE-
SUPPORT PROPOSED STATE WHERE
YOU'RE SUPPORTER OPPOSED YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION SO WE
ADDED ONE MORE BUT WE JUST FOR
BLENDING TE TWO LET'S GO HERE
AND HEAR FROM. PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CALLED IN THAT WANTED TO STATE
WHETHER THEY'RE FOR OR AGAINST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION LET'S GIVE
THAT A TRY. AT&T OPERATOR
TOPCOAT. WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM HUSSEIN FROM REAL
CONCERNED YOU KNOW THE CLOSEST.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT. LEVINE AT
TWO THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS CHRISTY ACRE
I REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF-
AMERICANS IN THE MAKE AMERICA
FREE AGAIN GROUP- WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL ADDS IT THANK
IN ADVANCE OUR PRE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE CHIU FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY BAD APOLOGIES WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME'S KRISTINA HOW THE BRAND-
AND IT PROBABLY PROTECT
ADVOCACY WE HAVE PAID THE BILL
AND COST PERFECT AMENDMENT HER
ART LECTURE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES- I'M
CALLING IN ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
IS AUTHORIZED TO VACCINE AND
THE DISTRESS DISTRIBUTION OF IT
THIS BILL IS THANK YOU. AGAIN
AREN'T RIGHT. YEAH I'D LIKE.
DIED AGAINST THE TO U. T. NEXT
CALL YEP YEP APOLLO. WE ALL
LINED EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KIM SCOTT
WITH PLASTER COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN FOUR
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM-
THAT ALIGNED THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JILL HAWKINS AND FREE SPEECH OF
MADE FOR HARD SPEECH TO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ALTHOUGH LINE THREE THIRTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
HERRINGTON PERFECT SAN DIEGO
COUNTY UP WITH THAT. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN I
REPRESENT TRADITIONAL VALUES
FOR NEXT GENERATION FOR
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE HERE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SEVEN FOUR
TWO. I THANK YOU. WELL TO ALIGN
THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LINDA THAT
YOU NATALIE AND I OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FOUR TWO. BOTH THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT BORDERLINE TWO NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS TYLER BAGLEY I'M A RESIDENT
OF AFTER COUNTY MOTHER OF SIX
CHILDREN AND AYE OPPOSED SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THEY ALL GOT A LINE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME HI
MY NAME IS ADRIAN PASSED WITH
THE AS FAR BACK SEEN EDUCATION
IS NOT HARASSMENT PASSING A
BUYER'S RESTAURANT. SIGN NO ON.
GO TO LINE. SIXTEEN BURKE ONE
SIXTY NINE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SPECIAL CONNOR I AM WITH
PROJECT THAT AND THE CAL
WORKING IN A MINES. WE STRONGLY
IT YEAH THANK YOU SIR. ON THE
OTHER LINE THREE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME ON THE
KAHANA I DIDN'T FEEL A AND I
WOULD RECOMMEND CAN MAKE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
FOUR MA'AM. THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS. CLOSED AT THE SEVENTY
FIFTH THANK YOU MA'AM. WELL TO
ALIGN THREE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
TELL AT. MY NAME IS MERRY WE
WRITER AND DIRECTOR RIGHT WHAT
THE CURRENT COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM. HELLO TO LINE THREE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LONGCLAWS LIBERTY HERE I AM
STRONGLY AGAINST SB SEVEN FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU. WELL ALIGNED
ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SHANNON HEIL THE
DOCTOR ON THE RECALL AND
STANDING UP REBELS RIGHT TODAY
AND I WILL DESCRIBE THE BILL AS
WELL AS CORRUPT AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHERE TO LINE THREE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOYCE LEE I'M AN
EDUCATOR MOTHER OF TWO AND I'M
STRONGLY AGAINST THE DETAIL
ADDED WHICH IS AGAINST OUR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH THANK. NEXT
BUT A LINE THREE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY YEAH OTHER.
THANK ACT FOR A MOMENT TO
CREATE I DON'T BELIEVE I LAND
DURING THE HOLIDAYS AND X.
COLOR GO TO LINE TWO THREE.
WHAT A LINE. THREE EIGHTY FOUR.
PAMELA BERRY AGAIN FROM- L. A.
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU. GO TO LINE
THREE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ALLISON FROM
FREEDOM KEEPERS UNITED AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SELL THANK YOU. WELL
TO ALIGN THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
A LANDLINE THE STATE PRESIDENT
OF BECAUSE I AM A TALENT. AND
ALABAMA BECAUSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE A SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DYLAN. MCCOLLUM
ACCEPTED AT THE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION THE FORTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD EIGHT THE RIGHT INVOLVED
FAN. AND I STRONGLY OF. THANK
YOU HAVE A BILL SEVEN FOUR.
WELL TO ALIGN THREE NINETY.
PLEASE HAVE YOUR NAME HELLO MY
NAME IS HILARY SMITH I'M FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY I
SUPPORT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH EVEN WHEN
IT'S NOT ALIGNED WITH MY
PERSONAL BELIEFS THANK YOU
MA'AM. WELL TO ALIGN THREE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME'S MARLENA DIFFERING I'M
FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THREE
EIGHT IN. BUT WE'RE WRAPPED
REDEFINED AND THE BELL THANK
YOU I OPPOSE THAT THANK YOU.
HELLO LINE TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I OPPOSED THE-
THAT REPORT MY NAME IS JIMMY
HARDER AND FORMED THAT WARRIOR
WITH THE BAND THANK YOU. WHAT
MOVED ALONG FOR HIGH. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LAWRENCE AND I OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. WELL TO ALIGN THREE EIGHTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVEN
WHILE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SMART ACTION COMMITTEE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE THAT
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DURING SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL. YES
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
OKAY NAME AN ORGANIZATION. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WILL MOVE ON TO
THREE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DR JOSEPH IS
NOW A WITH THE INTERACTING
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU SIR. WELL
GO ON TO LINE FOUR OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR IT. YES NAME AN
ORGANIZATION BARRIERS TO THE-
KOLINSKI IGNORANCE FREEDOM
RISING OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT DENIES INFORMED CONSENT.
ALTHOUGH LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE ON THEN TO LINE FOUR OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
TO THE JOCKEY AND A MASSAGE
BEFORE M<c.cyan>. I AM FROM ONLY</c>
THE DINAH WAS A RADICAL
PROVIDENCE FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GET BACK THINK I'D WE GOT
COPYWRITER. NEXT CALLER. ABOUT
A LACK OF ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR BUT. THANK FORTY PARTY
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SUSAN
ARNOLD PLANNING ATTORNEY WITH
THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAD WE ARE
IN STRONG MISSION SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO FOR REASONS
ARTICULATED IN OUR LETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS TRACY ACADEMIA I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
UNDERSTAND- AT THE NINETY NINE
POINT NINETY RECOVERY RATE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
DICK AND YOU VERY LINE SIX
POSSIBLE THAT'S CALLED. THANKS
THIRTY ONE DAYS AGO AT. WHEN HE
WAS CHARLES RANDALL I'M A
PRIVATE CITIZEN I REPRESENT US
CITIZENS IN FAVOR OF THE
CONSTITUTION IN OPPOSING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. FOR NINE THREE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS HEATHER KELLER.
PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THAT'S NOT. MY NAME IS
BETH AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
OPPOSE SEVERAL. ZERO ARE THERE
ANY COMPANY I THINK. YES MA'AM
ABOUT AS CLOSE AND IMITATED.
THANK TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA MURPHY. I'M
CALLING FROM. WHAT THE- AT. THE
SENATE. BUT FOR A GROUP YOUR
BREAKING UP WHAT OKAY THANK YOU.
NOT TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
ALLEGED OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
EDUCATION LIBERTY. OF SPEECH
AND THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T. I AM
COMPOSED THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR. AND NEXT GO TO LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SERRA AGNES LEN THE CITIZEN OF
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY THERE BEEN
OVER SIX THOUSAND DEATHS FROM
THE TUNGSTATE VACCINE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS MINIMALIST
FELL AT THE SEVENTH YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE AT. TWO ONE
SEVEN. HELLO YES- MY NAME IS
MARK MARK BOWLER. I'M FROM
SUMMIT HELD FAURIA- WITH THE
NUMBER COUNTY HEALTH ADVOCATES
FOR FREE SPEECH AGAINST
CENSORSHIP AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WILL NOT GO TO
FOUR ZERO TWO. HI MY NAME IS
JACKIE- I'M FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT SB.
SEVEN FOUR TWO IT IS ABOUT. AND
THEN. THANK YOU OPERATOR SO LET
ME ANNOUNCE AGAIN WE NEED YOUR
NAME. AN ORGANIZATION ONLY IS
NOT TO CUT YOU OFF BUT WE HAVE
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
IN Q. M. WE WOULD LIKE TO GET
OUT OF HERE IN THIS MILLENNIUM
SO. PLEASE NAY AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE SO YOU CAN BE HEARD. AND
WE WILL DOUBLE TO. ONE ZERO
SEVEN. YEAH THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER FINALLY ABOUT. WE DON'T
HAVE. AND NEXT IN LINE FOR ALL
NINE. JANET THERE ARE
GRANGETOWN TWEETING. UPLOADS
THIS. THANK YOU. AND NEXT IS
LINE TO TWENTY. ONE DON'T STOP
BLOCKS. HELLO IT'S CLEAR MARK
WILLIAMS A CONSTITUENT OF
DISTRICT SIXTY FIVE AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM. NEXT ON THE LINE AT.
FOUR ONE ONE. MY NAME IS BRENDA
MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE. TWO ONE
ONE. GOOD MORNING GOLF BURKE
WITH THE VACCINE INJURY
AWARENESS WE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE HIS FELLOW THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE.
NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE TO WILL
WIND. ONE THIRTY TWO. MY NAME
IS SHERRY AND I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE WITH ACTING INJUED TWINS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU. WE WILL
ALSO LINE SEVENTY. I DO
GONZALEZ WHAT. WHAT AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL THANK YOU SIR. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE FORTY
NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
WILL. AND I REPRESENTS UP AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
FILM THANK YOU. BUT A LUNCH FOR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY IT HAD.
RIGHT WHAT WHAT. FOUR TWO ZERO
FOUR EIGHT- I APOLOGIZE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE AND
I REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA I. AT FROM. RIGHT
THANK YOU NAY REALIZATION. ONLY.
WELL I'M THIRTY NINE IF THAT. I
THIRTY NINE ALLIANCE OPENS THIS
BUT. BUT A LINE FOR TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARLENE. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JAY FROM ELDORADO COUNTY THIS
IS A DIRECT VIOLATION OF
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT HUMAN
SUBJECTS ON MEDICAL EXPERIMENT.
THE EX THANKS FOR TWENTY FIVE
DAYS BUT- CAPTAIN CODY FROM BIG
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. FIND ONE EIGHTY EIGHT IF
I HAD. ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT WHEN IT'S OPEN. MY NAME
IS THE STOCK. I AM NOT
CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED TEACHER-
YES BILL THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE OF THE
DESPITE. THANK FOR INTERNET
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY-
YET ARE ON BOTH AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM PENNDOT I
THANK GOD FOR THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HILL THE ROCKY CHILDREN'S
HEALTH DEFENSE. STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY STORY LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS. WELL
DEMOCRATS REMEMBER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
THANKS FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX STATES BUT. HI MY NAME IS
CONNECTING ON BEHALF OF JANET
AND THOUSANDS OF KIDS FOURTEEN
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NOT ASHARI AND I
REPRESENT PROTECT ALL FUNDED BY
THE SALE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINDA LEE FLAMINIO
SLOW COUNTY REGISTERED VOTER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SEVEN
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SHIFTED AT.
FOUR FOUR SIX. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KAREN REDDING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PRIVATE CITIZEN
I STRONGLY. OBJECT TO THIS BILL.
THANK FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN IF I HAD. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SALLY INTENT-
FROM THE SENATE CLARA. I AM
STRONGLY AGAINST THE S. B.
SEVEN POINT TWO THANK YOU. MY
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANKS FOR FIVE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK ON
RECORD ON BEHALF OF SILENCE
FAMILIES. DID MONTEREY COUNTY
WE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE IF YOU
AGREE DISPLAY UNETHICAL AND
ILLEGAL SB SEVEN FORTY TWO NEXT
UP FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS ARE
GOING UP NEXT. BRANCH FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY LINE IS
OPEN DESPITE. ONE FOUR ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS RIGHT. APPLE I AM THAT
MOTHER THREE AND SWORN AT THE
COMPLICATION FROM TWENTY FOUR
YEARS AGO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
RIGHT WITH YOU KNOW THE PERSON
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FOUR ZERO FIVE ONE. WE'RE GOING
TO LINE FOR UNDER SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I'M HERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PARENTS
UNITED WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH PLANET THAT
HASN'T BEEN. AYE OPPOSED. BUT A
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LAURA ALBERT
MOTHER OF FIVE AND GRANDMOTHER
FOR INCURRED COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN FOUR TWO THANK
YOU. BERLIN FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE JUST AHEAD. YEAH
GOOD MORNING THIS IS REVENUE
WHEN THE SILVER- HELP LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CHILDREN'S
HEALTH DEFENSE CALIFORNIA AND
MILLION MAMA'S MOVEMENT
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANKS FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE THIS CALL AT ALL. HI MY BUT
I'M CALLING FROM UP. I THANK
YOU THAT FOR YOU THE VIOLATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU I
AND THIRTY FIVE THESE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS LADY DEATH. LADY
JUSTICE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FREEDOM
COLLECTION COALITION WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THAT CLAUDIA OF
EXCELLENCE I'M A SINGLE MOTHER
AND I LOVE AND OF A- OKAY
CHILDHOOD END UP BY THAT AND-
AT THE BILL. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR SEVEN DECADES BUT I
THINK. ONE FOUR SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE'RE GOING TO
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KEITH. CARLSON AND I
MADE TECHNOLOGY CEO IN THE
SILICON VALLEY AND I'D STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR ANYONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHAEL MCCABE CALLING
ON THE CONTROL OF THIS STORE
AND I OPPOSE. SB SEVEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU SIR. THANKS FOUR
HUNDRED TO BE HAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS A BRAND IN OUR FOR.
FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT YES GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA
BIANCANIELLO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL FEB SEVEN B. SEVEN
FOUR Q. AS A VACCINE INJURED
MOTHER. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND ONE JUST AHEAD.
FIVE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS BORING. MARK MY NAME
IS. SO I THINK I DID PETER WITH
AT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I
HAVE ACTIVATED YOUR SON THANK.
FELT. THANK FIVE AND FOUR THIS
BUT- HELLO NAME EMAIL ADDRESS
AND I A TEACHER FROM JOAQUIN
COUNTY THE FOUND OF AN A LITTLE
ACTUALLY OF CHILDREN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
FIVE HUNDRED AND TO JUST GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BLANKA
HER TADO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL SB. SEVEN FORTY TWO. THANK
FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN JUST AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S LINDSAY HOLMES AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SELF
THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN IF I HAD. HI MY NAME
IS BRIANNA BY REGISTERED NURSE
AND MOTHER TO BE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SEVEN FORTY. THANK
YOU. THANKS FIVE NINETEEN HE'S
GOT HAD. YES HI MY NAME IS
ANDREA ANDERSON AND AYE OPPOSED
SB SEVEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU.
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE HAD.
TWO FOUR ZERO SIX OPENS. THANKS
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THIS GUY HAD.
THE CANCER FROM RETURNING
CALIFORNIA OTHER THAN THE
THOUSANDS OF HUMAN LIFE THAT
STAND BILLS HAVE ALREADY
IMPACTED ADVERSELY AND I
STRONGLY. OPPOSED SB SEVEN
PORTANTINO. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DR JANE
CARLSON FROM SAN MATTEO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK THIRTY EIGHT
DESCRIBES. THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THIS BUT. ABOUT
ALIGN ONE NINETY TWO THIS GUY
HAD. HI I'M ANNA KATHLEEN ON
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I'M A
MEMBER OF A VOICE FOR CHOICE
ADVOCACY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO PLEASE READ AND
RESPOND TO OUR LETTER
CONCERNING AMENDMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT BUT. HELLO
THANKS FIVE FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LAND BUILT THEM. HELLO. GO
AHEAD NAME AN ORGANIZATION
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE
MATIC- THE MOST REMEMBER VOICE
SURGERY AND- HIGHLY HIGHLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN IF I HAD. MY NAME IS
JENNY SUIT FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS JENNY HENSLEY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND WONDERING WHY
KIANA SO OBSESSED WITH THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE MOMENT.
THANKS FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THANK GOD. WE HAD NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS IT
WILL BEGIN WITH THE DOCTOR
COURT. WELL I WILL BE VOTING
FOR THIS BILL TODAY- HOWEVER I
DO THINK THE OPPOSITION HAS
SOME POINTS FIRST OF ALL THE
THIRTY FOOT DISTANCE. THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE I KNOW
OF AND I'VE BEEN LOOKING THAT
YOU CAN TRANSMIT OVER THIRTY
FEET OUTSIDE THAT YOU CAN
TRANSMIT A- ARE COVERED AND
YOU'RE PRIMARILY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE COVETED VACCINES AND
YOU SET IT AT THIRTY. FRANKLY
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
THAT EVEN INDOORS YOU CAN DO IT
WITH SPECIALLY IF THE
VENTILATION IS SET UP JUST
RIGHT. BUT I REALLY DON'T THINK
THAT THAT MEASURE AND PROBABLY
SOME OF THE OTHERS THAT YOU
HAVE IN THE BILL WOULD SURVIVE
A COURT CHALLENGE SO. AGAIN I
WILL BE VOTING FOR TODAY BUT
I'D SUGGEST THAT YOU CHANGE THE
BILL- I'M MOVED TO BAIL. DO YOU
REMEMBER. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SHE
NINETY MAKE COSTA RICA THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH SHARE NINE I
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND APPRECIATE- YOU'RE
LISTENING TO ALL THE TESTIMONY-
I THAT- DUCTWORK I HAVE
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR YOU- I
THINK THAT SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME UP IN TERMS OF
DISTANCE- I MEAN THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST QUIETLY
STANDING THERE WAVING SIGNS
RIGHT AND WE SAW IT FOR EXAMPLE
AND- DODGER STADIUM- THAT THEY
WERE COMING UP AND SCREAMING
AT. PEOPLE YELLING- SO WE KNOW
THAT WHEN PEOPLE YELL OR SAYING
SO WHAT THE PROJECT VOICE YOU
HAVE MUCH GREATER TRANSMISSION-
THIS DOES APPLY I MEAN WE HAVE
INDOORS AND OUTDOORS SO IT DOES
HAVE IT DOES DEPENDS TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT ON VENTILATION
BUT ALSO POINT OUT THAT. WHEN
YOU HEAR FROM THE USE RIGHT-
YEAH WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO
IS CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO GO GET
THEIR VACCINES BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE INTENT OF THE JUST YOU
KNOW THE EXTREMISTS OURS
ACTUALLY TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE
FROM GETTING BACK TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY WANT TO GET
VACCINATED. AND TO DISCOURAGE
THEM IN FACT I FIND IT QUITE
TELLING THAT- SOME OF THE
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION AS A
PERSON WHO HAS A HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT AND
ACTUALLY IS PLANNING ON
FACEBOOK TODAY HAVE YOU TALK
ABOUT SUCH A FACEBOOK DIRECTLY
SAID D. HAVE DIRECT PEOPLE TO
GO TO VACCINATION SITES AND
CONDUCT- THESE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES PROBABLY HOPING
WAITING TILL THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY. HOPING THAT THIS
BILL BE DEFEATED SO THAT THEY
COULD DO IT WITHOUT TRIGGERING
IS MORE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
SO I AM CONCERNED AND I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES
SUPPORT THE USE THAT THEY ARE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE NERVOUS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT- DAY WOULD BE
HARASSED AND- AND ATTACKED
FLOORED JUST TRYING TO. PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT NEVER
WOULD REALLY WANT TO THANK- THE-
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
AND- SO I THINK ADDRESSING MANY
OF THE ISSUES A CONSTITUTIONAL
OTHERWISE ACTUALLY- STAFF ON
BOTH BOTH. A GUIDE TO MAKE
DEMOCRAT AL COMMITTEE STAFF AND
RIVER. STAFF REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK- WE WANT
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THIS BILL IS REALLY.
ACTIVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GET
VACCINATED SHOULD BILL GET
VACCINATED WITHOUT BEING
HARASSED. BUT BEING
INTIMIDATED. AND ALSO WE ALSO
PROTECT FREE SPEECH. AND THIS
IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT TO
PREVENT SOMEONE FROM. US GOING
AND SAYING WHAT THEY WANT TO
SAY- IN APPROPRIATE PLACES WHAT
WE DON'T WANT TO DO. IS-
PREVENT PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO
GET IT FROM BEING ABLE TO GET
VACCINATED. AND WE ALWAYS SAY
THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
RIGHT TO SWING YOUR FIST STOPS
AT THE PERSON'S NOSE AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
AND SO WITH THAT- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR- YOUR CONSIDERATION. IN
THE- BUT OUT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE. JUST BECAUSE WE HAD
MEMBERS THAT WEREN'T HERE IF
YOU ALLOW IT. ANY TO MEMBERS
THAT WORK. BEFORE WE ENDED.
FURTHER OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AVERAGE GIVE ME. IF
GIVEN THEM AN OPPORTUNITY IF
YOU WANTED TO. ASK QUESTIONS
YOU'RE GOOD GOOD GOOD DIMMER
WE'RE GOOD. SO WITH THAT- IS
SHARMA THANK YOU FOR. WORKING
WITH- BOTH PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE THE SENATE. BECAUSE
THAT FOR US- THAT DEFINITELY-
REAL CONCERN THAT WE GO THROUGH
ALL OF THIS. YOU'RE ALL THIS
TESTIMONY. AND IT GETS
CHALLENGED IN COURT ON A FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT CONSTANT THAT'S
WHY YOU GOT. SO MUCH SUPPORT
AND- END UP AMENDMENTS FROM
BOTH COMMITTEES TO ENSURE THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT- WE DON'T
VIOLATE THAT AND SO I THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING- THOSE SUBMIT.
AMENDMENTS- I THINK WITH WHAT
DOCTOR CORP BROUGHT UP- IT'S A
MATTER OF. JUST YOU KNOW PASSED.
THAT'S OUT OF MY- FIELD- AS FAR
AS MAY. HOW FOR. SOMEONE TO BE
A PART FORTY. CONTRACT THIS
LAST YEAR WE'RE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT CONTRACTING. VIRUSES DID
WE- EVER KNEW BEFORE AND- IS
WE'D BE DEPENDING ON THE CDC
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND
SO AT THE I THINK IF YOU WERE
TO PROVIDE. THE DATA THE
VERIFICATION OF MEDICAL
REASONING FOR WHY YOU YOU HAD
THAT I THINK THAT WILL. THAT
WILL HELP ASSUAGE WHO IF NOT
ALL SOME PEOPLE'S CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT THE DISTANCE. AS
WITHOUT THE CHAIRED RECOMMENDED
AIBO. CALDERON ON SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR HAND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY NEL BARRICADE
HAND BARRICADE HAD A LEAK LEAK
I WORK HARD WORK I SANTIAGO. C.
R. TELL NO C. R. TURNOUT WICKS
WICKS I. THE MEASURE PASS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WILL NOT GO ON TO- ITEMS-
ACTUALLY ITEMS TO AND FOUR SB
SEVEN ONE ZERO BRADFORD
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST AND IT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB FIVE SIX SEVEN BRADFORD
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE SENTENCING.
AND MR BREAST CENTER BRADFORD
WHICHEVER ONE YOU WANT TO BEGIN
WITH- YOU HAVE YOUR DISK YOUR
IT'S AT YOUR DISCRETION I'M
GONNA START WITH SEVEN CHANCES
MY WITNESSES ARE READY SO. YOUR
ANCESTRY FOR A MEASURE THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BETWEEN PROSECUTORS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WHO HAVE COMMITTED MISCONDUCT
ON DUTY THIS BILL REQUIRED TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO HAVE
RECEIVED MONETARY BENEFITS FROM
AN ASSOCIATION THAT SOLELY
REPRESENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
RECUSE HIMSELF. FROM THE
INVESTIGATION CHARGING AND
PROSECUTION OF OFFICERS THAT
THAT MEMBER IS A PART OF THAT
ASSOCIATION ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL APPLIES IF THAT
ASSOCIATION PROVIDES
REPRESENTATION FOR THAT OFFICER
IN THE CRIMINAL CASE. AFTER
RECUSING THEMSELVES ATTORNEY
GENERAL SHALL ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CASE AND
IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS A
CONFLICT THEN THEY WILL ASSIGN
A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR. BOTH
STATE LAW IN THE STATE BAR
RULES OF PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT
ADDRESS HOW ATTORNEY SHOULD
RESPOND WHEN FACED WITH A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BUT
THEY'RE UNCLEAR WITH THIS
SPECIFIC TYPE OF SITUATION
PROSECUTORS SOME OF THE MOST
POWERFUL ACTORS. IN OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THEIR ROLE IS UNIQUE.
AND UNLIKE MOST ELECTED
OFFICIALS- DUTIES AS TO FOR AND
IN FOR THE LAW NOT SOME MAKE
POLICY CHOICES. THAT BEING SAID.
THIS RETURNEES HOLD A
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE IN HOLDING BAD
OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE YET MANY
TIMES OFFICERS IN THE STATE
SERIOUSLY HARM KILL HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE EVERY
YEAR AND ALMOST NONE OF THEM
EVER FONG CRIMINAL LIBEL. MOSSO
MARTIN NEVER EVEN CHARGED AS A
RESULT. COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE ARE RIGHTFULLY
CRITICAL OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATIONS ESPECIALLY WHEN
THAT ASSOCIATION DONATES TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND AS
FINANCING COUNSEL FOR THOSE BAD
OFFICERS THIS IS A CLEAR UP THE
CODE ISSUE AND OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WILL BE. BETTER
FOR. AND IN BENEFIT GREATLY BY
ADDRESSING THIS CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THIS BILL DOES NOT.
MEMBERS STATE DOES NOT PREVENT
ANY OFFICER FROM RECEIVING A
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL TRIAL. THIS
BILL DOES NOT PREVENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNIONS FROM
DONATING TO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CANDIDATES. NOR DOES IT FORBID
JUST RETURNING FROM ACCEPTING
THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS IT ONLY
REQUIRES THOSE ATTORNEYS TO
RECUSE THEMSELVES FROM THAT
CRIMINAL CASE. REMOVING ANY
OPPORTUNITY FOR BIAS OR
FAVORITISM. TESTIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. ARE TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S FIRST WE
HAD DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CHASE THE BODINE AND
AFTER WHICH WILL HAVE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FROM LOS ANGELES
GEORGE GAS CONE. BOTH OF WHOM
ARE MEMBERS OF THE PROSECUTOR
LINES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO IN SUPPORT WILL
BEGIN WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CHESTER
BODINE AND THEN WILL. GO TO
DALY COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
GEORGE GASCON MISTER BODINE
OPERATOR WE OPEN UP THE LINE.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
VIEWS THANK YOU FOR THE WALK
WITH ALL OF YOU DO TO MAKE SAN
FRANCISCO CA FOR MORE FAIR. MY
NAME IS JASON ROUTINES ARE
DIRECTED DISTRICTS. OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCES CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
PROUD TO SPONSOR SENATE BILL
SEVEN TEN BY SENATOR GRASSLEY-
YEAH I WANT TO ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS AND I KNOW THEY MADE
UP AND DOWN THE STATE ABOUT THE
NEEDS OF THIS BILL. I WOULD
LIKE TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ARGUMENTS. THAT WE HAVE
HEARD IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL
IS. TAILORED ADVANSIX. STATE
INTEREST. IN THE ENTIRE OF OUR
JUDICIAL. AND FAIR TREATMENT
FOR ALL THAT AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. ALSO ALWAYS CLAIM THAT
WE ARE INFRINGING ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO ENGAGE IN
POLITICAL SPEECH TO CONTRIBUTE
TO A CAMPAIGN OF ADA CANADA
THEIR CHOICE I WANT TO BE CLEAR
SENATE BILL CLINTON DOES NOT
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATIONS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO CANDIDATES.
ACROSS YOUR LAWSUIT YOUR SAYS
THE BILL LIMIT THE ABILITY OR
THE RIGHT TO DA CANDIDATES.
LOOKS AFTER. THE BILL PROVIDE.
THAT IN CASES AND ON MY CRIME
COME ON DUTY OFFICER THE DA
RECUSANTS FROM THE INTO. YES
ONLY YES THE LONG ASSOCIATION
ALSO PROVIDES REPRESENTATION TO
THE OFFICER IN THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. BOTH SONGS MUST
BE MET. YES MUST HAVE GIVEN A
MONETARY BENEFIT DIRECTLY TO
THE AGE LONG INVESTIGATION AND
YES- SOLUTION MUST BE PROVIDING
REPRESENTATION TO THE OFFICER
BEING INVESTIGATED AND THE
REMEDY IN THAT SITUATION IS
SIMPLY REFUSAL OF THE DA FROM
THE INVESTIGATION OR
PROSECUTION. THIS TAILORED LAW
IS AIMED AT ADVANCING A
COMPELLING STATE INTERESTS THAT
IS MAINTAINING PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE. IN THE INTEGRITY OF
PROSECUTORS IN THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS OF POLICE
WRONGDOING. THE ALL TO COMMON
AFTER PROSECUTORS ACCEPTING
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND
THEN FAILING TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE MEMBERS OF THOSE
SAME ASSOCIATIONS FOR-
APPARENTLY CRIMINAL ACTS
CORRODES PUBLIC TRUST IN AN
INSTITUTION WHOSE LEGITIMACY
HINGES ON PUBLIC FACE IN ITS
FAIRNESS AND IMPARTIALITY
FILING. THE OPPOSITION ALSO
POINTS OUT. THAT NUMBER IS OF
LEGISLATIVE BODIES DO NOT HAVE
TO RECUSE THEMSELVES FROM
VOTING ON ISSUES RELATED TO
ENTITIES THAT HAVE DONATED TO
THEIR CAMPAIGNS. BUT
PROSECUTORS SURVEY PUBLIC DUTY
DISTINCT FROM OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS WE ARE ADMINISTRATORS
OF JUSTICE AND WE ARE TURNING
HELLO A HIGHER STANDARD THAN
ANY OTHER ELECTED OFFICIAL WE
MUST HOLD ANYONE WHO BREAKS THE
LAW ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS EVEN IF. THEIR FELLOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT. IT IS A PARA
IMPORTANCE THAT THE PUBLIC
TRUST US TO CARRY OUT THOSE
DUTIES FAIRLY IMPARTIALLY
SENATE BILL SEVEN TEN IS
CRITICAL TO BUILDING THAT TRUST
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU D. A DE CASTRO. AT&T
OPERATOR. K. ARMS YEAH CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES. RIGHT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE CANADIAN
THANK YOU TO ENSURE FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
GEORGE GAS CONE I AM A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALIGNS OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
PROUD TO BE THE SPONSORS OF SB
SEVEN TEN. I AM BE ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF LOS
ANGELES AND PREVIOUSLY I
CERTAIN DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
SAN FRANCISCO FROM NEARLY NINE
YEARS. I SPENT THIRTY YEARS OF
MY CAREER SO LONG PORTION
OFFICERS SERVING AS THE CHIEF
OF POLICE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ONLY A CERTAIN CHIEF OF POLICE
IN THE LAPD. I DEDICATED MY
BOOK. LIFE TWENTY SURE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
PROVIDES FAIR. AND EQUAL ACCESS
TO JUSTICE. OKAY CANNOT
FUNCTION EFFECTIVELY. PUBLIC
DOES NOT TRUSTED IN HELPED
SHAPE IN HIS IMPARTIALITY. THE
NATION WIDE DEMONSTRATIONS OVER
THERE GEORGE FLOORINGS AND
BRIANNA TAYLOR AND COUNTLESS
OTHERS HAVE MADE IT CLEAR TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT FACES A CRISIS
OF LEGITIMACY. NOT JUST THE
POLICE. IT IS ALSO ACROSS ON
THE COURT WILL OFTEN FAILING
OPEN LOOK. WHEN THEY BREAK THE
LAW. WHEN PEOPLE AND BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES SEE THEIR
LOVED ONES CALL OFF TO JAIL FOR
MINOR OFFENSES. AND THEN WALKED
FOR USE OFFICERS KILLED MEMBERS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES WILL NOT
FACING ANY CRIMINAL
CONSEQUENCES. IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THE PEOPLE CONCLUDE.
THAT THE SYSTEM IS RIGGED
AGAINST. SB SEVEN PENN WILL
ADDRESS ONE OF THE ALL TO
COMMON PRACTICE THE CONTRIBUTES
TO THIS PERCEPTION. THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OPINION
MONETARY BENEFITS ON THE SEND
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO C. H. IN.
THE REPRESENTS THE OFFICERS
THAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO HOLD
THE ACCOUNT. REGARDLESS OF THE
PROSECUTORS IN PENSIONS THE
FINANCIAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOLICITATIONS FOR ROADS CROSS
IN ORDER FOR SHELL OF THE- BUSH
SERIOUSLY UNDERMINES THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE ENTIRE
CRIMINAL. JUSTICE SYSTEM. AS
ATTORNEYS WERE HELD TO THE
ETHICAL STANDARDS REGARDING
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. BUT
THERE ARE CRITICAL GAPS IN THE
STANDARDS THE RESULT IN A
LOOPHOLE FOR THE SITUATION. SB
SEVEN TEN MORE CLOSEST
LOOPHOLES. AND HELP RESTORE
TRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE. IT IS FOR THIS REASON
LARA ELSEWHERE HE WROTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WOULD NOT GO
TO THE ROOM FOR. ANY IN PERSON
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN FIRST CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF GOVERN FOR
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR BRADFORD'S BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING A LITTLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO. KIM WAS WAITING
TO I SPOKE TO HIM. ASHLEY
MONTERROSA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TEN THANK YOU. HI
EVERYONE MICHELLE MONTERROSA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THAT WOULD GO TO
WITNESSES I BELIEVE ON THE LAWN
WHO MAY WANT TO TESTIFY ARE
THERE ANY. HEARING NONE. AT&T
OPERATOR WILL GO TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN ONE
ZERO BRADFORD THEY'RE ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE RIGHT NOW YOU
MAY OPEN UP THE LINES. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ONE. SEVEN
ONE ZERO. THIS PRESS ONE THEN
YOU'RE- BEGAN TO SHOW SUPPORT-
SB SEVEN ONE ZERO THIS PRESS
ONE OF YOUR- BUT A LINE FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THESE GUYS.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
PRINCE OF MEETING ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOT HAVE TO MENTOR ABOUT
HALF OF THE PRODUCT YOU'RE
GOING TO CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO PROVIDE SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA YELLOW BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET INITIATE
ACTOR JAMES AT THE SAN DIEGO
COALITION WE THE PEOPLE SAN
DIEGO FILLER FOR THE COMMUNITY
ASIAN SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE.
THANKS COMMITTEE SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE SAN DIEGO AND
NORTH SAN DIEGO COUNTY
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES FOR DUSTIN
MORROW GOVERNMENT UP RIGHT HERE
SAN DIEGO COLECTIVO MISSION
IMPACT PHILANTHROPY. FELT
TERRIBLE QUATTRO B. L. M. SO
WHAT SOCIAL WORKERS FOR EQUITY
IN LEADERSHIP- SO CRAP
INDIVISIBLE PRIVATE SAN DIEGO
SAN DIEGO PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATIC. PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE ADVANCEMENT OF THE AMERICAN
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IF THAT MAKES
IS THAT THE COALITION SB CHANGE
BEGINS WITH ME INDIVISIBLE AND
THE DEMOCRATIC WOMEN'S CLUB. OF
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THANK YOU FOR.
DOING ALL IN ONE. THANKS SIX
HUNDRED TWO BUT. SIX ZERO TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JENNIFER WROTE AND I AM FROM
CALIFORNIA AND I OF HURDLES SB.
SEVEN FORTY TWO. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU SAID YOU NINETY FIVE. YES
TO NINETY FIVE. YES THIS IS
THAT MANY HIGHER FROM THE A
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY GROUP WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TEN.
THANK YOU. NINE SIX ZERO SORRY
LINE IS OPEN DESPITE. SIX
HUNDRED AND. FORTY HI MY NAME
IS ROMAN RAMACHANDRAN I AM A
STUDENT AMBASSADOR WITH
INTERACTING I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF STUDENTS TO VOICE MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETY HAD. THANKS FIVE
NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TIMOTHY
I AM A SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TEACHER OF
TWENTY THREE YEARS AND I'VE
ALSO BEEN GRANTED PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE FOR JUSTICE-
I AND THE GROUP ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS SIX HUNDRED
ONE THREE AT. HI MY NAME IS
VALERIE WILSON THE I AM A
PARENT IN SAN DIEGO AND I
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FOUR ZERO.
THANK YOU. WHEN ONE TWENTY BUT
HAD. THANK GOOD ENOUGH ON THE
TOPIC ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. FIND ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE IF I HAD.
ALL MY NAME IS MICHAEL CARRILLO
AND AS AND FOR THE COMMUNITY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY.
HI MY NAME'S CLAUDIA DOES COME
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE ONE NINE. MY
BLANK AND. SIXTY EIGHT. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. I HAD WIENER.
READERS BILL OKAY. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. THANK FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE OF UP AND FISCAL
HAD. HI MY NAME IS GIVEN AS THE
KNOWS ANOTHER COMMUNITY MEMBER
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN TEN
THANK YOU. THANK SIX TIME
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE'S. SIX ONE
ZERO AND IT'S OPEN THIS BUT-
HELLO HELLO DAVID ORGANIZATION
I HAD. I THIS IS MARLEY AND I
AM. POSING WITH THE BILL SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO. IN THE FACE OF
IT THIS IS FOR S. B. SEVEN ONE
ZERO BRADFORD. SO ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN ONE
ZERO. CAN MAKE A COMMENT NOW.
TO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE NOT SHOWING SUPPORT. FOR
SEVEN ONE ZERO. BUT NINE SIX
FOURTEEN TO STATEN. THANKS SIX
ONE FLOOR PLEASE BY AND. HELLO
HELLO SIX FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES- THIS IS NANCY
CARLSSON WITH WITNESS TONIGHT
IN CALIFORNIA- CATCH UP
CALIFORNIA. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. SEVEN ONE ZERO.
THIS IS FOR SUPPORTING SIX
THIRTEEN AND HIS CURRENT. GOOD
MORNING ARE YOU HAVING A GOOD
OUT WITH WIDENING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT SB SEVEN TEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS SIX
HUNDRED AND THREE AHEAD. SIX
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT A LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE. SO I HAD. HELLO
HELLO. HELLO I HAD. WE ARE
LIVING AND I'M CALLING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I'M A RESIDENT
LIFELONG TRANSACTION SHOULD GO
AND I'M A MOTHER OF TWO KIDS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN
TEN. THANK YOU. IN ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU-
WILL NOW GO TO- WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ALLARI
MORRIS- CALIFORNIA'S
SECRETARY'S SOCIAIS SHOULD BUY
FROM WE HAVE RYAN SHERMAN IN
PERSON. I'M NOT SURE WHICH
CLIENT IS. RIGHT HERE IN THE
ROOM SO MANY. UP GO AHEAD LARRY
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SIR-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL SEVEN
TEN THIS BILL SINGLES OUT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AMONG ALL
ELECTED OFFICIALS AS BEING
INCAPABLE OF RECONCILING THEIR
ETHICAL DUTIES BUT HAVING
RECEIVED POLITICAL SUPPORT IN
THIS CASE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS. WHY WOULD BE AS
BE HELD TO A DIFFERENT STANDARD
THE MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE MOST OF THEM
ROUTINELY SOLICIT SIGNIFICANT
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A
VAST ARRAY OF SPECIAL INTEREST
TO HAVE BUSINESS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN VOTE ON
THEIR BILLS WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ELECTED DA
RECEIVING THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT UNION IN
HIS OR HER COUNTY AND THEN
CLEARLY AND ETHICALLY ASSESSING
A SUBSEQUENT OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING CASE. AND A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE ACCEPTING
CONTRIBUTIONS THROUGHOUT HIS OR
HER CAREER FROM SAY UTILITY
INTERESTS AND THEN VOTING ON
LEGISLATION REGULATING THOSE
SAME UTILITIES PRACTICALLY
SPEAKING NOT WE WOULD NOT
SUGGEST THAT JUST BECAUSE A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
TAKING CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS HERE SHE
IS RENDERED INCAPABLE OF VOTING
HIS OR HER CONSCIENCE ON A BILL
AFFECTING THAT SPECIAL
INTERESTS. YET THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL TELLS ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WHY IS THE
BILL SINGLE OUT ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONTRIBUTIONS THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL INCLUDING
MY FRIEND BE ABLE BEING FROM
SAN FRANCISCO LA DA GEORGE GASC
DON'T HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY AND
FINANCIALLY SUPPORTED BY
DEFENSE BAR INTEREST BUT THE
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT THEM
FROM INVESTIGATING OR
PROSECUTING AN OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING WHERE THOSE SAME
MEMBERS OF THE DEFENSE BAR HAVE
A KEEN INTEREST IN WHETHER
CHARGES ARE FILED. THIS WOULD
SEEM AN EGREGIOUS DOUBLE
STANDARD AT BEST MISTER GASTON
SUPPORT IS NOT SURPRISING GIVEN
THE NEAR UNANIMOUS OPPOSITION
TO HIS POLICIES BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IT'S DRAMATIC RIGHT CRIME RATES.
AS WE READ THE BILL OF THE
DISTRICT DID NOT RECEIVE
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
THE LOCAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OR DEPUTY SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION BUT DID RECEIVE A
CONTRIBUTION FOR THE POOR ACT A
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION WHICH HAS
MEMBERS IN BOTH THE LOCAL
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND LOCAL
POLICE AGENCIES THE DA WOULD BE
DEEMED TO HAVE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND THUS PRECLUDED
FROM CONDUCTING OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING INVESTIGATION
IN ANY AGENCY THAT HAS PORAC
MEMBERS. UNDER THIS BILL WHAT
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING THE
CURSE D. A. WOULD BE COMPELLED
TO REVIEW OR OR HIS CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DETERMINE WHAT
IF ANY POLICE ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTED HIS OR HER CANDIDACY
AND GET THAT OFFICER WAS A
MEMBER OF ANY OF THEM. THE BILL
IF APPROVED WOULD BE GUARANTEED
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING CASES THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL SOON BE
INVESTIGATING UNDER LAST YEAR'S
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX MOREOVER YOU
WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE IN WHICH BOTH
AN AG AND THE LOCAL VA RECEIVED
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM PORAC OR
OTHER STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION. IN SUCH CASES THE
DA WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DEDUCT
THE- I. S. INVESTIGATION NOR
WILL BE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL
THEN BE COMPELLED TO RETAIN A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO CUT
INDUCTEE INVESTIGATION IF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY DOESN'T WANT
TO ACCEPT CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
PUBLIC SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS
THEN HERE SHE CAN BE QUITE.
WELL AS WOULD MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY STRENUOUSLY OBJECT TO
THE APPLICATION THAT THEY
CANNOT DISCHARGE THEIR ALEXA
DUTIES FAITHFULLY AND WITHOUT
FEAR OR FAVOUR NO MATTER WHO
HAS SUPPORTED THEIR CAMPAIGN
FOR OFFICE WE SUPPORT THE
TRANSPARENCY OF RECORDING ALL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS INCLUDING DA'S AND
BELIEVE THE VOTERS CAN DEPART
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES JUST AS
THEY WOULD WITH MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WHO
ACCEPT CAMPAIGN. CONTRIBUTIONS
WHETHER ANY OFFICIAL ARE TO
VOTE PHONE TO. WE THE BILL
SIGNIFICAN COST CHALLENGES AS
WELL IN THE CALIFORNIA COURT
CASE WOODLAND RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION VERSUS CITY COUNCIL
OF LOS ANGELES THE COURT NOTED
THAT QUOTE POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS INVOLVED IN
EXERCISE OF FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION AND ARTICLE ONE
SECTION TWO OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THIS BILL IS
DANGEROUS ARBITRARY
INCONSISTENT AND UNCONSTRUCTED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK. OKAY MISTER SHERMAN I'M
A GIVE YOU EXTERMINATOR THOUGH
MR MORE SAID ALMOST ALL YOUR
TIME TO. I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF
YEAH. MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RIGHT SHERMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE LABOR UNIONS THAT
REPRESENT PEACE OFFICERS
INCLUDING THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION LOS
ANGELES SCHOOL POLICE
ASSOCIATION AND POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATIONS FROM THE CITIES OF
CLAREMONT CORONA HOMEOWNER PALS
FORTIES NEWPORT BEACH. BURBANK
UPLAND SANTA ANA RIVERSIDE
INGLEWOOD ARCADIA IN CULVER
CITY THESE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
LABOR UNIONS REPRESENTING
POLICE OFFICERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE UNITED IN STRONG
OPPOSITION S. B. TEN WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL DECLARES A LEGAL
FICTION OF CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IN AN EFFORT TO RESTRICT
POLITICAL SPEECH A PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE LABOR UNIONS REPRESENT
PEACE OFFICERS. THAT'S WITHIN
SIX TO. ZERO SB SEVEN TEN
SIXTEEN PREVENT PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
LABOR UNIONS REPRESENTING PEACE
OFFICERS FROM MAKING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS TO A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS
OF THIS BILL MAKE THAT GOAL
QUITE CLEAR RESULTING IN SB
TENSE DUBIOUS CONSTITUTIONALITY-
MR MORE AID MENTION THE OTHER
ISSUES CONCERNING FREE SPEECH-
AND UNDER CURRENT LAW CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE CURRENTLY
LIMITED TO PREVENT AN ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
ARE CAPPED AT FORTY NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR LEGISLATIVE
ELECTIONS IN EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED
FOR NAY G. RACE. FURTHERMORE WE
BELIEVE SB TEN IMPERMISSIBLY
LIMITS THE AG'S CONSTITUTIONAL
POWERS AND PROHIBITS THE AG
FROM PERFORMING THEIR
PRESCRIBED OVERSIGHT DUTIES
PURSUANT TO ARTICLE FIVE
SECTION THIRTEEN OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. EVEN IF THE AG
ACCEPTS THE FIVE DOLLAR
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION. THE
EATER. SB SEVEN TEN WILL OF
CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEYS ANTI
POLICE ORGANIZATIONS AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM GROUPS
TO CONTRIBUTE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO AN AG OR DA
CANDIDATE OR OFFICE HOLDER. BUT
THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS ARE NOT
PRESUME TO CREATE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. SB SEVEN TEN DECIDES
WHO MAY AND WHO MAY NOT
DIRECTLY SUPPORT CANDIDATES FOR
ELECTIVE OFFICE THIS IS A CLEAR
VIOLATION OF CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MANY MORE WE
REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
SEVEN TEN. RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED OVER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW ARE YOU ANY
NUMBER BRING IT TO THE OUTSIDE
THIRTY ANY OTHERS HELLO MONICA
LEAVES THAT MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION I WOULD LIKE TO GET
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
BEFORE WE GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
SEEING NONE HEARING NONE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN ONE
ZERO. AT&T OPERATING A OPEN
LINE. TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
SEVEN ONE ZERO THIS PRESS ONE
ZERO YOUR TELEPHONE. THANKS
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK FIVE
NINE SIX LINES OPENED THE
SPREAD. OVERRULING SIX HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. THIS GUY
HAD A LOT OF. OKAY BOB THIS IS
PRIYANKA FROM CUPERTINO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB SEVEN FORTY FIVE PROPOSED
BY. SENATOR RICHARD PAN- ROCK I
GREW UP TO BE IMPLEMENTED BY
THE- YOU. WORK IN SEVEN ZERO
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE PIECE
BUT. SIX FIVE ON YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I HOPE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RANDY PERRY WITH KORAK-
IN OPPOSITION DISCONTENT THANKS
THANK YOU SIR. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KELLY READ FOR
KEEP CALIFORNIA SAFE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANKS IS LIKE SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JERRY ALL THE CITIZEN IN FOLSOM
AND I OPPOSE. SB SEVEN TEN.
THANK YOU MAX IS FINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN JUST GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALICE CHOICE
FROM SACRAMENTO AND AYE OPPOSED
SB SEVEN CAN. NINE SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT DESCRIBES. DID
YOU GET THE KERR HI YOUR ORDER
DID. UNDER. THIRTY EIGHT. THE
LITTLE AND FUNDERDOME FORTY
THREE IS GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR
FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TOTALING THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK THREE NINE THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN. I GOT A LINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING AT
THEIR FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE- SB SEVEN CAN.
BELITTLING THIRTY TO HIS CREDIT.
ONE THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANKS FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
FIVE SEVEN CERTAINLY LINE IS
OPEN GET. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN MURPHY I'M CALLING
YOU FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA- STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
SEVEN PM. THANK YOU. THANK SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIX FIVE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR.
THIS GUY HAD. OKAY. WHAT A LINE
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE AT.
THANKS SIX FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT OLYMPIC TENDERED
AND PICK OR GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S JENNIFER RAFF AND CAUSED
ME TO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
SB SEVEN TEN S. B. SEVEN FOUR
TWO. BUT BUT A LINE THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARLENA DEEP RANGE I'M
FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I'M
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TEN.
THANK YOU. COMMENTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS. I
MISSED. YOUR LACKEY AND THEN MR
LEE. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
REBEKAH BAR QUE HAN. BURKE.
LOOKS LIKE JUST RIGHT BY. YOU
HAVE A LINEUP COULD YOU FIRST
MR LACKEY OKAY. FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO SAY THAT I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR YOU CENTER BRADLEY
BUT- BRADLEY. BUT I'M OFF TO A
GREAT START. PLEASE PLEASE
FORGIVE ME I'M NOT THAT THAT'S
PART OF THE SECOND TIME I'VE
DONE THAT TO YOU HERE WITHIN
THE LAST MONTH SO I REALLY
GREATLY APOLOGIZE. YOU DESERVE
BETTER THAN THAT BUT- I THINK
ALSO THE PUBLIC DESERVES BETTER
THAN THIS I THINK THAT- IF
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE PURGE
OF CONFLICT OF INTEREST THE
BILL SHOULD BE MORE BALANCED.
AND EVEN HANDED WHY LIMIT THE
CONFLICT TO CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM POLICE
GROUPS WHAT ABOUT CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM GEORGE SOROS AND MANY OF
THE SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WITH A
CLEAR AGENDA. A PROSECUTING
MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
FOR ALLEGED EXCESSIVE FORCE
VIOLATIONS I THINK IT'S
IMBALANCED AND IT'S UNFAIRLY
FOCUSED. ON FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS OF POLICE GROUPS. SO I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND DIDN'T MR LEE YOUR NEXT.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT YEAH THOSE WE
HOLD WITH HIGH RESPECT TO IT TO
ENFORCE OUR LAWS ARE ALSO HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY BREAK
THEM TO OR IN THE- ABUSE OUR
PUBLIC TRUST SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK THIS BILL SUPPORT I KNOW
WE'VE HAD. SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
INFLUENCE OF CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS THE FACT EARLIER
THIS YEAR. AND I'M HAPPY TO
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION I HAD
A MORE WIDE RANGING BANNOCK ON
COUNTY CONTRIBUTIONS TO
POLITICAL CANDIDATES AND I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE THEIR SUPPORT ON
IN THE FUTURE. AND DOING SUCH
MEASURES LIKE THAT AND WE'VE
HAD COME IN CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS BUT I THINK THIS NARROWLY.
TAILORED BILL GETS TO THE HEART
OF SOMETHING RIGHT. EVEN THE
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WHICH I THINK IT IS.
PUTS IDEA'S AND AGES IN A
COUPLE POSITION WHERE IF THERE
IS SOME SOLUTIONS LIKE THIS IT
IS. AND WE'VE HEARD THIS
DOCUMENT MANY TIMES THAT
UNCOMFORTABLY CHAU PROSECUTING
YOUR FRIEND ESSENTIALLY. AND
PUTS THEM IN AWKWARD POSITION
AND THIS KIND OF MAKES IT SO
THAT WE CAN. HAVE THE BEST
JUDICIAL PROCESS ALSO WITHOUT
THE AWKWARDNESS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. AND GIVES I THINK A
MORE FAIR SHOT TO BOTH PARTIES
I THINK AND IT'S REPORTING. SO
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THIS
BILL I'M BE SUPPORTED TODAY AND
I WOULD HOPE TO JOIN AS A CO
AUTHOR WHEN. APPROPRIATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SOMEONE WITH.
MISS REBECK ABOUT CAYENNE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD AND I'M
ALSO GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL FOR MANY OF THE REASONS
EXPRESSED BY MY COLLEAGUE. BUT
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION THAT HAS BEEN
POSED ABOUT WHY IT ONLY RELATES
TO CHARGING DECISIONS- FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHY ISN'T
THE BILL BROADER RIGHT IF THERE
WERE SOME REASON THAT THEY
WOULD NEED TO CHARGE- A PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
DA SAID YOU HAVE A PROSECUTOR
WHO HAS TAKEN. MONEY FROM THE
DEFENSE BAR WHY WOULDN'T THAT
BE A SIMILAR CONFLICT OF
INTEREST I GUESS I JUST. WANNA
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SORT OF WHY WE ARE
LOOKING AT A BROADER CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AT. THE END IT'S A
FAIR QUESTION BUT HERE WE ARE
TRYING TO. TAKE ONE ISSUE AT A
TIME AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
PROSECUTING A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ALMOST NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE. DO THIS CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND- THEY HERE IN THIS
SITUATION. THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT TAKING A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION. AGAIN THE- THESE
UNIONS PROVIDE- THE TOURNEY'S
IN THE LEGAL DEFENSE FUNDING.
FOR THOSE OFFICERS AND WORDS
PROSECUTORS DON'T SO I MEAN I
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS DON'T SO THAT
STICK. THE CLEAR DIFFERENCE THE
SAME UNION THAT IS PROVIDING A
CONTRIBUTION TO A DA OR- OR THE
AG IS AT THE SAME TIME. PAYING
FOR THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY FOR
THOSE OFFICERS SO THAT'S WHERE
THE REAL CONFLICT AND- AND
DIFFERENT FROM- EIGHT EIGHT.
DEFENSE ATTORNEY. THANK YOU AND
AS I SAID I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT WORK AND- AS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE SAID. YOU
KNOW THERE'S SO LITTLE FAITH
RIGHT NOW IN THE SYSTEM AND I
THINK THAT THIS IS A STEP IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE REBUILD
TRUST IN THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE. AB BUT I DO THINK
IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT IF WE
BELIEVE. THIS WILL BE HERE FOR
THE FIRST BILL OF YOURS I
REALLY CAN'T SUPPORT- I THINK
YOU KNOW I GET MONEY FROM LABOR
UNIONS. I WROTE ALL THE TIME ON
THINGS THAT AFFECT THEM. AND I
REALLY DO THINK- IF YOU'RE
SUSPICIOUS OF DJS YOU SHOULD BE
SUSPICIOUS OF LEGISLATORS. IN
TERMS OF WHY THERE AREN'T MORE
PROSECUTIONS FIRST OF ALL THE
WAY THE LAW WAS WRITTEN IT WAS
JUST VERY HARD AND PARTICULARLY
INTERPRETATIONS BY THE SUPREME
COURT. IT WAS JUST VERY HARD
BECAUSE IF THE OFFICER HAD ANY
KIND OF JUSTIFIABLE FEAR. YOU
COULDN'T PROSECUTE THEM AND SO-
ONE OF THE RARE CASES WAS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE I LIVE
WHERE THEY- PROSECUTED SOMEONE
WHO SAID THAT HE GRABBED HIS
GUN WHEN HE MEANT TO GRAB HIS-
TASER. AND ARM AND KILLED THE
YOUNG MAN AT A BART STATION. HE
WAS PROSECUTED FOR
MANSLAUGHTER. ACTUALLY HE WAS
PROSECUTED FOR MURDER BUT THEY
GOT A CONVICTION FOR
MANSLAUGHTER- WE THERE IS A
CURRENTLY PROSECUTION GOING ON
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY NOW. ARE WITH
AND THE ONLY REASON IT'S GOING
ON IS THAT WE PASSED A BILL
THAT MAKES IT SO YOU HAVE TO
GET YOU CAN ONLY USE FORCE WHEN
IT'S NECESSARY. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT MY DA IS ABLE TO NOW
PROSECUTING OFFICER WHO SHOT
SOMEONE WHO HAD A BASEBALL BAT.
AND YEAH SO I THINK THINGS ARE
CHANGING- BUT I DON'T THINK
THIS IS A WAY TO PROMOTE MORE
CHANGE- THE REASON WHY-
PROSECUTORS AND POLICE I THINK.
DO YOU OFTEN SEE THINGS THE
SAME WAY AS THE NATURE OF WHAT
THEY DO IN THE COOPERATION
THAT'S BETWEEN THEM. AND I
DON'T THINK THIS WILL CHANGE
ANY OF THAT SO I WON'T BE
VOTING FOR YOUR BILL TODAY I'M
SORRY. ANYONE ELSE. HERE TO
READ. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD FROM THE REPRESENTING
YOUR BILL TODAY AND- YEAH ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS I HAVE ABOUT
THIS IS. SO THE DA RECUSES
HIMSELF WHO PROSECUTES. ARTISTS
EITHER TOURNEY GENERAL ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS A CONFLICT AS WELL
BILLS ASSIGNORS SPECIALLY
GENERAL IS ALSO SUBJECT TO THIS
YES SO YOU'RE SAYING GOES FROM
FROM THE DA'S OFFICE UP TO THE
STATE LEVEL. AND SO AND IF
THERE'S A CONFLICT THERE IS A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR. OKAY
BECAUSE- YEAH I THINK ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS WITH THIS IS THAT-
DATE WE ARE THE OBVIOUSLY IF
THE DA HIMSELF. IS SUPPOSEDLY
UNDER THIS GUY THE GUYS OF I'M
GOING TO NOT BE FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL BECAUSE I'VE ACCEPTED
CONTRIBUTION. I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT STOPS IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T STOP ANY ORGANIZATION
BECAUSE EVERY WORKS FOR HIM.
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE BASICALLY
TAKING ALL THESE AND PUTTING
THEM INTO SOMEBODY ELSE'S LAP.
AND AND LOSING THAT THAT
CONTROL OF FOR THAT AREA THAT
LOCAL AREA IN THAT COMMUNITY-
SO- IT ALSO ASSUMES THAT DID A
DA WOULD WANT TO PROTECT.
BECAUSE AN ORGANIZATION HAS-
SUPPORTED HIM HE WOULD WANT TO
PROTECT A ONE ONE BAD OFFICER
AND MOST OF THE DA-
PROSECUTIONS- THAT I'VE SEEN-
OR SITUATIONS WHERE THEY DO
HAVE. OFFICERS THAT HAVE- BEEN
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR
WHATEVER ISSUE IT IS THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF. PUBLICITY
INVOLVED IN THOSE AND THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PRESSURE
ON THEM- BY ONE GROUP TO
PROSECUTE THE HECK OUT OF
SOMETHING AND BY THE OTHER TO
ADMINISTER A FAIR PROCESS. AND.
AND THE MOST OF THE TIME I HAVE
SEEN THEM. I LAND- WHERE THE
LAW TELLS THEM THEY HAVE TO
LAND BECAUSE THAT'S THEIR
PROFESSIONAL OBLIGATION TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ELECTED THEM IT'S
THEIR JOB THE PEOPLE ELECTED
THEM TO DO THAT JOB AND I DON'T
THINK- THIS. CREATES A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE IMPARTIAL AND I
HAVE NOT SEEN OUR- YOU KNOW
THE- PLA'S UNIONS AT CENTRO
WHEN OFFICER BELONGS TO A UNION
THEY'RE OBLIGATED BY LAW. TO
REPRESENT THEM THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY WANT A BAD OFFICER TO
STAY IN THE RANKS- THEY JUST
HAVE TO PAY FOR THE DEFENSE AND
THE DEFENSE WILL PUT ON THERE.
IT DID ATTORNEY WILL I MEAN THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WILL PUT ON
THEIR CASE- AND I DON'T SEE
THAT. IF WE'RE GOING TO ACCUSE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OF BEING-
BEING AN ETHICAL BASICALLY
BASED ON CONTRIBUTIONS HI DAD
AND- I THINK THE CITIZENS WOULD
SEE THROUGH THAT AND HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AT THE BALLOT BOX
SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IT'S WITH THE
CITIZENS AND IF YOU HAVE A
PROSECUTE AG A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THAT'S NOT GOING TO
PROSECUTE ANY POLICE. ISSUES
WHEN THERE COULD BE A VERY
OBVIOUS CASE A PERSON CAN GET
REMOVED IN OFFICE IT'S HAPPENED
BEFORE. AND IN DEVICE VERSA TO
WHEN SOMEBODY SEES SOMETHING
WHERE- OTHER PEOPLE ARE GETTING
PROSECUTED. THEY WIND UP
GETTING RECALLS OR BOARD
REMOVED ENOUGH FROM OFFICE AND
EXTEND THE RUN. SO IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO GO DOWN
THIS PATH OF MISTRUST OF A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY- THEY HAVE AN
OATH THEY THEY THEY TAKE AN
OATH- TO UPHOLD THE LAW. AND IF
THEY DON'T THEY WON'T BE
ATTORNEYS BECAUSE OF THE BAR
WILL TAKE CARE OF THAT. SO I
STRUGGLE WITH THAT THIS IS A
STRUGGLE WITH THIS A LOT. AND I
DON'T DIE I CAN'T SEE THAT I
CAN SUPPORT IT. THANK. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE SOONER BRADFORD THANK
GOODNESS CHAIRED THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I THINK WE FIND
OURSELVES IN A VERY UNIQUE
SITUATION FAR DIFFERENT THAN A
CITY COUNCIL PERSON FAR
DIFFERENT THAN A LEGISLATIVE
BODY WHO TAKES A CONTRIBUTION
AGAIN WE DON'T DETERMINE LIFE
OR DEATH WE DON'T DETERMINE THE
BILITY OF SENDING SOMEONE TO
AND CHARGING SOMEONE. IF THIS
IS A PERFECT WORLD THEN YOU
WOULD HAVE MORE THAN 1% OF
OFFICERS CHARGED IN LESS THAN
THAT CONVICTED IF THIS IS FAIR
THERE IS INCESTUOUS
RELATIONSHIP THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN ONE FOUR SUBMIT NDAS
AND JUDGES AND IT'S HISTORICAL
AND WE'VE HAD A HUNDRED YEARS
UP WE'VE HAD THIRTEEN HUNDRED
SHOOTINGS. IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. HOW MANY OFFICERS WERE
CHARGED. THIRTEEN WHO WOULDN'T
LOVE BILLS OCT ALL THOSE
THIRTEEN WHICH CHARGE FROM YOU
WERE CONVICTED ONE. I HAVE A
NEIGHBOR WHICH ONE IS MOST
BRILLIANT. DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
PROBABLY AN L. A. COUNTY HAVE
NOT TO STATE. HE WAS APPOINTED
TO THE BENCH A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO. AFTER TWO YEARS ON THE
BENCH HE RESULT HE RESIGNED
BECAUSE OF THE INCESTUOUS
RELATIONSHIP THAT EXISTED
BETWEEN THE D. EIGHT AND THE
INVESTIGATORS OF POLICE
SHOOTINGS BECAUSE WHO
INVESTIGATES POLICE SHOOTINGS
OTHER POLICE OFFICERS AND THE
MAJORITY OF JUDGES COULD EVEN
GET JUDGES TO GO ALONG EVEN IN
A GRAND JURY INDICTMENT LIKE TO
SAY IT'S EASIER TO INDICT A HAM
SANDWICH THAN A- THAN A POLICE
OFFICER. AND MY GOOD NEIGHBOR
SAID I HAD TO RESIGN FROM THE
PRIOR TO GOING TO THE BENCH D.
EIGHT. AND IT'S A CLEAR
INCESTUOUS RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN OFFICERS AND ALL WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT IF YOU MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION. TO A DEAR. TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THERE'S A
CONFLICT AGAIN IF THERE WAS NOT
A CONFLICT YOU WOULD HAVE MORE
THAN 1% OF OFFICER BEING CHARGE.
LET'S GONNA TALK ABOUT
CONVICTED CHARGE WHO DID YOU
WRITE THAT OFF. IS TO IN NATURE
OF THE RELATIONSHIP THAT HAS
EXISTED FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS AND IT'S FAR DIFFERENT
THAN AGAIN LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND HERE IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY WE ALL TAKE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE HAVE TO
RECUSE OURSELVES TO CERTAIN
AGREED ON A LOT OF THINGS BUT
THE CONFLICT THAT EXIST. HERE
WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS FAR
DIFFERENT AND YES IN THE
CONSTITUTION IT'S DATA STATE
BAR STATES THAT OFF. A
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT THAT YOU
KNOW YOU CAN ADDRESS THOSE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST BUT THERE
ARE LOOPHOLES THAT EXIST. AND
THAT- GUIDELINES THAT ARE FAR
DIFFERENT FROM ANYTHING THAT WE
HAVE TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR SO
IN ORDER TO BUILD TRUST. WE
NEED TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THIS
IS ABOUT TRUST AGAIN. MOST OF
THE OFFICERS THE OFFICERS WHO
BEAT RODNEY KING WITHIN A IT'S
OUR LIFE I DON'T LOST YOUR JOBS
THEY'RE STILL WORKING TODAY NO
ONE FOUND GUILTY OF ANYTHING
AND WE SAW ALL IN LIVING COLOR
HOW MANY MORE BRIANNA TAYLOR'S
DO WE NEED I MEAN MORE GEORGE
FLOYD DOING BUT MOST OF THOSE
OFFICERS ARE NEVER CONVICTED IF
IT WASN'T FOR VIDEO TAPE DEREK
SHOPPING WOULD BE WALKING THE
STREETS TODAY. BECAUSE NO DA
WOULD HAVE PROSECUTED THIS GUY.
NO D. A. WHAT IT CHARGES GOT.
THIS IS ABOUT RIGHTING A WRONG
THIS IS ABOUT LOOKING AT
HISTORICAL PRACTICES THAT
EXISTED BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND BUILDING TRUST
AND PROVIDING TRANSPARENCY AND
MOVIE REMOVING THAT INCESTUOUS
RELATIONSHIP THEY CLEARLY
EXISTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. AND I TO MISTER BRADFORD
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
YEAR- I THOUGHT LONG AND HARD
ABOUT. ACTUALLY ALTERING THIS
BILL AND I THOUGHT THAT I WOULD
BE A LITTLE. TO RESTRICTIVE
WELL WHEN I LOOK AT THIS IT IS
THIS TERM PERCEPTION IS REALITY.
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT JUDGES AND
WE KNOW A LOT OF JUDGES IT
CAN'T CONTRIBUTED CAMPAIGNS
THEY CAN'T ENDORSE THINGS AND
WE HAVE MORE FAITH IN THEIR
JUDGMENT. AND WE DO WITH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND SO- I THINK THIS
BILL IS A MEASURE BILL AND THAT
YOU GIVE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
INDIVIDUAL TO STILL CONTRIBUTE
AND YOU GIVE THEM STILL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY HAVE
THEIR VOICE AND TO SPEAK IN THE
IN THE POLITICAL SYSTEM-
WITHOUT RESTRICTING THEM AND
SO- I THINK THIS THIS IS A GOOD
COMPROMISE IN IN A LOT OF WAYS.
AND THAT- WE SHOULD GO AHEAD
AND NOT ONLY BOTH WHICH IS MOVE
THIS ALONG. BUT- MAYBE D. A.
SHOULD BE AT THE HIGHER RANK OF
ART AT THE HIGHER. VISIBILITY
OF WHAT THE JUDGES. BUT THAT'S
FOR ANOTHER DAY RIGHT NOW LET'S
JUST TAKE THIS FIRST STEP. AT
BEING ABLE TO GIVE THE D. A.'S.
THE CREDIBILITY THAT THEY NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD. AND SO WITH
THAT TEACHER IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. CALDERON ON SB SEVEN
TEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD THE
MOTION IS G. PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI GENSER ATTY LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAN LI LI
HI CORK. QUICK NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO THEY ARE TELL NO C. R.
TURNOUT WICKS WICKS I. THE
MESSAGE ON CALL EACH TO THANK
YOU MORE. AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY FOR A CARD SB. FIVE SIX
SIX SEVEN- AGAIN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN EMBERS- I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB FIVE SIX
SEVEN A BILL THAT WILL IMPROVE
THE STATE FELONY DETERMINATE
SENTENCING PROCESS I'M
ACCEPTING TO SUGGEST TO
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE KNOWLES'S IS- TO
MAKE PENAL CODE SECTION. ELEVEN
SEVENTY POINT ONE PERTAINING TO
ENHANCEMENTS CONSISTENT WITH
THE APPROACH IN MY BILL THAT
SECTION WOULD OTHERWISE SUNSET
ON JANUARY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO IF THIS
BILL IS NOT AMENDED. JUST A
LITTLE BACKGROUND CURRENT LAW
SPECIFIES THAT IF THE STATUTE
SPECIFIES THREE POSSIBLE SINCE
SINCE SHE TURNED FOUR FELONY
OFFENSES LOW MEDIC MIDDLE OR
HIGH WITH VARIATIONS OF TIME TO
BE SERVED THE CHOICE
APPROPRIATE. APPROPRIATE TERMS
REST WITH THE DISCRETION OF THE
COURT EXISTING LAW SUNSETS
BEGAN ON JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND S. B. FIVE SIX
SEVEN IS A GOOD REPLACEMENT IT
MAKES THE SYNCING PROCESS A
LITTLE BIT MORE FAIR- THIS BILL
CREATES A PRESUMPTION OF
SENTENCING A JUDGMENT. NOT TO
EXCEED THE MIDDLE TERM UNLESS
THERE'S AGGRAVATED.
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT JUSTIFY-
IMPOSITION OF A HIGHER TERMS.
OF THIS BILL PROVIDES- THAT
WHEN I HIGHER TERMISM PULLS THE
FACTS SUPPORTING THOSE
AGGRAVATION SO MUST BE
STIPULATED. TO BY THE DEFENDANT
OR SUBMITTED TO THE JURY AND
PROVEN BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT OR FOUND BY THE COURT IN
A BENCH TRIAL IN THAT INSTANCE
WHERE THERE WAS NO JURY
INVOLVED. SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
ALLOWS THE PARTIES TO DISPUTE
THE FACTS IN THE RECORD OR
PRESENT ADDITIONAL FACTS THIS
MEASURE PERMITS DEFENDANTS TO
REQUEST I BY KATIE HEARING OF
TRIAL CHARGES TO BE SEPARATE IT
SEPARATED FROM ENHANCEMENTS
UNLESS THE FACTS AT ISSUE IS
ALREADY A ELEMENT OF THE CHARGE
OF THE FENCE. IN CONTEXT OVER
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM WHILE
IT IS APPROPRIATE TO PUNISH
PEOPLE FOR COMMITTING CRIMES WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GIVE
IMPACTED PEOPLE PROPER DUE
PROCESS THAT IS BUILT ON
FAIRNESS AND FAX. S. B. A FIVE
SIX DOES JUST THAT FINALLY LONG
SINCE THE SINCE COSTS THE STATE
LOTS OF MONEY AND ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
REHABILITATING PEOPLE AND BRING
THEM BACK. TO THE FOLD AND TO
SOCIETY WE NEED TO REVERSE THIS
PRACTICE OF A FEEL OF WHAT I
SHOULD SAY OF A FILL PRACTICE.
I HAVE ONE WHEN THIS- HERE
TODAY- STE STEPHEN- MUNCUL. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CRIMINAL
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MISTER MOM KILLED HAS SPENT
FORTY THREE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
AS AN ATTORNEY AND HAS A
CERTIFIED. IS A CERTIFIED
SPECIALIST IN CRIMINAL LAW
AFTER STEP TESTIMONY WILL- STAY
ONLINE TO ASSIST US IF THERE'S
ANY TELESCOPE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND MEMBERS ARE
RESPECT US FOR ABOUT. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD. I WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. STEPHEN MONK HELP
FROM. THESE OTHER GERMAN. YEAH
THAT'S FINE STATE RUN CAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CJ AND
SPONSOR THIS BILL. ANY FACTS
USED TO INCREASE THE SENTENCE
ABOVE THE STATUTORY MAXIMUM
MUST BE PROVEN BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT AT TRIAL OR
ADMITTED BY THE SENATE. THAT
WAS THE HOLDING YOUR CUNNINGHAM
VERSUS CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THIS LEGISLATURE RESPONDED TO
THE DECISION BY ATTEMPTING TO
FINESSE THE IDEA OF QUOTE
STATUTORY MAXIMUMS SAYING
RECORD WAS FREE TO CHOOSE ANY
OF THREE AVAILABLE TERMS. BUT
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO
REQUIREMENT FOR PROOF OF
AGGRAVATING FACTS AS THE
SUPREME COURT REQUIRED AND FOR
THAT REASON SHE SHE J. HAS
ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT THE
PRESENT. SYSTEM IS STILL
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. SB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN IS THE FIX TO THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL. BY AMENDING
PENAL CODE SECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY SUBDIVISION B. IT
REQUIRES PROOF OF AGGRAVATING
FACTS AT TRIAL OR ADMISSION BY
THE DEFENDANT. IT ALSO REQUIRES
THAT THE TRIAL OF THOSE FAXED
YOU SEPARATED OR BIFURCATED
HUNDRED GUILT TRIAL IF THE
DEFENDANT REQUESTS. THIS IS TO
AVOID PREJUDICE FROM FACTORS
NOT RELATED TO THE PREFER CAL.
THESE NEWARK. ONLY APPLY IF THE
PROSECUTION IS SEEKING AN
AGGRAVATED TERMS. FIFTY EIGHT
THANKS OR LOWER TERM WILL BE
ADEQUATE PUNISHMENT THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS DON'T COME INTO
PLAY. THE PROSECUTOR CAN EVEN
PRESENT AGGRAVATING FACTS AT
SENTENCING TO SUPPORT AN
ARGUMENT FOR THE MIDDLE TERMS.
WITHOUT DOING THE PLEADING
IMPROVES OUR REQUIREMENTS JUST
AS THEY HAVE ALWAYS DONE IN THE
PAST. IGNORE THE DA IS SEEKING
A MAXIMUM SENTENCE INVEST 3% OF
FELONY CASES THAT ACTUALLY GO
TO TRIAL. NOT ALL OF THEM WILL
INVOLVE A BIFURCATED TRIAL.
DIFFERENT AGGRAVATING FACTORS
WILL BE PROVEN AS PART OF THE
EVIDENCE OF JAIL THERE'S NO
BIFURCATION. IF THE DEFENSE
DOES NOT REQUESTED THERE'S NO
BY FISH. AND EVEN WHERE THERE
IS A REQUEST TO BIFURCATE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE BIFURCATION
OF PRIOR CONVICTIONS AT TRIAL
SUGGESTED IN MOST CASES AFTER
THE JURY FIND SKILLED. IN THE
SENATE WILL EITHER ADMIT THE
AGGRAVATING TRACKS OR WEAVE
JURY SO THE COURT ALONG WILL
DECIDE ON THE CRUCIBLES FAX. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S AN AMENDMENT
TO THE VERSION BEFORE TODAY.
WHICH MADE ACCEPTED AND WE'RE
ALSO MADE CHANGES TO CANNOT.
ALONG BALANCE POINT ONE
REGARDING CHARGING- THIS-
PROPOSED AMENDMENT WOULD REMOVE
A SUNSET PROVISION. AND
HARMONIZE THE PROCEDURE
BETWEEN- THE CHARGES UNDER
ELEVEN SEVENTY AND BEING HAVE
SINCE THE SEVEN POINT ONE
WHERE. YOU'RE DEALING WITH AN
ENHANCEMENT WHICH HAS THREE
POSSIBLE TERMS. THERE'S A
MEMBER WOULD BE PRIMARILY JUST
ELEVEN SEVENTY POINT ONE
SUBDIVISION VINNY. AND THE
CHANGES AGAIN WOULD ONLY APPLY
WHERE THE PROSECUTION IS
SEEKING THE PROPER TERM OF THE.
THREE ALLOW FOR AN ENHANCED.
THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
REQUIREMENT SWEETEN HERE SON
THE MAN MAKES NO CHANGE AND
THAT- AND- THESE CHANGES WILL
FIND AND DEFINITIVELY. SOLVING
PROBLEM OF UNCONSCIOUS
SENTENCING. IN CAL. IN PRACTICE
THE CHANGE WILL OF THE ROLE
SMALL NUMBER. OF THE ALL SO
NUMBER OF CASES TO GO TO TRIAL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITHIN DAY UP. FORTY
TWO OH TWO. WE SEEM ONE YOU MAY
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
MORNING A LITTLE WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR ANYONE ELSE IN THE- IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. C. N. NONE
WILL GO OUTSIDE TO ANYONE TO
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SIX
HEARING NONE OPERATOR OUT CAN
GO TO THE TELEPHONE. AND OPEN
UP LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN BRADFORD. REPORT
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE SIX
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIRST
COMMENT IS FROM LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MARKO'S GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MARKET.
THANKS SIX HUNDRED AND TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MICHAEL KESSLER CALLING
ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALL OF
US OR NONE AND COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS IN THE LOBBY SENATE
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TEACHER OF TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND I'M ALSO
SPEAKER SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE FOR JUSTICE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANKS
SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PAUL GREEN AND I'M CALLING
INSPIRED AWHILE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
STRONG SUPPORTER BELT THANK YOU
HELLO MY NAME IS REMINISCENT OF
THE NUMBER. THE CALIFORNIA IN
THE IN SO. OF SB. FIVE SEVENTY.
TRY TRY. AT THANKS SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FISCAL AHEAD THE.
THANKS SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOW CAN YOU HEAR ME.
ASSEMBLY THANK. YOU VERY HIGH
LA- CALIFORNIANS WILL AGREE
THAT AFFECTS THE ENTRANCE
REPORT. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING JOINT COMMITTEE
THIS IS GREGORY PUT OUT WITH
THE ISSUE JUSTICE SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CORRECT ARE NOT HAPPEN GO
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND. THANKS SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD- MY NAME IS
MATTEL BOB ALONG CONGRESS ANY
SKI AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
FOR THE FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE.
JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
NINE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIS HOLINESS
CARE AND AYE OPPOSED SB FIVE
SIX SEVEN. IF. IN ONE MOMENT
PLEASE SO WE GOT THERE ANOTHER
LINE NUMBER. THANK SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK SEVEN ZERO AIRLINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY HAVE A
MARCH ZERO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COVERAGE WITH A DEJECTED AND
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. JERRY
COULD NOT GO TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LARRY MORSE CODE FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
UP BY PHONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FIVE SIX SEVEN I
WOULD NOTE THAT WE HAVE NOT HAD
A CHANCE TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENT YET- THIS BILL
AMENDS. CODE SECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY SUBDIVISION BE TOO SO
THAT A TRIAL COURT MAY ONLY
IMPOSE A SENTENCE AN
AGGRAVATION IF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AN AGGRAVATION
HAVE BEEN PROVEN BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT IF ADOPTED
THIS WOULD REQUIRE THE PEOPLE
TO THINK OF EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE
AND THAT AGGRAVATION AND PLEAD
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN ADVANCE OF
TRIAL. SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
UNDERMINES THE LEGISLATURE
SENSIBLE RESPONSE TO CUNNINGHAM
VERSUS CALIFORNIA IN WHICH THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
HELD THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DETERMINATE SENTENCING SCHEME
AS IT STOOD WAS NOT ACTUALLY
ADVISORY A JUDGE WAS REQUIRED
TO IMPOSE THE MIDDLE TERM
UNLESS IT BOUNCE BACKS IN
AGGRAVATION RENDERING THE
MIDDLE TERM THE TRUTH STATUTORY
MAXIMUM. ANY FACTS AN
AGGRAVATION BUS HAD TO BE
PROVEN BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT TO A JURY THREE MONTHS
AFTER THE DECISION AND
CUNNINGHAM IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SENATE BILL FORTY THE SO
CALLED CUNNINGHAM SIX WHICH
AMENDED PENAL CODE SECTION
ELEVEN SEVENTY SO THE TRIAL
COURTS WERE EMPOWERED TO
CONSIDER THE ENTIRETY OF THE
EVIDENCE. AND IMPOSE THE
MITGATED MIDDLE OR AGGRAVATED
TERM AS APPROPRIATE THE
LEGISLATURE DUST HELP THE
COURTS AND JURORS FROM BEING
OVERWHELMED BY LONG COSTLY
TRIALS WHERE THE PEOPLE WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO PROVE BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT HOLISTIC
FACTORS IN AGGRAVATION SUCH AS
THE DEGREE OF PLANNING OR
SOPHISTICATION OF A CRIME.
WHETHER THE CRIME CONSTITUTED A
HATE CRIME WHETHER THE
DEFENDANT TOOK ADVANTAGE OF A
POSITION OF TRUST OR A
VULNERABLE VICTIM AND THE LEVEL
OF VIOLENCE THE DEFENDANT. USED
IN THE COMMISSION OF A CRIME
SUCH TRACTORS AND SUGAR LESS.
OFFENDERS GET SH SAY. AND
CULPABLE OFFENDER GET SO. SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN REQUIRE A
BIFURCATED TRIAL ON THESE
AGGRAVATING FACTORS- I'M LAST
THE AGGRAVATING FACTORS AND
ELEMENTS OF THE CRIME. WHAT
ABOUT THE FACTORS THAT ARE NOT
AN ELEMENT OF THE CRIME BUT ARE
STILL AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
CHARGES SUCH AS THE
VULNERABILITY OF THE VICTIM
VICIOUSNESS CRUELTY AT CETERA.
THESE KINDS OF AGGRAVATING
FACTORS WOULD MOST LIKELY BE A
PART OF THE PROSECUTION'S CASE
IN CHIEF ANYWAY IT MAKES NO
SENSE FROM AN EFFICIENCY OR
COURT COSTS STANDPOINT BUT NOT
HAVE THE JURY MAKES THESE
FINDINGS AT THE SAME TIME THEY
ARE DECIDING GUILT ON THE CRIME
CHARGE. WE WOULD HOPE THAT
CENTER FOR BRADFORD WOULD
CONSIDER AMENDING THIS BILL SO
THAT IF AN AGGRAVATING FACTOR
IS NOT AN ELEMENT OF THE
OFFENSE WHAT WOULD NECESSARILY
BE PART OF THE PROSECUTION'S
EVIDENCE IT WOULD NOT HAVE TO
BE BIFURCATED. ALSO DEEP
CONCERNS THAT SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
SEVERELY RESTRICTS OF VICTIMS
PARTICIPATION IN THE SENTENCING
PROCESS FACTORS THAT THE VICTIM
WALKED THE COURT TO CONSIDER AN
AGGRAVATION COULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED. UNLESS THEY WERE
PLAYED IN ADVANCE OF JURY TRIAL
AND PROVEN BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT THIS WOULD BE
PARTICULARLY UNFAIR IN CASES
WHERE EVIDENCE WAS EXPRESSLY
EXCLUDED AS A RELEVANT OR
INFLAMMATORY. AS WE SAW WITH
THE HIGHLY PUBLICIZED BROCK
TURNER CASE A FEW YEARS AGO THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIM STATEMENT
AT SENTENCING WAS POWERFUL. AND
IMPACTFUL. SUCH TESTS TO.
SHOULD NEVER BE. BECAUSE OF
THESE CONCERNS THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IS RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. THANKS ARE. THANK YOU WE
NOW BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO ARE THERE
ANY. IN PERSON WITNESSES. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. SEEN NONE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES OUTSIDE
THE CAPITAL NEAR THE LONG. NONE
OF WILL NOW GO TO THE EIGHTEEN
ANTI OPERATOR OPEN APPLIES FOR
A- SB FIVE SIX SEVEN BRADFORD-
FOR TELEPHONE TESTAMENT. TO
SOAK UP TO BREAK I'M INTERESTED
FIVE SIX SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE AT THIS TIME. ONE
COMMENT FROM LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU INTERNET
NINETY THREE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE MARLENA
DIFFERING AND I'M FROM SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY I'M IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANKS FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO OKAY YES YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CLEARLY
A MOTHER OF TWO I'M ALSO THE
FOUNDER OF UNITED WE STAND AND
WE HAVE A THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO MEMBERS IN OUR GROUP MOST
OF THEM ARE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS- SPEAKING ON THEIR
BEHALF WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN THANK YOU KNOW
AND SB FIVE SIX. THANK YOU.
WELL I TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO YES NAME AN
ORGANIZATION FIFTY TWO COULD GO
AHEAD. CLOSE CALL HELLO. I
NEIGHBORHOOD ISRAEL AND. SEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL YES
GO AHEAD NAME AND ORGANIZATIONS.
OH SORRY- MY NAME IS GRAHAM
WILLIAMS I'M WITH SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT AND MEMBER OF THE
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE PROJECT THIS
AND ON THE COMPORT OF FIVE BILL
FIVE SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU. I
THINK YOU AT THIS TIME. SO WILL
NOW BRING YOU BACK TO COMMITTEE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK SEEING NONE YOU MAKE
CLOSE MISTER BRADFORD THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OF MR MEMBERS
FOR THIS IS THIS REPORT MEASURE
AGAIN WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
ELIMINATE THESE LONG SENTENCES
THAT USUALLY FIND THEMSELVES
FALLING ON PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
THE POOR BY GIVING DISCRETION-
NOT NECESSARILY IMPOSING THE
MOST HORSES- SENTENCE AND
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF. ALLEGATIONS
THAT WERE MADE TO HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DEFENDANT
TO. TESTIFY IN A BIFURCATED-
SITUATION AGAINST THOSE CHARGES
ONLY CREATES A AGAIN GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS AND
AS WE'VE SEEN- THIS MASS
INCARCERATION IS ONLY IMPACTED
POOR PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN THIS JUST ALLOWS US TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD SO TO SPEAK
AND RESPECT LESS RAGO. JACKSON
THANK YOU MISTER BRADFORD FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD TOM THIS
IS JUST ANOTHER. PILLAR IN OUR
ABILITY TO CORRECT A LOT
INJUSTICES IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. INSULA CHEERS
RECKON I VOTE MEANT JERRY YOU
MAKE CALDERON. THE BILL'S
IMPROPERLY MOVED AND SECONDED
ON SB FIVE SIX SEVEN BY SENATOR
BRADFORD THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI
LACKING NOW PARA QUE HAN
BARRACK HE HAD I BELIEVE. B. I.
CORK I PORK AYE SANTIAGO. C. R.
TELL. WICKS ASSEMBLY MEASURES
ON CALL WE NEED ONE MORE THANK
YOU APPRECIATE MEMBERS INCHER
OKAY- SENATOR DORADO EUROPE- SB.
SEVEN THREE ONE. CRIMINAL
RECORDS RELIEF. OKAY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
WILL EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING SYSTEM FOR ARREST AND
CONVICTION RECORD RELIEF IN
THREE WAYS. WHEN IT COMES TO-
UP EXTENDED AUTOMATIC ARREST
RECORD SEALING TO FELONIES IF
THE INDIVIDUAL WAS NEITHER
CHARGED NOR CONVICTED SIX YEARS
AFTER THE ARREST. IT WOULD
EXTEND- AUTOMATIC CONVICTION
RECORD RELIEF TO NON SERIOUS
AND NON VIOLENT FELONIES. AFTER
AN INDIVIDUAL COMPLETES ALL
TERMS OF INCARCERATION
PROBATION. SUPERVISION POST
RELEASE SUPERVISION PAROLE AND
A FURTHER PERIOD OF FOUR YEARS
WITHOUT ANYNEW CONVICTIONS.
AND IT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF A FELONY TO
PETITION. IT WOULD BE BY
PETITION THE COURT FOR SEAT
SEEK THE CEILING BELIEF. THESE
PETITIONS ARE DONE ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS AND THE COURTS MAKE
THE FINAL DECISION. THERE EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
LIVING WITH AN ARRESTER
CONVICTION ON THEIR RECORD THE
ARE PARENTS NEIGHBORS CO
WORKERS FELLOW CHURCH GOERS. AT
ONE INDIVIDUAL COMPLETES THEIR
SENTENCE. THERE DEEMED TO HAVE
PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY
THEY'VE ACCEPTED RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THEIR ACTIONS. WHILE THEY
WERE INCARCERATED WE HAVE MANY
PROGRAMS WHICH THEY TAKE
CLASSES THERE EARNED DEGREES IN
ROLLING COUNSELING. THE PURSUE
THE REHABILITATION THEY WORK
HARD TO BE PREPARED FOR THEIR
RE ENTRY. BUT AFTER RELEASE.
INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO APPLY
THEIR NEW SKILLS TO USE. AND
BEGIN TO BUILD A NEW LIFE
THEY'RE HIT WITH LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF RESTRICTIONS AND
LIMITATIONS. ON REBUILDING
THEIR LIFE- AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CONVICTION RECORD STAYS ON.
UNTIL THEY REACH OF IT A
HUNDRED YEARS OF AGE. AND AS
MANY AS THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN DENIED
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF PAST
RECORDS A LOAN. THIS WILL NOT
GIVE UP WILL GIVE INDIVIDUALS
THE MEANS TO OVERCOME- US CIVIC
EXCLUSIONS THAT A PAST RECORD
BRINGS. THIS DOES NOT CHANGE
HOW EXPLAINED CHEN EXPUNGEMENT
RELIEF INTERACTS WITH
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING. IT DOES
NOT MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
EXISTING LICENSING DISCLOSURE
OBLIGATIONS- HIGH SENSITIVITY
LICENSING AGENCIES AND
EMPLOYERS WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
FULL ACCESS TO ALL RECORDS.
EVEN THOSE GRANTED RELIEF
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HUMAN SERVICES INVOLVING
CHILDREN. OF THE CARE OF
CHILDREN THE ELDERLY BANKING
AND COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND HIGH
SENSITIVITY EMPLOYERS THAT RELY
ON THE- J. LIVE SCAN
FINGERPRINT BACKGROUND WILL
ALSO CONTINUE TO HAVE. ALL FULL
ACCESS- SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
INCLUDES STRINGENT OVERSIGHT
AND STRICT SCRUTINY AT EVERY
SINGLE STAGE- IT PROVIDES AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO WEIGH IN ON ANY POTENTIAL
RELIEF GRANTED. I'M PROUD TO
SAY THERE'S A BROAD COALITION
OF ECONOMIC JUSTICE BUSINESS
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ORGANIZATIONS OF FAITH- THAT
ARE ALL TOGETHER IN THE NEXT
SINGLE COALITION. TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS- TO TURN THE PAGE
ON THE PAST AND BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD MY WITNESSES TODAY WILL
BE CRISTINA PERKINS AND
IMPACTED INDIVIDUAL AND
ACCORDING CO TIME DONE
DELEGATE. THE STEP ON DOING IS
FROM THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND HERE A PERSON IS
A LITTLE FROM CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. WILL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
BURKE MR PERKINS- MISTER NUNEZ
WHOEVER WANTS TO BEGIN FIRST BY
PHONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA PREPARED THEN I FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO A
TIME DAN GALECKI AND I'M QUIET
JUST BROKE MY BEACH SUPPORT IT
SENATORS SEVEN THIRTY ONE. I
HAVE EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC ABUSE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP AND
HOMELESSNESS DUE. TO-
CONVICTIONS ON MY RECORD.
RONETTE EAST- OAKLAND THERE WAS
A LOT OF PROPERTY CRIME IF I
MUCH LOVE THE- BY THE AGE
EIGHTEEN SAID IF YOU ST. NOW
END UP AND DRINKING I. AT THE
YEARS A COUPLE LOS. I ENDED UP
IN A VERY DANGEROUS
RELATIONSHIP WACKY FEED MY
FIRST CHECK OUT. ALBERT DAN I
TO GET A LIFE MY VIEWS YOU'RE
GOING TO KEEP MY CHILDREN SAFE.
DURING THIS TIME I ENDED UP
HOMELESS ARTICULATING CRIMES ET
COLD HERSELF. MY CHILD. I WAS
UNAWARE THAT MY LAW LEVEL COULD.
WHICH I MY LIFE FOR VERY LONG
TIME. THIS IS DID NOT HEAR THAT
WILL TELL WITH HAD NO. YOU'RE
ALSO TO FOR OFFER. IN MY PUBLIC.
WILL NOT ABLE TO IT ME. ALL
DISTRACTING. WHAT HAVE WE ON
MONDAY HEALTH AND I ACTUALLY
BROWN DOWN. TO SPEAK THEIR. THE
RESOURCES HELP CONNECT ME
COUNTRY IS NOT. AT A LOCAL WHY
PROGRAM THAT WILL TO HELP AND
IF THEY- WITH. RIGHT AT NUMBER
OF PARENTS YOU ANGER MAY.
CLASSES IN ON THIS THREE DITCH.
THAT FOUND OUT ABOUT IT. IN
SCRAPPY TO EXPRESS THEIR- THAT
ACHIEVE GOALS I HAD. OF THAT
MEANS THEY'RE YEARS I USED.
BECAUSE MY OAK CREEK. IT'S WHAT
ALLOWED IT VERY TEDIOUS. AND I
HAVE TO WRITE IT YOU LET IT'S
HOW THEY'RE NOT AND THAT AID
FOR. AND A POINT THAT MAKE THE
THIS THE OTHER. EACH HAD HIS
PLAN ALL MARCH ARE THAT CAN.
THEY PROVIDE THREE WERE. TO
HELL PROVIDE REHABILITATION.
ADULT OUT HAVE TO TURN IN A
THAT IF YOU HAVE SEEN. AT
POSITIVELY OF THEMSELVES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR TAX
CONVICTIONS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO HELP ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA IN MOVING THIS BILL
FOR YOUR- THANK YOU NEXT TO
HAVE MR NUNEZ. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS AS FUNDING YET I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO
KNOWN AS A. R. C. I. THE
SENATOR STATED THERE ARE EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE BUT HOW THE PAST ARREST
OR CONVICTION ON THEIR RECORD.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT A RECENT
REPORT BY CSJ START TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION WORKING AGE
CALIFORNIANS SALAS ONE IN TEN
LIVING WITH A FELONY RECORD
CALIFORNIA MAINTAINS AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CONVICTION RECORD
UNTIL THAT PERSON REACHES A
HUNDRED YEARS OF AGE BECAUSE OF
THE WIDESPREAD USAGE OF BACK
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN TODAY'S
SOCIETY. THESE RECORDS
PERMANENT PRESENT THOUSAND THE
BARRIERS RESULTING IN
WIDESPREAD CONSTRAINTS ON
COMMUNITY REINTEGRATION AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH THE REPORT ALSO
FOUND THAT THE STATE'S GROSS
DOMESTIC PRODUCT LOS TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS DUE TO THE
BARRIER A PAST FELONY RECORD
REPRESENTS FOR PEOPLE TO BE
FULLY EMPLOYED. AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ECONOMY. THANK KERR PER
ONLY PARTIAL RELIEF AND IS ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR SPECIFIC SUBSET
OF PEOPLE WITH CONVICTION
RECORDS FOR PEOPLE WITH
MISDEMEANORS AND A SMALL
CATEGORY PEOPLE WITH FELONIES.
I DID NOT RESULT IN PRISON OR
JAIL TERMS SO INDIVIDUALS SUCH
AS I CURRENTLY HAVE NO WAY TO
RUN. REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU
CHOSEN TO LIVE OUR LIVES. IT
SHOULD THEN COME TO NO SURPRISE
THAT 86% OF A. R. C. NUMBERS
I'VE NEVER HAD A RECORD
EXPUNGED AND MAJORITY EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT. HAVE BEEN DENIED
WORK BECAUSE OF THEIR PRIOR
CONVICTION HISTORY. BLOCKING
ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
ARE PRIMARY FACTORS DRIVING
RECIDIVISM. AND CONVICTION
RECORDS ARE SEVERE BARRIERS TO
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND AGAIN
COME AT THE COST OF TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. AS
CONTINUES OPEN UP AND
BUSINESSES FACE WORK SHORTAGES
WE SHOULD SUPPORT SMART AND
RESTORATIVE WAYS TO ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK AND FIND SECURE AND STABLE
HELPING. SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
IT'S ABOUT CREATING SECOND
CHANCE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
TAKE OWNERSHIP AND MAKE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT OF
THEMSELVES BECAUSE WE DESERVE
TO BE SEEN. BEYOND OUR CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
COME TO THE ROOM- ANY
INDIVIDUALS IN FORTY TWO OH TWO
IN SUPPORT OF A SB SEVEN. SEVEN
THREE ONE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS A LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE PRO
CLOSE SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND I BELIEVE YOU'RE
ALSO HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU. AFTER
ANYONE ELSE SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO. IT TO ANYONE OUTSIDE. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO A- ON THE LAWN I
BELIEVE LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT.
THIS. THREE NINE OR IS THERE.
C. NINE WILL GO NOW GO TO THE
PHONES EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WE
NOW READY TO HEAR FROM ANYONE
AND SUPPORT. OF SB. THREE SEVEN
THREE ONE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST TIME- COME FROM ONE OF
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS MALIBU
SAY ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT ABOUT THE SEVEN THIRTY
ONE. GUERLAIN FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MESSAGER MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMES DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABOR'S STRONG SUPPORT.
TOTALING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DONNA THANKS
REPRESENTING WHAT THE ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORTED AT THE SEVEN THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
SIX HUNDRED AND TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS MICHAEL KESSLER WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
TO SAVE THE COMMITTEE TIME I'LL
BE READING OFF THE LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE GIVEN US
THEIR PERMISSION TO SAY THEY'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
REPRESENT JUSTICE INITIATE
JUSTICE INLAND EMPIRE FAIR
CHANCE COALITION A NEW WAY OF
LIFE. DREAM CORPS JUSTICE
HOMIES UNIDOS. UNITE LA.
STARTING OVER IN SANTA CRUZ
BARRIOS UNIDOS CALIFORNIA OF
RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER OF
REFORM JUDAISM DEFY VENTURES
FAIR CHANCE PROJECT AND RESTORE
JUSTICE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS IN THE LOBBY SENATE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TEACHER OF TWENTY
THREE YEARS I AM ALSO SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDSHIP
CIRCLE FOR JUSTICE. AND ME ARE
VOICING OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBER ARPINO
PROBLEM BECAUSE BONTA
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY TACTIC
TO ALSO SAY THE COMMITTEE TIME
ARE ABOUT TO READ OFF A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT GAVE US THE
PERMISSION- STARTING WITH ON
COMMON LAW. BAKER CENTER POLICY
ALLIANCE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
CONDITIONS CONNECT NETWORK.
WHAT CURRICULA COMMUNITY
SYNAGOGUE. HOW ALLIANCE YOU CAN
JUSTICE SHEIKH ACTION BAY SMART
CAPTIVE CAL. PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION RIGHT NOW BY
YES AND ALSO COSPONSORED
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. THANKS FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TO MARK TOOK OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DIMITRIS THE WORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING M.
MEMBERS AS MANY HAD THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY WE ARE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL REPAIRS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT. THANKS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RUBEN
IS THE KNOWS THE TIME DONE
DELEGATE AND SOMEBODY WHO IS
JUST INTO. YOUR SUPPORT. SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. ELSEWHERE
CALIFORNIA. OUR YOU'RE PLAYING
SOME HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CATHOLIC
PRIVATE BEHALF OF THE MICHAEL
TO ZENICA POLICY AND MARK.
THANK SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE WANT
TO GET GOAL SANTA CLARITA I AM
OPPOSED. TO SEVEN THIRTY NINE.
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. NEXT.
THERE'S MORE NOTICE ALL
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU NOW. WE HAVE IN
OPPOSITION OF FRANCIE KOHLER
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS WHO SPEAK IN
PERSON THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY TO BEGIN THANK YOU CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FRANCIE
KAHLER I'M A PAST PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT SHARE THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED INVESTIGATORS I
REPRESENT OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES I'M
ALSO. A CRIMINAL DEFENSE
INVESTIGATOR AND HAVE BEEN FOR
OVER THIRTY SIX YEARS. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR HAS
AMEND. AMENDED SB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE TO INCLUDE VIOLENT AND-
SERIOUS FELONIES AND TO
PRESERVE ACCESS FOR FOUR YEARS
RATHER THAN THE TWO YEARS THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED.
HOWEVER THE MEASURE STILL
AUTOMATICALLY CLOSE RECORDS.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED AND SUBSEQUENT
COMPLETELY THEIR SENTENCES IN
ANY PAROLE OR PROBATION
VIOLATIONS ARE PART OF OUR- OUR
SOCIETY. WE SUPPORT A PROCESS
TO ENABLE PEOPLE TO HAVE A
SECOND CHANCE. PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT INVOLVES EMPLOYMENT IN
HOUSING IT'S CRITICAL. THERE
ARE HOWEVER MANY SITUATIONS.
WHEN A CRIMINAL CONVICTION IS
THAT A VITAL IMPORTANCE TO THE
PROTECTION OF OUR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. SUCH AS
EVALUATING STAKEHOLDERS IN
MERGERS. ACQUISITIONS AND
BUSINESS PARTNERSHIPS. VALUE IN
AN INDIVIDUAL EITHER AS A
ROOMMATE OR IN A ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIP. CRENNEL CUSTODY
AND- PARENTAL SKEWS ME CUSTODY
IN DIVORCE CASES. EDIBILITY IN
CIVIL LAWSUITS SUCH AS THE
RIGHT TO CONFRONT WITNESSES
WITH IMPEACHMENT INFORMATION.
IN THE INTEREST OF AN EQUITABLE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THIS INFORMATION
MUST ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO BOTH
SIDES IN A CIVIL PROCEEDING.
EVALUATED APPLICANTS BEEN
CONVICTED OF FINANCIAL FRAUD
FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S APPLYING FOR
FINANCIAL POSITION IN A CARE
GIVING SITUATION SUCH AS A
NURSING HOME AND PUTTING THE
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES AT
WORTH. AND I SEE THAT. THOSE
THAT ARE CONSIDERED FOR ELECTED
POSITION OUR POLITICAL
APPOINTEE- DO HAVE TO SELF
DISCLOSE IF THEY HAVE A
CONVICTION BUT THAT'S ONLY A
SELF DISCLOSURE AND NO WAY TO
VERIFY. FINALLY SB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE WHAT FOR ME THAT PROHIBIT
MANY BUSINESSES FROM COMPLYING
WITH EXISTING LAWS THAT INCLUDE
SPECIFIC LOOK BACK PERIODS AND
SET FOR THE MANDATORY SCOPE OF
SCREENING. INSTEAD OF THE BRIDE
AND COMPLETE CLOSURE OF
CRIMINAL RECORDS AN ALTERNATIVE
WOULD BE TO RESTRUCTURE ITS
PROVISIONS SO THAT THE SAME
CRITERIA APPLE COAL TO
EMPLOYMENT. THAT CURLY ALLOWS
ONLY SEVEN YEARS AND NOW IN THE
BILL IS FOUR YEARS WOULD
ACTUALLY APPLY TO HOUSING AS
WELL. THE SAME RULES THAT APPLY
TO EMPLOYMENT WOULD APPLY TO
HOUSING WHERE THE APPLICANT OF
WHERE THE RECEIVER OF THE
APPLICANT COULD ONLY LOOK BACK
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME AND NO
MORE INSTEAD OF THE CLOSER
RECORDS AND FOR THESE REASONS
SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE. ACCORDING
TO OUR VIEW DOES NOT STRIKE AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN THE
ABILITY OF CONVICTED
INDIVIDUALS TO BUILD A NEW
LIFE. AND THE PROTECTION OF THE
PUBLIC I URGE A NO VOTE IN THE
COMMITTEE UNLESS IT'S AMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY. WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO- IN OPPOSITION ME WITNESSES
OUTSIDE IN OPPOSITION AND ALONG.
SEEING NONE- EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATORS WOULD GO THE PHONE
LINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY OPEN UP
LINES FOR DOURADO SB SEVEN
THREE ONE. SHOP ADDITION FOR SB
SEVEN THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
OUR FIRST COMMENT FROM NINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET ME. YES GO
AHEAD YEAH HI MY NAME IS LEE
AND THEN THE AND THEN THE
MOTHER TO RESIDENTS AT THE BILL
AMONG THE FOUNDER OF UNITED WE
STAND WITH THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO MEMBERS BOTH OF THEM ARE
NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS AND- I- I
OPPOSE. ON SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
FOR THE RECALL OF THE SPEAKER
HAD MENTIONED EARLIER THAT IT
WOULD IMPACT ON SEARCH FOR
MANAGING RELEASED OR THANK YOU
THANK YOU BUT A LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS BEING A
YOUNG I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND- REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT OUR-
SO WHAT THANKS FOR THE MENTION
THAT EARLIER. UP VOTE. OKAY
THANK YOU. BUT A LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI KELLY COREY RIGHT
KEEP STONE INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES AND WE
OPPOSE AFTER THE SEVEN THIRTY
ONE FOR REASONS OUTLINED BY
FRANCIE KAHLER. THANK YOU
TOTALING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH NEW MEMBERS LAURIE BORIS-
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WE REMAIN OPPOSED
BUT IT HAD- FRUITFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE-
SPONSORS OF THE AUTHORS AND ARE
HOPING TO GET TO NEUTRAL. THANK
YOU. THANKS FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS THREE MARTIN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
ALSO A MEMBER OF CALLIE I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. COLLINES
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JENNIFER
YEN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA IT ISN'T AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE TO
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S CLAUDIA GOT US
SOME APPEARING IN LOS ANGELES
AND I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE HAD NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
URGENT- ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU CHEERS RECOMMEND
I VOTE MAKE. CALL THE ROLL. THE
BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
CENTER DRAWS THAT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SO YOU'RE A LACKEY. LACKEY NOW
BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND HI LETE
LETE I WORK. QUIRK I SANTIAGO
C. A. R. TELL NOW THEY ARE
TURNOUT WICKS. MEASURES ARE
CALLED NEEDS ONE MORE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO WE WILL.
RECESSED FOR ONE HOUR. I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXTRA FIVE MINUTES
WILL COME BACK A ONE OH FIVE.
RECESSED.
TO ONE OH FIVE FOR.
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IS BACK IN IN SESSION
FROM A BRIEF- RECESS AND WE'RE
RATING FOR US SENATOR JONES S.
B. THREE FIVE EIGHT PROPERTY
CRIMES MAIL THEFT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. IF. WE'LL GIVE HIM A FEW
MINUTES. IF HE'S NOT HERE SOON
WE CAN GO TO MISS LEYVA. SB TWO
NINE NINE BUT I BELIEVE HE'S
YOU SHOULD CENTER JONES SHOULD
BE HERE. WOW SLUG MAGIC. I
SPEAKING HEY APPEARS I'M
HEARING MY NAME ECHO THROUGH
THE WHOLE. AND I JUST WALKED IN
THE DOOR SWIMMING YOU'RE READY
FOR ME WE ARE ABSOLUTELY READY
FOR YOU THANK THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING A
UNDERSTANDING TO CENTERS CAN-
WANTED TO GO NOW BUT TO. SHE
HAD A- SHOULD I GO SOME HAD TO
DO SOME OTHER COMMITTEE MEETING
SO I THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT WITH US NO PROBLEM I
THINK THE SENATE IS. PROCESSING
ALL THE ASSEMBLY BILL SO WE'RE
DOING THE WORK FOR YOU GUYS.
SHARE MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH- FOR. INDULGING ME
THIS AFTERNOON AND ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT. SB THREE FIFTY WHICH I
THINK IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC SAFETY. BILL SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY EIGHT MODERNIZES
THEDEFINITION OF MAIL. AND
PROTECTS ALL FORMS OF MAIL
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
DELIVERIES PROCESS. CURRENTLY
THE DEFINITION OF MALE ONLY
PROTECTS U. S. P. S. UNITED
STATES POSTAL SERVICE MAIL. AND
THIS DEFINITION IS OVER SEVENTY
YEARS OLD. AND IS SIMPLY
OUTDATED. TODAY WE HAVE MANY
MALE CARE OPTIONS MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MALE RANGING
FROM POSTCARDS. TO LARGE
ENVELOPES TO PACKAGES. ALL
THESE SHOULD BE AWARDED THE
SAME THEFT PROTECTION AS USPS
MAIL. BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT
COVET NINETEEN SITUATION ONLINE
SALES HAVE INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY IN FACT BETWEEN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. IN APRIL
THIS YEAR ONLINE SALES HAS
INCREASED FORTY NINE PERCENT.
IN OUR COUNTRY. WHILE SHOPPING
ONLINE CAN BE EASIER AND SAFER
UNFORTUNATELY THIEVES WITH MALA
TENSION ARE INCREASINGLY
STEALING PACKAGES HE SEES ARE
OFTEN RE REFER TO AS PORCH
PIRATES. I JUST A PORTION
AMOUNT OF PORCH PIRACY OCCURS
IN CALIFORNIA IN 20001930% OF
ALL STOLEN PACKAGES ACROSS THE
NATION WERE STOLEN IN THIS
STATE. I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN 30%
OF ALL STOLEN PACKAGES AND
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WERE
STOLEN IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
PACKAGES CAN CONTAIN A WIDE
VARIETY OF HIS INITIAL ITEMS
SUCH AS MEDICATIONS AND FOOD.
MANY SENIORS AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND MY DISTRICT RELY ON THESE
PACKAGES EVERY DAY FOR DELIVERY
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR DAILY
SURVIVAL. NOW TO PROTECT THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE WE MUST TAKE
EVERY STEP TO STOP THIS PACKAGE
THEFT. THIS UPDATED DEFINITION
OF MAIL WILL COMBAT PORCH
PIRACY BY PROTECTING ALL TYPES
OF MAIL INCLUDING PACKAGES FROM
ALL TYPES OF MAIL CARRIERS. SB
THREE FIFTY EIGHT SIMPLY BRINGS
PARITY BETWEEN U. S. P. S. AND
NON U. S. P. S. MAIL THEFT.
NOTE THAT MISTER CHAIR THAT
CONCLUDES MY OPENING I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME
WITNESSES THAT SHOULD BE
STANDING BY. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT SO I HAVE A GYM KROEBER
SAN DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME BY
PHONE IS THERE ANOTHER ONE IN
ADDITION TO I THINK THAT'S IT
SIR. OKAY BUT- OPERATOR MATE
YOU CAN OPEN UP THE LINE-
KROEBER YOU HAVE A FIVE MINUTES.
THE IS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON JIM COOPER YEAH SAN
DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME AN
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
PURSUING JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY WE
BELIEVE SB THIRTY FIFTY EIGHT
IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR GOAL OF
SUPPORTING LAWS THAT WILL MAKE
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
SAY FOR. THE CLOVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RESULTED IN MORE
AMERICANS ORDERING ONLINE THAN
EVER BEFORE IN APRIL AND MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY U. S. CONSUMER
SPENT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ONLINE THAT 7%
MORE THAN OVER THE ENTIRE
HOLIDAY SEASON. AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. IN TWENTY TWENTY
NEARLY 60% OF AMERICANS THAT
THEY RECEIVE PASTORS DELIVERIES
AT HOME AT LEAST ONCE A WEEK AN
INCREASE OF TEN PERCENT. FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE NUMBER OF
CONSUMER EXPERIENCE PACKAGE
STAFF ALSO JUMP YEAR OVER YEAR
GROWING 2403% CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE THE STATE WITH
THE WORST PACKAGE STEP PROBLEM
IN THE NATION. WITH MORE PEOPLE
SHOPPING ONLINE MORE GOOD TO BE
DELIVERED TO PEOPLE'S HOMES BY
MEANS OTHER THAN THE
TRADITIONAL POSTAL SERVICE WELL
THIS BRINGS CONVENIENCE THAT IS
ALSO MADE PACKAGES AND INVITING
AND EASY TARGET RECEPTORS
THROUGHOUT THE DELIVERY
PROCESS. AS CONSUMERS WE OFTEN
DON'T KNOW WHERE OUR PACKAGES
ARE COMING FROM- WHAT KERRIER
IS DELIVERING THEM WE EXPECT
THAT ALL OUR PACKAGES WILL BE
PROTECTED THROUGHOUT THE
DELIVERY PROCESS REGARDLESS OF
THE CARRIER. THE LAW IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS NOT
EQUALLY PROTECT DIFFERENT FORMS
OF MALES AND IT CAN BECOME A
LIFE OR DEATH MATTER VERY
SPECIAL ITEMS FOR MEDICINE. BUT
A PERSONAL NOTE ONE MINUTE
CHECKS WERE STOLEN FROM MY
FRONT PORCH I HAD TO CANCEL MY
CHECKING ACCOUNT AND DEAL WITH
THE AGGRAVATION OF CHANGING
ACCOUNT INFORMATION ON ALL MY
DIRECT PAID BILLS. WE BELIEVE
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE LAW
RELATED TO PACKAGE THAT BE
OBLIGATED TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO VOTE YES ON SB THREE FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW
WILL BRING YOU INTO THE INTO
THE HEARING ROOM ANY OF ANYONE
HERE FOR IN PERSON AND SUPPORT
OF. THE BILL. CHINANDER WILL GO
TO THE- OUT SIDE IN THE COURT
IN KOREA ON THE LAWN AND
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SB.
THREE FIVE EIGHT. SEEING NONE
WILL NOW GO TO THE EIGHTEEN
ANTI OPERATOR WE'RE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF A SB. THREE FIVE
EIGHT. ISN'T ON A MAN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE MY FIRST COMMENT
WILL COME FROM A LINE OF EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
ARE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. THE
PART OF SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CONNECT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
EIGHT TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES HI L. LIU AND SIZE
SUPPORT HIGH SPEED. THREE SIX
EIGHT THREE FIVE EIGHT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WE NOW GO TO-
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE KATHY SURE
ACLU BY PHONE AND DECLINED
BACCHUS THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE ALLIANCE- BOTH BY
PHONE- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR YOU
CAN OPEN UP THE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
KATHY SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTIONS WE RESPECTFULLY NOT
DEPOSED SB THREE FIFTY EIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD DOUBLE THE
POTENTIAL JAIL TERM FOR THEFT
OF LOW VALUE PACKAGES FOR SIX
MONTHS UNDER CURRENT LAW TO
YEAR ASPECTOS DEL. I HAVE BEEN
THE VICTIM OF PACKAGED BACK
SEVERAL TIMES I UNDERSTAND
PEOPLE'S FRUSTRATION WITH THIS
CRIME. THAT SAID WHEN SOMEONE
COME BONTA MY COURTS AND FIELDS
MY TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR BOX OF
ORGANIC SACKS MY NEW IMMERSION
BLENDER OR EVEN A NICE DOWN
JACKET I GOT MY PARTNER FOR
CHRISTMAS. IT IS NOT AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE OR A JUST
RESPONSE TO BLOCK THAT PERSON
UP FOR A YEAR. THIS IS TRUE FOR
SEVERAL REASONS. FIRST WE IT'S
NOT GOING TO WORK TO REDUCE THE
INCIDENCE OF PACKAGE THAT. MANY
YEARS OF RESEARCH SHOW THAT AN
INCREASE IN THE SEVERITY OF
PUNISHMENT DOES NOTHING TO
DETER FUTURE OFFENSES. IT'S
GROWING MONEY AWAY SPENDING IT
WITHOUT ANY BENEFIT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. SECOND IT DIRECTLY
CONTRAVENES THE WILL OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND ENACTING
PROP FORTY SEVEN. THE VOTERS
UNDERSTOOD THAT SPENDING THE
STATE'S MONEY ON LOCKING UP LOW
LEVEL OFFENDERS FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME WITH WASTEFUL
AND INEFFECTIVE AND THEY OPTED
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THAT APPROACH.
FINALLY WE KNOW THAT ANY
INCREASE IN PUNISHMENT FOR THIS
TYPE OF LOW LEVEL CRIME. IS
GOING TO FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON BLACK
PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR. CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO MOVE TOWARD
LESS PUNITIVE MORE EFFECTIVE
AND MORE HUMANE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POLICIES. WE KNOW WHAT
WORKS TO PREVENT CRIME IF YOU
WANT TO STOP PACKAGE BACK UP
THE REAL EDUCATIONAL AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND MORE
ABOUT SOCIAL SERVICES. TO ALL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMMING AND SUPPORT THE
REINTEGRATION FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CONVICTED OF CRIMES. DON'T
THROW THE STATE MONEY AWAY ON
LONGER SENTENCES THAT DO MORE
HARM THAN GOOD. WE RESPECTFULLY
AFTER YOUR NOTE. THANK YOU. NOT
GLENN BACKUS ELLA BIGGEST.
AFTERNOON GOING BACK ISRAEL
BIGGER SENSE FOR HUMAN IN WHICH
WITH ON TO THIS. IF TO GET
INFORMATION FROM AMAZON ABOUT
THE AVERAGE PACKAGE VALUED IN
TWENTY TWELVE IT WAS PUBLISHED
THAT THEIR- AVERAGE VALUE WAS
FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS AND THIRTY
ONE CENTS. MY MOST RECENT
AMAZON PURCHASES WERE A
REFRIGERATOR MAGNET. NINE
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY EIGHT CENTS
IN VALUE AND BEFORE THAT I GOT
A FOUR PACK OF SOCKS ALL BLACK
FOR SIXTEEN DOLLARS AND TWENTY
CENTS. IF THEY'VE BEEN STOLEN
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW.
AB SEVENTY SIX MONTHS IN JAIL I
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. IT'S
ALREADY TOO MUCH FOR THE
PERSON. FOR THEIR FAMILY TO
HAVE TO BEAR THE COSTS IN THAT
CONVERSATION AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS TO BEAR.
INCREASES TO TWELVE NINETY TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON BAD POLICY AND
DISRESPECTFUL OF THE VOTERS WE
HAVE THREE ON ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE NOW BRING YOU BACK
TO WITNESSES. JUST GIVE ME IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
OUR ON THE LAWN OUTSIDE. SEEING
NONE. AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
LINE- AT&T OPERATOR FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE WHAT THIS TIME. ROBERT
LANE NINE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
NINETY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BARCODE GEORGIA MAY
HELP THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THE ISSUE. WE HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. OKAY DO NOT BRING
IT BACK INTO COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
SO MR SANTIAGO. I GREW UP IN MR
LACKEY. THANK YOU SELECTED I'LL
BE VERY VERY OF. VERY BRIEF I'D
I WOULD FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO
JUST SAY THAT. IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY THAT THESE PEOPLE
COMMIT THIS OFFENSE THAT YOU'RE
ADDRESSING ONLY DO ONE
RESIDENTS AT A TIME. WELL AT A
TIME THEY ONLY DO IT BUT I MEAN
THEY CONTINUALLY DO MULTIPLE
RESIDENCES BECAUSE THERE REALLY
IS NO. THREAT OF ARREST OR ANY
THREAT OF SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES SECONDLY. IT WAS
JUST A. NOT THAT LONG AGO
TWENTY NINETEEN WHERE WE HAD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WITH THE AB
TWELVE TEN. IN A BILL WAS VERY
SIMILAR TO THIS THE PAST SIX OO.
BY THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
PROBLEM HAS DONE NOTHING BUT
GOT WORSE. SINCE THAT ACTUALLY
OCCURRED SO I'M THANKFUL YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION
AND IT PROBABLY HAS MY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER. MR
SANTIAGO. I THINK MR CANNOT A
COUPLE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I'VE
HEARD A LOT OF DEBATE IN THE
UNITED- TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE
BEEN TRYING TO GET CLARITY. AND
HERE'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
TO SO THERE'S THERE IS- OF
COURSE THE PEOPLE SAYING THAT
THIS IS GOING TO INCREASE
PENALTIES AND CRIMES THE WAY I
UNDERSTOOD WHEN I LOOKED AT I
WANNA BE CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOU CORRECTLY. IS
YOUR BURNT YOUR BRING IN PARITY.
TO THAT SORT OF DELIVERY SYSTEM
OF GOODS WHATEVER COMPANY IT
MAY BE. TO WHAT THE POST OFFICE
CURRENTLY DOES BUT I WANNA BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK MISTER SAN
DIEGO SOME OF THE CONFUSION ON
THAT IS- BASED ON PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS. ON MISTER LOWE'S
BILL. A FROM A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO MY ORIGINAL- RENDITION OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR- INCLUDED-
AND FOR EXAMPLE IN MY BILL
INCLUDED. YOU KNOW INTENT TO
STEAL INCLUDED- ENTERING THE
CARTILAGE CURTILAGE OF THE
HOME. AND SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
OTHER DETAILS IN IN THAT BILL
THAT- AS AND IS NOT IN THIS
BILL NOW. AND IN FACT THE VERY
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL IS VERY
CLEAR AND THEN IT'S JUST A FEW
COUPLE WORDS CHANGES THAT IT'S
MAKING. THEIR MODERN DELIVERY
SYSTEM- OF OTHER COMPANIES.
RIGHT I MEAN WE'RE JUST
EQUALIZING EVERYTHING TO THE
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE IN
FACT. THIS LANGUAGE WAS- WORKED
OUT BETWEEN MY OFFICE. AND
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY TO COME TO
A I THINK A BETTER BILL AND I
AND I'M- MORE. A CLEANER BILL
AND THEN EASIER TO- OPERATE
UNDER THIS LAW THAN WHAT I WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDING. SO YES
THAT THAT THAT IS TO ANSWER
QUESTION DIRECTLY YES IS DOING
EXACTLY THAT PUTTING PARITY
INTO THIS. COAT MESSAGES I
STARTED VOICE MAN. MISTER ROGER
BUT BUT WHEN PAIRED IT WILL
WORK MAN YES PLEASE THAT IS SO
MISTER MISTER WITH QUESTION I'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO ASK IF I
WANT YOU TO ADDRESS MAYBE WHY
WE'RE HEARING- THE OPPOSITE
BECAUSE- IN AND OUT BECAUSE OF
THE I MEAN THE ARGUMENT ABOUT-
THE ARGUMENT ABOUT INCREASING
FEES AND PENALTIES AND SUPPORT.
DOES NOT SIT WELL WITH ME WHEN
IT COMES TO. A SERVICE TO A TO
THIS PARTICULAR- ITEM BUT- WHY
THEN WOULD SOMEBODY MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT WELL I THINK BASED ON
THE- CURRENTLY- YOU KNOW FOR
LACK OF FED EX YOU YOU PS- AND
THE OTHER DELIVER COMPANIES
AREN'T COVERED. UNDER THIS CODE
AND SO THERE'S SOME DEBATE ON.
ON YOU KNOW HOW- POLICE AND
PROSECUTORS NEED TO PROSECUTE
THAT CRIME SO AGAIN THIS IS
JUST. BRINGING THEM ALL UNDER
THE SAME CODE MAKING PARITY ON
EVERYTHING WE'RE NOT CREATING A
NEW. CRIME WERE NOT. INCREASING
THE PENALTIES FOR ANY CRIME THE
CRIME AND THE PENALTIES ARE
ALREADY IN CODE. WE'RE JUST
MATCHING. ALL THE OTHER
DELIVERY SYSTEMS TO. WHAT THE
U. S. P. S. HAS AND AGAIN IT
GOES BACK TO THOSE PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THE BILL THE
PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS I
BELIEVE BECAUSE SOME OF THAT
CONFUSION. IF I HAVE ANYTHING
I'LL COME BACK WITH THE SECOND
COMING- IS ABOUT OKAY IS THERE
FOR. YEAH OR I CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION SO THIS WOULD GIVE YOU
PARITY WITH THE U. S. P. S.
PENALTIES HOWEVER IT CAN ALSO
RIGHT NOW TODAY IF YOU STEAL A
PACKAGE IT'S ARE PROSECUTED
UNDER JUST COMMON THEFT. AND
THE PENALTY THERE IS SIX UP TO
SIX MONTHS RATHERTHAN A YEAR
EITHER WAY IT'S A MISDEMEANOR
THIS ONE ALLOWS IT FOR UP TO A
YEAR- UNDER PROP FORTY SEVEN
ALL OF THOSE CRIMES WERE. CHECK
WELL THE PENALTIES WERE CHANGED
AND YOU DON'T GET MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS UNLESS YOU STEAL
SOMETHING OVER NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS SO WITH ISN'T
INCREASE OVER WHAT THE CURRENT
PROSECUTION WOULD BE BUT IT
JUST BRINGS IT IN LINE WITH THE
U. S. POST OFFICE- I'VE GONE
BACK AND FORTH ON THIS BILL I
AM GOING TO VOTE FOR TO DAY-
AND- BECAUSE YOU DID. CHANGE SO
MUCH AND NOW SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY I THINK- RESPECTING THAT
CHAIR SEVEN PUBLIC SAFETY I
WILL VOTE YESTERDAY AND I GUESS
I'D BETTER MOVE THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT YES PLEASE. OKAY THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND I JUST I
WANTED TO BUILD ON THE
CONVERSATION THAT'S HAPPENED SO
FAR AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINED THAT
MAIL THEFT ALERT. SERVED TWELVE
MONTHS- NOW MAIL IS DELIVERED I
MEAN EVEN FROM WHEN I WAS A
CHILD I THE VAST MAJORITY OF
MAIL WAS DELIVERED BY THE US
POSTAL SERVICE THAT'S NO LONGER
TRUE THE VAST MAJORITY OF MY
PACKAGES ARE NOT DELIVERED BY
PRIVATE CARRIER. SO IF. AFTER
THE PACKAGE WAS ENVISIONED TO
BE TWELVE YEAR TWELVE MONTHS
USING TWELVE MONTHS AND THAT
SHOULD BE TRUE NO MATTER WHO IS
DELIVERING THE PACKAGE IF THE
CONVERSATION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THAT IS AN APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF TIME TO ME THAT IS A
SEPARATE CONVERSATION. AND ONE
OF THIS LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE UP
AND- AND THEN WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS BUT THE QUESTION BEFORE
US TODAY IS SHOULD IT MATTER
WHO DELIVERS YOUR PACKAGE AND
MAIL THEFT IS. HAPPENING ALL
THE TIME TO MY CONSTITUENTS AS
I'M SURE IS TRUE OF MANY OF US
AND IF TWELVE MONTHS IS
APPROPRIATION MATTER OF AMAZON
IS YOUR DELIVER A OR THE POST
OFFICE AND SO I AM LOOKING FOR
AND SUPPORTING THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WITH A-
THANK YOU VERY ROBUST
CONVERSATION FOR THIS BILL- AND
I KNOW YOU AND I'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT THIS BEFORE SO I JUST
HAVE TWO THINGS ONE SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE ANDERSON IS
VERY CLEARLY THAT IF YOU'LL GET
MAIL DELIVERED THROUGH A
PRIVATE KERRIER AMAZON UPS.
FEDEX WHATEVER- IF THAT
PACKAGES IS STOLEN UNDER YOUR
BILL THEY WOULD THEN ADD THAT
THE POTENTIAL SENTENCING WOULD
BE AT PARITY WITH CURRENT
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE
PENALTIES WHICH IS UP TO ONE
YEAR WHAT YES AND WE'RE NOT
CHANGING ANY SORT OF CURRENT US
PS PENALTIES AS WRITING THE
SAME. OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT-
I FORGOT MY SECOND QUESTION I'M
SORRY. WHAT IT WAS JUST BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ONCE THE BILL
PASSES. THANK YOU- SO YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS REALLY BOILS DOWN TO
IS. WHAT THEY HAVE SAID YOU
KNOW THIS ABOUT MAIL AND AT THE
EXPANSION OF OUR MAIL SYSTEM
HAS SIX. I MEAN THEY DELIVER
PACKAGES THAT ARE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO YOUR FRONT PORCH.
AND IF YOU'RE NOT THERE TO TAKE
ON BEFORE THE PERSON COMING
DOWN THE ROAD TO SEIZE IT THERE
TAKES IT- THAT'S A SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS DOWN NOT TO FORTY SEVEN
DOLLARS STAFF- SO THAT THAT'S
TO ME THAT'S KIND OF BESIDE THE
POINT. THE POINT IS PEOPLE ARE
SICK AND TIRED OF HAVING YOUR
STUFF STOLEN OFF THE FRONT
PORCH BY THESE PART B. PORCH
PIRATES. AND AND SO THAT THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING IS
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE PORCH
PIRATES KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING INTO WHICH IS THE SAME
AS IF YOU'RE BREAKING IN OUR
MAILBOXES WHICH THEY DO A LOT
OF. AND AND YOU GET TO PAY A
PRICE FOR THAT YOU GET TO PAY A
PENALTY. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS AND YOU KNOW WHETHER THE
PENALTIES TO STEP OR NOT THAT'S
LIKE. MISS BAR CANCER IS FOR
ANOTHER OTHER DAY BUT I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BILL AND I THINK
THAT THE PUBLIC WOULD BE AS
WELL RECEIVED FROM THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE SICK AND TIRED OF BEING
RIPPED OFF. AND AND IT'S A
GREAT RESPONSE TO THAT. AND SO
ARE YOU TAKING AMENDMENTS ON
THE BILL BECAUSE IF YOU ARE
LOVED WE HAD AND- IF WE
ENCOUNTER I WOULD HAVE. YES I'D
BE HAPPY TO ADD YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR ANYBODY ELSE I DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MEMBERS PLAN AT
THIS POINT TIME BECAUSE IT'S-
THE BILL'S BEEN PRETTY I DIDN'T
MEAN IT IS A PRETTY EFFICIENT
BUILT ON. THERE SO I THINK I'M
A CO AUTHOR NOT AMENDMENTS
THOUGH YEAH I THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED. THANK YOU.
THIS WORKS SORRY I REMEMBER
SECOND GRADE- ONE OF THE THINGS
UNITED. BILL EARLIER WAS- WOULD
SAY THAT THIS BILL IS NOT NOT.
IT'S NOT. YOU TO. SO OF YOUR OF
UP. OR ONE OFF IT'S MORE GEARED
TOWARDS THE SORT OF
PROFESSIONAL RINGS THAT- SOME
PEOPLE BELIEVE ARE PERPETRATING
THESE CRIMES. CAN YOU TELL ME
EXACTLY HOW THIS BILL IS.
GEARED TOWARDS THAT UNIVERSE OF
PEOPLE WELL I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
OBVIOUSLY HAS A GREAT BILL
THAT'S- WORKING ITS WAY THAT'S-
GOING AFTER. CRIME RINGS AND-
THE ORGANIZED- PACKAGE THEFT.
WHICH I. YOU KNOW THIS BILL I
THINK SUPPLEMENTS THAT
COMPLIMENTS IT DOESN'T GET IN
ITS WAY DID DOESN'T- CHANGE IT
AT ALL- A LOOK IN INDIFFERENCE.
I UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION'S
ARGUMENTS ON A TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR PACKAGE OR FORTY SEVEN
DOLLAR PACKAGE THAT'S- THAT.
WILL I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
ENVISIONS WITH THIS BILL THAT
THAT'S WHAT. WE'RE GOING TO
PROSECUTE RIGHT AYE AYE BUT-
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT ARE
RECEIVING TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
PACKAGES AND FORTY SEVEN OUR
PACKAGES ARE ALSO RECEIVING
ESSENTIAL. SUPPLIES MEDICATIONS
FOOD- YOU KNOW SINCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED A LOT MORE
PEOPLE ARE ORDERING FOOD TO BE
DELIVERED THAN EVER BEFORE.
MEDICATIONS OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
COMING MEDICAL DEVICES MEDICAL
SUPPLIES. HE IS WE GARDASIL THE
VALUE OF THOSE PARTICULAR ITEMS
THAT ARE LEFT ON THE PORCH.
THEIR THEIR VALUES THEIR DOLLAR
IT'S NOT THE DOLLAR VALUE THAT
MATTERS IT'S- WHAT IT MEANS TO
THAT PERSON WHO'S RECEIVING
THAT PACKAGE OF ITS A MEDICAL
DEVICE OR MEDICAL SUPPLIES IT
DOES MATTER HOW MUCH IT COSTS.
THEY NEED THAT SUPPLY TO
SURVIVE. AND SO- THIS IS
DESIGNED TO GO AFTER. FOLKS
THAT ARE FOR YOU KNOW FOR LACK
OF A BETTER TERM MAKING A
LIVING. OUT OF FOLLOWING THE
AMAZON TRUCK AND WHEN THEY GO
AROUND THE CORNER- GOING ON TO
THAT PERSON'S. FRONT YARD AND
FRONT DOOR IN AND GRABBING THAT
THAT- THAT BOX. OR PACKAGE OR
WHATEVER SO- YEAH GOING TO WORK
YEAH I THINK THE BEST WAY TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IS IF SOMEBODY
REALLY JUST ONCE STOLE A TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR. OR FIFTY OR A
HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH PACKAGE-
THE DA ISN'T GONNA GO ALL HOG
AND PUT THEM IN JAIL FOR A
YEAR- YOU KNOW THEY'LL TRY AND
GET THEM TO PLEAD TO. YOU NOW.
PLEAD GUILTY CAN NOW PAY FIND
THEY'RE NOT GONNA PUT HIM IN
JAIL FOR THE REST ON THE OTHER
HAND IF IT IS. SOMEBODY GOING
AROUND AND PICKING UP ONE
PACKAGE AFTER ANOTHER. THEN
THEY MAY GO AFTER THEM AND THEY
MIGHT PUT HIM IN JAIL FOR A
YEAR AND I'M OKAY WITH THAT SO.
I FINALLY TALKED MYSELF INTO
YOUR BILL. TOPS YOU I YOU'VE
YOU'VE ARGUED YOURSELF MUCH
BETTER THAN I COULD HAVE. AND
THE OTHER. PEOPLE WE ASK IF YOU.
WE ARE TOGETHER YEAH RIGHT OF
COURSE ISN'T MUCH. IT IS NOT
THE BILL IN PARLIAMENT SECOND
AND ON S. THREE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR JOHNS THE MOTION.
SHARES RECORD. IS NOT. I THINK
THAT'S FAIR TO SAY OKAY ON SB
THREE FIFTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
MACKEY HI POWER CAN BACKHAND HI
LEE. CORK BY CORK I SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I SEE R. TWO C. R.
TWO I LICKS. FOR NOW. WHAT'S
NOT VOTING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS IS-
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I THINK
WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB DEBATING
IT AND TAKING ALL SIDES INTO
CONSIDERATION SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. YOU. SB. TWO NINE
NINE. VICTIMS COMPENSATION.
VICTIMS COMPENSATION THE
PROJECT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THIS BILL MUCH APPRECIATED
SENATE BILL TWO NINE NINE
REMOVES BARRIERS FACED BY
VICTIMS INJURED OR KILLED BY
POLICE AND OTHER VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES IN GETTING HELP
FROM CALIFORNIA'S VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD CURRENTLY
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD CAL BCB.
CANNOT APPROVE AN APPLICATION
FOR ASSISTANCE WITHOUT A POLICE
REPORT WHICH IS OFTEN NOT
AVAILABLE IN CASES WHERE THE
POLICE BECAUSE THE INJURY OR
THE DEATH CAL THE C. B. CAN
ALREADY USE OTHER EVIDENCE TO
ESTABLISH A THE CRIME OCCURRED
FOR VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT OTHER VICTIMS
SUCH AS THOSE WHOSE INJURIES
RESULTED FROM POLICE ARE NOT
AFFORDED THE SAME FLEXIBILITY
IN ADDITION CAL BCB CAN DENY
APPLICATIONS IF IT DETERMINES
THAT THE VICTIM'S INVOLVEMENT
IN THE EVENTS GAVE RISE TO THE
APPLICATION VICTIMS MAY ALSO BE
DENIED FOR NON. COOPERATION
WITH THE POLICE GIVING
SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT TO THE
OPINION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
SIMPLY PUT SB TWO NINE NINE
WILL IMPROVE ACCESS TO VITAL
RESOURCES OF VICTIMS OF
VIOLENCE AS THEY RECOVER FROM
THE PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
INJURIES INCLUDING THOSE CALLS
DUE TO THE ACTIONS OF POLICE OR
THE CASES OF PEOPLE KILLED BY
THE POLICE BE ABLE TO BURY
THEIR LOVED ONES WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT. CALIFORNIA'S
VICTIM COMPENSATION PROGRAM IS
THE MEANS BY WHICH WE AS A
COMMUNITY PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME
VICTIMS OF WRONGFUL CONVICTION
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
INDIVIDUAL SERIOUSLY INJURED
AND THE FAMILIES OF THOSE
KILLED BY POLICE IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE CURRENT WORK OF CALVI
CV THIS IS VITAL WORK TO HEAL
TRAUMA AND INTERRUPT THE
SILENCE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING. ASSISTANCE
RECOVERING FROM INJURIES
IMPERIAL X. HOW SURVIVE AND
COMMUNITIES. IN THE PAST
THERE'S BEEN HESITANCY TO
EXPAND COVERAGE BECAUSE OF
CONCERNS THAT THE COMPENSATION
FUND IS UNDERFUNDED.
FORTUNATELY THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES THIRTY THREE MILLION
FOR THE FUN OF THIRTY NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION GOING
FORWARD ANNUALLY. IN ADDITION
REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE HAVE
DROPPED SIGNIFICANTLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THE FUND HAS
BEEN GROWING IN THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF. PRECIADO COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH IMPROVE THE
BILL BY MAKING THESE CHANGES.
NEARING THE DEFINITION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ALL PENAL CODE
EIGHT THIRTY OFFICERS. TO ADDS
AS AN EXCLUSION FROM COVERAGE
INDIVIDUAL SERIOUSLY INJURED BY
POLICE WHO WERE CONVICTED OF
COMMITTING A VIOLENT CRIME
DURING THE INCIDENT WHICH THEY
WERE INJURED AND THREE.
CLARIFIES AN EXISTING LAWS THAT
THE BOARD GETS REIMBURSED IF A
PERSON OBTAINS A SETTLEMENT
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT. CONTINUES
TO APPLY. MEMBERS INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS STRAIGHTFORWARD
AND IF ENACTED WILL MAKE AN
IMPORTANT IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. HERE WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IS
ASHLEY AND MICHELLE MONTERROSA
MEMBERS OF THE CRIME SURVIVORS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND
JUSTICE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS AT THE CORRECT TIME I
WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THE BILL. TAKEN KDM
PERSONAL SECOND THANK YOU
SENATOR. AND ANTE OPERATOR IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING. I THINK WHAT
MIGHT'VE. IN BETTER PERSON YEAH.
I KNOW IT'S AN EXCITING DAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA FOR THE
INTRODUCTION GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHELLE MONTH IT'LL
SUCK THE ELDEST SURVIVING
SISTER OF SEAN MONTERROSA JOHN
WHAT THAT ALSO WAS KILLED BY
VALLEJO POLICE ON JUNE SECOND
OF TWENTY TWENTY HE WAS
KNEELING WHAT IS HANDS IN THE
AIR IN A PARKING LOT ONE BELOW
POLICE OFFICER JARED TIME FIRED
FIVE SHOTS FROM THE BACKSEAT OF
A MOVING. UNMARKED POLICE
VEHICLE AND KILLED HIM. THIS IS
EQUIVALENT TO A DRIVE BY
SHOOTING. THERE'S NO WAY AN
OFFICER. COULD I FELL UNDER ANY
THREAT FROM THE BACKSEAT OF A
MOVING VEHICLE ESPECIALLY ONE
WHICH IS NOT EVEN IDENTIFY UP
AND IDENTIFIABLE AS A POLICE
VEHICLE. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
NOTHING WILL BRING BACK SHAUN.
BUT AS F. F. SB TWO NINE NINE
HAD ALREADY BEEN A LAW OUR
PARENTS WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TAKE TIME OFF FROM WORK TO
MOURN HIM. AND PLANETS FUNERAL.
WE HAVE SISTERS COULD HAVE US
THAT ACCESS COUNSELING TO HELP
US PROCESS OUR GRIEF. AND WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD
KNOWLEDGE THAT'S VICTIMS AND
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT AND
COMPASSION WE DESERVE. BUT IN
REALITY WE WERE MET WITH NONE
OF THAT THE LITTLE SUPPORT WE
DO HAVE WHAT WE BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO FIGHT FOR IT. IN ORDER TO
GIVE SEAN HIS PROPER BURIAL OUR
FAMILY HOW TO SET UP A GO FUND
ME. AND DEPEND ON OUR COMMUNITY
TO SUPPORT US THROUGH THE MOST
DEVASTATING TIME IN OUR LIVES.
FINDING JUSTICE FOR YOUR LOVED
ONE IS NOT EASY. MY SISTER AND
I HAVE QUIT OUR JOBS. OUR
PARENTS WERE ONLY ABLE TO TAKE
TWO DAYS OFF WORK TO GRIEVE THE
LOSS OF THEIR ONLY SON AND HAVE
BEEN WORKING SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
WITH NO ACCESS TO COUNSELING OR
THERAPY. IMMIGRATED HERE TO
GIVE US THE AMERICAN DREAM ONLY
TO BE MET WITH AMERICAN
NIGHTMARE WHICH IS LOSING YOUR
LOVED ONE TO POLICE VIOLENCE.
WE NO LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
BROTHER WE CANNOT SPEAK TO HIM
LAUGH WITH HIM. OUR MOTHER WILL
NEVER SERVE SHAUN ANOTHER MEAL.
OUR FATHER WOULD NEVER HOLD
SHAWN'S CHILDREN HIS LAP WE
FEEL BLESSED AND GRATEFUL TO
HAVE. THE SUPPORT OF OUR
COMMUNITY DURING THIS TIME BUT
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE AND CARRY ALL THIS PAIN
WITH NO RESOURCES OR SUPPORT.
NO MATTER WHAT THE POLICE
REPORT SAYS THERE WERE FIVE
VICTIMS CREATED WHEN MY BROTHER
WAS KILLED. MY FAMILY SUFFERED
AND THERE ARE TOO MANY FAMILIES
LIKE OURS. OUT HERE DEALING
WITH THE SAME TRAGEDY. WE'RE
THANKFUL FOR THIS BILL AND
BEING A PART OF PUSHING THIS
CHANGE FOR ALL OF THE SURVIVORS
WHOSE FOR. WHOSE DESERVE HELP.
IT IS TIME TO CALIFORNIA STANDS
BEHIND ALL SURVIVORS
SPECIFICALLY FAMILIES AFFECTED
BY POLICE VIOLENCE. I ASKED THE
ALL VOTE YES ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR LABOR FOR THE
INTRODUCTION. I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINE NINE
WHICH WOULD MAKE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FOR FAMILIES
AFFECTED BY POLICE VIOLENCE
ATTAINABLE I'M ACTUALLY
MONTERROSA THE YOUNGER
SURVIVING SISTER MY BROTHER
SEAN MONTERROSA WHAT OUR FAMILY
HAS BEEN PUT THROUGH BY VALLEJO
POLICE DEPARTMENT WILL TAKE
MORE OF THE TOP MORE TIME THAN
I HAVE YOUR TODAY BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE WAY IT%
ILLUSTRATES THE NEED FOR SB TWO
NINE NINE. LOSING SOMEONE YOU
LOVE TO VIOLENCE IS AN
UNIMAGINABLE PAINT THAT RIPPLES
THROUGH EVERY PART OF YOUR LIFE
WHEN THAT LOSS COMES AT THE
HANDS OF SOMEONE TASKED WITH
KEEPING YUR COMMUNITY SAFE AT
THE HANDS OF A POLICE OFFICER
IT'S ALSO STIGMATIZING AND
DESTABILIZING. INSTEAD THERE IS
NOW IN SEAN'S PACE AN ACHING
VOID OF GRIEF AND ANGER TO ITS
CREDIT CALIFORNIA OFFERS SERVER
SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF MANY
KINDS OF CRIME AND VIOLENCE BUT
OUR FAMILY BECAUSE SHAUN'S
KILLER HOW TO BATCH QUALIFIES
FOR NONE OF THAT. ON JUNE
SECOND OF TWENTY TWENTY SEAN
WAS KNEELING WITH HIS HANDS UP
WHEN OFFICER JR AT TIMES OF THE
VALLEJO POLICE DEPARTMENT SHOT
THROUGH THE WINDSHIELD OF AN
UNMARKED PICKUP TRUCK WITH A R.
FIFTEEN. I JUST SO HAPPEN TO
TURN TWENTY THE DAY AFTER.
SINCE THE MOMENT TO SEAN'S LIFE
WAS TAKEN. WE'VE HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO SPRING INTO ACTION. AND
CALL FOR JUSTICE. MY SISTER
MICHELLE AND I FOR THE PAST
YEAR HAVE CONTINUOUSLY HOW TO
PUT OUR BODIES ON THE LINE WE
QUIT OUR JOBS WE PUT SCHOOL ON
HOLD AND I HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO PRINT GRIEF PUBLICLY. JOHN
WAS ALSO PROVIDER IN OUR FAMILY
NOW OUR PARENTS SPEND THEIR
DAYS WORKING TWELVE TO FOURTEEN
HOUR SHIFTS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
EVEN THROUGH THEIR GRIEF JUST
TO STAY AFLOAT. I SAY THIS TO
SHED LIGHT ON HOW FOR IMPACTED
FAMILIES WILL GO FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES. ALL OF THAT WHILE
NOT HAVING ANY TYPE OF ACCESS
TO FAMILY THERAPY. GRIEF
COUNSELING OR ANY TYPE OF
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES. THIS
IN NO WAY IS AN ISOLATED CASE.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER FAMILIES
AND NOT JUST IN THE LAB BUT ALL
ACROSS OF CALIFORNIA. WHO HAVE
SO SIMILAR STORIES ABOUT THE
WAYS THAT POLICE MURDERED OUR
LOVED ONES THEN LEAVE THE
FAMILIES WITH NO RESOURCES TO
COVER SPECIFIC EXPENSES SUCH AS
MEDICAL BILLS. FUNERAL AND
BURIAL EXPENSES. AND COUNSELING
MY HOPE IS THAT YOU ALL BEGIN
TO CENTER THE VOICES OF MANY
IMPACTED FAMILIES LIKE OURS AND
REALIZE THE URGENCY. TO GIVE
FAMILIES ACCESS OF EVERYTHING
SB TWO NINE NINE PROVIDES THANK
YOU GOD BLESS YOU ALL. THANK
YOU AND OUR SYMPATHIES- AT&T
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER-
ALL I'M SORRY WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE HERE IN. IN THE ROOM YOU
MAY PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SENT AND
COMMITTEE THANK YOU- CENTER
RIGHT AFTER THIS BILL- MY NAME
IS PATRICK BANKER AND TIME IS
NOT REALLY EASY TO TALK ABOUT
BUT FOR THE PAST SIX YEARS I'VE
BASICALLY BEEN TORTURED AND
IT'S BEEN TOUGH. TO TALK ABOUT
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN IN A WAY THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVEN'T HEARD
OF IT IT'S BEEN BY PEOPLE THAT
ARE REALLY I MEAN PRETTY MUCH
PROTECTED BUT- I WAS EXPOSED TO
LIKE NANO DEVICES ABOUT TWELVE
YEARS AGO. AND NOW DEVICES ARE
LIKE WILL COMPUTERS RADIOS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT I CAN LIKE YOUR
SIZE AND ABOUT SIX YEARS AGO I
TRIED TO SAVE A WOMAN THAT I
LOVE FOR SOME FROM SOME DRUG
DEALERS. AND I THINK SOME OF
THEM WERE CORRECTIONS OFFICERS
BECAUSE THEY RETALIATED AGAINST
ME FOR THE NEXT SIX YEARS
TORTURE ME THESE NOW DEVICES
THAT WERE IN MY BODY AND I
DIDN'T KNOW HOW THIS HAPPENED
AT FIRST BUT BASIC HERE THEM
CALLING ME THE N. WORD CALLING
ME ADAM IS COMMON DURING THE
KILL ME TELL ME I HAD TO- BURN
MYSELF ALIVE AND HANG MYSELF
AND SHOOT MYSELF I WAS GOING TO
GET AWAY FROM THEM. AND SO I
STARTED RESEARCHING NOW
TECHNOLOGY AND THEN I CALLED UP
THE PRISON IN IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY- TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THEY TELL ME THAT
THEY DID A TRIAL RUN ON ME WITH
NANOTECHNOLOGY AND I WAS REALLY
SCARED AND I AND I AND I KNOW
THAT THEIR PERSONAL TIME WITHIN
MISTER SUPERVISOR I TRIED TO- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO SO I
THOUGHT THE CIVIL ACTION I WAS
SCARED AND I'M STILL SCARED
EVERY DAY IS REALLY HARD I
DON'T HAVE ANY SUPPORT I DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY HELP ME SUFFER
LIKE MY DOCTOR BUT- INSURANCE
COMPANIES AREN'T HELPFUL. I'M
HOPING THAT PEOPLE CAN HAVE-
EASIER ACCESS TO IT C. T.
IMOGENE TO SEE IF THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED THESE ARMOR SYMPATHETIC
TO YOURSITUATION BUT IS NOT
GERMANE TO OUR PARTICULAR
DISCUSSION AT THIS TIME. SO WE
WISH YOUR SUPPORT WE WISH YOU
SUCCESS BUT WE CAN ADDRESS YOUR
ISSUE AT THIS. TIME SO PLEASE
UNDERSTAND OUR- YEAH ANY OTHER
OTHER WHAT. AND ROOM THAT WE
LIKE TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. FINE OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE OUTSIDE MY STEP OF THESE
IF YOU'RE OUT THERE. WHEN I WAS
VERY GOOD AND I GUESS WE GOT
SOMEONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. PROUD CO SPONSOR. AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY AT&T
OPERATOR WE WOULD LIKE TO-
LISTEN TO ANYBODY THAT'S ON THE
PHONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO NINE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ENTER ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND IF THEY
WOULD PLEASE JUST STATE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WE APPRECIATE THAT. OUR FIRST
COMMENT WILL COME FROM A LINE
OF EIGHT THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
GABRIEL GARCIA WOULD UTILIZE
I'VE BEEN GIVEN PERMISSION TO
READ OFF A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT THIS
BILL- STARTING WITH ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE. HEY
BURNS INSTITUTE. ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. INITIATE
JUSTICE SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA. YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION THE
OAKLAND POLICE COMMISSION
EDITION TO OUR CO SPONSORS THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE. STATE
CONTROLLER BETTY YEE CHARGES GO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JESSICA AGAIN
AND OF COURSE MY ORGANIZATION
UTILIZED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. CONNECT COMMENT FROM LINE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
THEY'VE AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF EVERY
TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY IN SUPPORT
AT THE TWO NINE NINE. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA THANKS
REPRESENTING A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THAT WE CAN NINETY
NINE YEAH THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ALICE KESSLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS ARE
BACK ON MARKETS REPRESENTING
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN AND
SUPPORTERS SB TWO NINETY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS MERRY
HIRED FROM THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY GROUP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
MARSHALL GOT ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CONNIE MCKENZIE
SPEAKING FOR MOMS DEMAND ACTION
AND EVERYTOWN SURVIVOR NETWORK
I'M ALSO A GUN VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS AND SPENT TIME IN
FEDERAL WITNESS PROTECTION
PROGRAM IN BENEFITTED FROM
VICTIM SERVICES I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT SB TWO NINE NINE. THANK
YOU. EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS TINA RODRIGUEZ I'M CALLING
WITH CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY
INJECTED IN SUPPORT SB TWO NINE
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK EIGHT
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
WITH A LOT OF THE VOLUNTARY
LEADER WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION
FOR GUN SENSE CALLING AT THE
PORT. THANK YOU. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- THIS RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND THE POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATIONS. OF
ARCADIA BURBANK CLAREMONT
CULVER CITY CORONA. INGLEWOOD
NEWPORT BEACH PALACE VERDES
POMONA RIVERSIDE SANTA ANA
UPLAND AND LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
POLICE ASSOCIATION. ALL
CURRENTLY HAVE IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON S. B. TWO NINE NINE.
PERSONS WHO DUE TO THEIR OWN
MISCONDUCT ELICIT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE SHOULD NOT
BE PROVIDED TAXPAYER FUNDS- AS
A RESULT OF ANY INJURY THAT
SHOULD OCCUR- THESE PERSONS ARE
NOT CRIME VICTIMS. WHICH IS THE
PURPOSE OF THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION- FORD. WE BELIEVE
THAT- TAXPAYERS SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO BEAR THE SPRINT AND BY
ALLOWING NON- CRIME VICTIMS TO
ACCESS THESE FUNDS. WE BELIEVE
IT'S WHOLLY INAPPROPRIATE AND
BUT AGAIN THE TAXPAYER SHOULD
NOT HEAR THIS IT ALSO- WE
BELIEVE MAKES LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS SOMEHOW APPEAR. THAT
THEY'VE INVOLVED- THEY'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN SOME KIND OF
MISCONDUCT- BASED ON JUST DOING
THEIR JOB AND IF AN INJURY
OCCURS AND- OFFICER HAS
COMMITTED A CRIME IN DOING THAT
THEY SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
PROSECUTED. AND ALSO THEN THE
PERSON WHO- IS THE RECIPIENT OF
THE POTENTIALLY EXCESSIVE FORCE
THEN THEY WOULD BE A CRIME
VICTIM AND ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION. SO FOR THESE
REASONS- WE REGRETFULLY MUST-
AND RESPECTFULLY- THAT'S FOR
ANOTHER THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHERS IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY I GUESS EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR. WOULD LIKE TO OPEN
THE LINES TO ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WE
WOULD ASK THAT THEY WOULD JUST
MENTION THEIR NAME. AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. YES TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE SO WE PROVIDE
CLAIM NUMBER FOR THE FIRST
COMMENT.
OKAY THREE TOTALING
ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE. OUR
FIRST PANEL COMPLAIN OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KELLY READ ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS SAFE AND CRIME
UNITED WITH ITS STRONG
OPPOSITION TO NINETEEN. THANK
YOU. HER NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE EIGHT HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THE
MARTINS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO HAVE ANY.
YES METRICS GO AHEAD PLEASE
THANK YOU- MISTER- THEY SHARE-
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
WITNESSES FOR HER VERY
COMPELLING TESTIMONY- AND
SHARING HER STORY IT'S GREATLY
APPRECIATED WHEN WE CAN HEAR
THAT SO THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR- AUTHORING THIS BILL
AND WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AND WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL ALREADY DID THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT- BUILT
IMPORTANT MEASURE- AND I REALLY
HOPE IT GETS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND WALDRON CAN CAN
HELP ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SOMEPLACE WELL. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU ON THE
EDGE. POLICE NOW. I THINK SHE-
OKAY. YEAH MEASURE ANSWER I'M
FOR AFTER OFFERED IF OPINIONS
THIS- I HAVE I HAVE BECOME-
ABOUT MOVING THIS THEM THE TRUE
OF AND THAT COMPENSATION THAT'S
ALREADY UNDER FUNDED. AND THEN
ADDING TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND
THEN OPENING THE DOOR- TO A
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT SOMEHOW
GOT THEMSELVES INTO A CONFLICT
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT- IT
THERE'S AN INCENTIVE NOW. GIVEN
THIS OPENING UP THAT DOOR. I TO
RESIST- BE INJURED AND THEN
CLAIM VICTIMHOOD- OVER BEING- I
OVER THE CONSEQUENCES OF
ESSENTIALLY- WHAT IT WAS WAS
THEIR BEHAVIOR. AND IN IN THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW I SEE A COUPLE
OF THE ATM OF ISSUES RELATED TO
THAT BUT- YOU KNOW I ALSO SEE-
AND I WOULD QUESTION MAYBE YOU
CAN ANSWER THIS- IF A PERSON IS
OUT. SHOOTING AT PEOPLE BUT
DOESN'T REALLY HIT ANYBODY BUT
DAN IS- SO DUDE BY THE POLICE
ARRIVING POLICE OFFICERS SO
THEY MAY NOT HIT ANYBODY. WELL
THEY DIDN'T CAUSE ANY INJURY.
AND THEREFORE ARE THEY ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS THIS VICTIM
COMPENSATION FUND. AFTER THEY
WERE STOPPED FROM. AFTER FUTURE
INYO INJURING SOMETHING IN THE
FUTURE. THE SHORT ANSWER IS NOW.
SO. IN THE IN THE LANGUAGE. IT
SAYS THAT. IF A PERSON IS
ACCUSED OF HURTING OR KILLING
SOMEONE THE BOARD INSTEAD
CHANGE SHALL NOT COMPENSATE
THEM IT SAYS MAY DENIED
COMPENSATION ACTUALLY THAT
ACTUAL LANGUAGE LARGEST WITH
SHALL NOT BE ELIGIBLE IT'S VERY
CLEAR SO DOES NOT SAY MAY DENY
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY DID THAT
GET CHANGED YES. OKAY ARGUES
THAT THAT ALSO OPENS THE DOOR.
IF I MAY RESPOND YES I THINK
SOME OF THE CONFUSION FOR SOME
FOLKS ON THIS BILL IS WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT INCENTIVIZING FOLKS
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS A POT OF
MONEY AND IF I CLAIM THAT- THE
POLICE SHOT ME OR THE POLICE
BOBBY- BEAT ME UP OKAY NOW
COUNTY LABOR GETS YOU KNOW
200-004-0000 DOLLARS. NUMBER
ONE CAL BCB IS A PAYER OF LAST
RESORT AND NUMBER TWO IT'S JUST
ABOUT REIMBURSEMENT SO IT'S IF
YOU HAD RECEIVED COUNSELING
SERVICES BECAUSE YOU WERE
TRAUMATIZED BUT BY THE WAY YOU
WERE TREATED IF YOU HAD TO
RECEIVE- ANY HOT AT THIRTY
HOSPITAL BILLS THEY WERE NOT
PAID BECAUSE YOU WERE HARMED BY
THE POLICE THEY WOULD BE
REIMBURSED AND IF GOD FORBID.
YOUR FAMILY MEMBER IS KILLED BY
POLICE THE FAMILY MEMBER COULD
THEN BE ELIGIBLE TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR BURIAL EXPENSES
SO I THINK THAT'S A VERY BIG
DISTINCTION BETWEEN YOU KNOW
PEOPLE THINKING THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE INCENTIVIZED TO CLAIM
VICTIMHOOD BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO SOMEHOW GET SOME SORT
OF MONEY THIS IS ABOUT
REIMBURSING PEOPLE FOR TRAUMA
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN INCURRED BY
THE POLICE BUT ADDED THAT
TRAUMA IS ALSO. YOU HAVE TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT HOW IT GOT
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE
SOMETIMES YES SOMETIMES NO TIME
AND THIS IS NOT ABOUT EVERY
PERSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAYING
THAT EVERY PERSON WHO COMMITS A
CRIME SHOULD BE HAVE ACCESS TO
CAL B. C. B. I MEAN ANYONE
WATCHING THE NEWS OVER THE LAST
HOW MANY YEARS COUPLE YEARS.
HAS SEEN THAT THE PLEASE DO NOT
ALWAYS DO THE RIGHT THING BY
FOLKS AND THE SO THIS IS JUST A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE TRUE
VICTIMS TO RECEIVE COMPENSATION
BE REIMBURSED FOR TRAGEDY OR-
TRAUMA THAT THEY HAVE RECEIVED
TIME AND IF THEY'RE NOT IF THEY
DO THEY ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
COURTS WHICH WILL ALLOW THEM
MUCH BIGGER COMPENSATION IN
THIS WOULD ALLOW AND IF THEY
DID GO TO COURT AND THEY WERE
GIVEN THE COMPENSATION. THEY
HAVE TO PAY BACK CALLUM CB. AT
THE END OF LEASE IN MY STE.
CALABRESE IS. BEFORE THIS BILL
IN BECAUSE EFFECTIVE OTHERS CAN
GOES GOVERNOR'S. CALVI C. B.
FUNDING THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS
YES BUT IT'S BEEN THERE BEFORE
BUT IT'S BEEN THERE BEFORE MR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS BILL. NOT
CREATE CALVI CB UNDERSTOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU THERE'S
JUST I THINK IT WAS FUNDED A
DIFFERENT WAY BEFORE. IT WAS
FUNDED BY. YEAH THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE THERE WAS YES YES
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY OF CORK-
YES SO. THERE'S SOME JUST I
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS WILL
CONVINCE MR SAY ARE TRANSPORTED
PROBABLY WON'T BUT IN
PARTICULAR THE BILL ALLOWS AN
EXCLUSION BASED ON WHETHER THE
VICTIM COULD HAVE FORESEEN THAT
ILLEGAL CONTACT WOULD HAVE
RESULTED IN INJURY SO IF YOU
HAVE SOMEONE WHO CAN HOUSE
SALSA POLICE OFFICER- MY GUESS
IS THAT THEY WOULD DECIDE THAT
WHATEVER THE POLICE OFFICER DID
IN THAT CASE. WHAT'S TO BE
EXPECTED SO YOU KNOW IT DOES
HAVE THAT EXCLUSION AND IT. SO
I THINK THAT WHAT THESENATORS
TRYING TO DO IS TO TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE WHO- FRANKLY HAVE BEEN
ABUSED BY POLICE I THINK THAT'S
THE- THE INTENT AND I BELIEVE
THE WAY THIS IS WRITTEN THAT'S
THE WAY THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
THANK YOU. MISS BURKE A HAND
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR- I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER WORK TO THE POINT AND THAT
MISTER CLARK JUST MADE THIS IS
THAT HAVE NARROWLY CRAFTED BILL
AND WE KNOW THAT GEORGE FLOOD
WAS A VICTIM. AND HE'S NOT THE
ONLY ONE. AND SO WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY CAN BE THE VICTIMS
EVEN IF IT IS AT THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ND SO TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND TO GIVE
THEM ACCESS TO THESE FUNDS IF
THEY ARE THE VICTIMS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT. YOU WORKED
HARD TO ENSURE THAT IT IS THE
VICTIMS THAT ARE GETTING THESE
FUNDS AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN. OKAY
IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- LET ME JUST
CLARIFY THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PROPOSED
TO YOU YES I DO YOU MAY CLOSE
MATCH. MEMBERS I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AS I STATED EARLIER THIS
IS NOT A POT OF MONEY FOR
PEOPLE TO RECEIVE THAT AS MR
FALCO DESCRIBED THAT'S WHAT THE
COURTS ARE FOR THAT IS IN CIVIL
PENALTIES COULD BE THE CASE
THIS IS ABOUT REIMBURSING
VICTIMS. FOR SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED TO THEM AND IT'S
REIMBURSING HOSPITAL BILLS
COUNSELING BILLS OR GOD FORBID
IF YOUR LOVED ONE WAS KILLED BY
POLICE YOU CAN GET THE FUNERAL
COSTS REIMBURSED MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU I DO THINK THE
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED. AS SUPPORT
AS AMENDED. AND WITH THAT WILL
CALL FOR THE QUESTION. THE
BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON SB TWO NINETY NINE
BY SENATOR LEAVE THAT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. BLACKIE NOT
LACKING NOW BARRICADE HAND
PACKING HANNAH HI LETE LETE HAI
CORK CORK I SANTIAGO. THEY ARE
TO THE R. TEN NO WICKS WICKS I.
BUT MEMBERS ON COLLEGE MORE
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER.
CENTER RUBIO. SB. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. MAY I BEGIN
I'M SORRY YES YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU AT TEARS MEMBER THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WHICH IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS SEEKING
PROTECTION FROM THEIR ABUSERS.
THANK YOU SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY WILL THAT JUST SIMPLY
VICTIMS TO FILE ELECTRONICALLY.
AND ALSO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY REMOTELY- I WOULD
LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO INVITE
ONE OF MY- SPEAKERS WHO'S HERE
WITH US TODAY TO JUST REALLY
BRIEFLY TELL HER TESTIMONY- AND
THAT IS I HAVE ON THE LINE
DIANNE DOROTHY BUT HERE IN
PERSON I HAVE RAINY. FROM AREAS
WHO WILL SPEAK ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCES. SHOW ME THANK YOU
YES YOU MAY PROCEED. MY NAME IS
RENEE WERE MERITS MY IT CAN
HERE OKAY I'M SORRY- COULD YOU
ADJUST THE MICROPHONE SO IT'S
NEAR- YOUR YOUR- THAT BETTER
YEAH THAT'S MUCH BETTER- MY
NAME IS RAINER MASS MY FOR
ADULT CHILDREN. AGES TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE AND I. ARE
SURVIVORS OF AN OFFICER
INVOLVED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
BIPARTISAN BILLS AND CRY- WE
WERE GRANTED A FIVE YEAR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER ON JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH I
APOLOGIZE. TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND ARE PURSUING OVER NO
RESTRAINING ORDER ON JULY SIXTH
AGAINST THE EX SPOUSE. THE
CHILDREN'S FATHER. SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT IS IMPORTANT TO
MYSELF. AND MY CHILDREN BECAUSE
IT WILL ALLOW REMOTE TESTIFYING
FOR OTHERS LIKE US I HAD TO SIT
LESS THAN FOUR FEET AWAY FROM
THE ABUSER WHEN PLEADING FOR MY
RESTRAINING ORDER. ONLY MY
CONFIDENCE FROM THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTER ADVOCATE
SEATED BETWEEN MYSELF AND THE
ABUSER. MY OLDEST SON
TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF THE
ABUSER HIS FATHER THAT DAY.
REMOTEST THE MONEY ALSO MEANS
OF THE ABUSER WILL NOT HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO PSYCHOLOGICALLY
OR PHYSICALLY INTIMIDATE THE
VICTIM IN PERSON EXAMPLE IN MY
CASE AFTER THE HEARING. THE
ABUSER REPEATEDLY PASSED ME IN
A VEHICLE AT A TIME TO GET MINE
AFTER COURT. I CANNOT EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH HOW ALL ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL WILL HELP OTHER VICTIMS
BECOME SURVIVORS LIKE MYSELF.
ALL ABUSED BECAUSE OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE THEN
PHYSICAL ABUSE LIKE WHAT I
UNDER BEGINS. THE EXPERIENCE OF
COURTS IS TAXI IN ITSELF BUT
THE FIFTY ABUSER IN A COURT
ROOM IN THE WHOLE OF THE
COURTROOM IS SCARY BECAUSE THIS
IS STILL THE TIME OF FLIGHT OR
FIGHT MODE FOR THE VICTIM.
TAKING AWAY THE POLITICAL
INTIMIDATION POWER OF THE
ABUSER WITH REMOTE TESTIMONY
AND ELECTRONIC FILING FOR THE
VICTIMS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. OF HEALING THE
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
LIKE MYSELF. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL I WAS SILENT FOR SO
LONG IN A BRIEF EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK UP NOW
ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THANK
YOU MA'AM. AT&T OPERATOR IF WE
COULD GET- MISS DORMITORY- FROM
THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE SHE'S ON THE LINE WE'D
LOVE TO HEAR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
RAMIREZ MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR RUBIO
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUE I AM
DAY AND ALREADY I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY JUSTICE CENTER.
DALY DOESN'T CENTER HAS HELPED
THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN HAS
PROVIDED ASSISTANCE TO VICTIMS
OF SEX TRAFFICKING. AS SOMEONE
WHO WORKS WITH SURVIVORS ON A
DAILY BASIS I KNOW FIRST HAND
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO PROTECT
THEM FROM BEING RE VICTIMIZED
BY THEIR ABUSERS AS MISS
RAMIREZ JUST STATED. ANY SHOW
THAT THE BEING TIMES ARE OF THE-
VIOLENCE COM WHEN THE VICTIM
DECIDES TO LEAVE THE
RELATIONSHIP AND WHEN SEEKING A
RESTRAINING ORDER. NEEDS
IMMENSE ANGER THEIR ABUSERS AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH OPPORTUNITIES
TO RETALIATE. I TESTIFYING
REMOTELY VICTIMS ARE ABLE TO
TELL THEIR STORY TO THE COURT
WITHOUT FEAR OF PHYSICAL
RETALIATION INTIMIDATION.
THREATS AND COERCION. BY THE
TIME BY THE DEFENDANT AND THE
DEFENDANT FAMILY BEFORE DURING
AND- AFTER THAT COURT HEARING.
AT THE FAMILY DOESN'T MATTER
WE'VE CREATED A SPACE WHERE
CLIENTS CAN SAFELY SPEAK TO THE
COURT IN A CALM ENVIRONMENT
THAT IS FREE OF STRESS AND
INTIMIDATION BY THEIR ABUSER AS
WELL AS THE CONFUSION OF THE
COURTHOUSE. HIS FACE STATE AND
STATE AND FREE FROM THE
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES. WITH
DRIVE TIME IS RAMIREZ.
CALIFORNIA COURTS HAVE NOW HAD
MONTHS OF VALUABLE EXPERIENCE
WITH REMOTE TESTIMONY AND IT IS
WORKING WELL. IT'S REMOTE
TESTIMONY IF DISTRICT AND THE
VIOLENCE BY FREEING THEM FROM
THE EVERYDAY FEAR OF THE
COURTHOUSE AND ALSO BENEFITS
THE ORDERLY AND EFFICIENT
CONDUCT OF THE COURTROOM. ON
BEHALF OF THE VICTIMS OF SAN
DIEGO I URGE OU TO PLEASE PUT
VICTIMS FIRST AND FOREMOST AND
KEEP THEIR FAMILIES SAFE BY
VOTING IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YES SIR YOU MAY
PROCEED GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE PATRICK
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
THIS CHART RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATIONS ARCADIA. BURBANK
CULVER CITY INGLEWOOD NEWPORT
HEALTH THIRTIES POMONA SANTA
ANA. AND LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
POLICE ASSOCIATION.
TRADITIONALLY SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THE PROJECTS-
VICTIMS OF CRIME. AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
THREE EIGHT. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYBODY OUTSIDE THE
OPERATOR WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
IF THE LINES TO ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO SUPPORT.
OF THIS MEASURE AND WE WOULD
ASK THAT THEY WOULD JUST TO
MENTION THEIR NAME. AND
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION. TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE THREE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. OUR
FIRST COMMENT WILL COME FROM
THE LINE UP EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE RED HOP ON BEHALF
OF STAND THE ECHO MERITATEN
GLORIA AND THE CITY COUNCIL. OR
PASSCODE SPONSORS AND SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT TIME I'LL COMPLAIN OF
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
LET'S GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ALEX KESSLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TO MARTEL
CUTS ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY I THINK. DO WE
HAVE ANY- BUT IN THE RUN THE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS MEASURE. DO
YOU HAVE ANYBODY WAITING
OUTSIDE ON THE LINE. WHAT WE'LL
GET RIGHT TO YOU HERE JUST A
MINUTE. DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
OUTSIDE THE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE- MISS
LIBBY SANCHEZ. SPEAKING AS A
WITNESS. FROM SEIU. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WOULD YOU STAND AS ON BEHALF OF
THE AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
IN REQUEST TO OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
WELL WE ABSOLUTELY SHARE THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
AUTHOR AND WITNESSES REGARDING
THE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC AND GUN
VIOLENCE WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
AUTHORIZING PARTIES AND
WITNESSES TO APPEAR REMOTELY
AND RESTRAINING ORDER
PROCEEDINGS WILL RESULT IN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS THEY
RELATE THE PARTY'S RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW. UNLESS THE BILL AS
AMENDED TO INCORPORATE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
OFFICIAL COURT REPORTERS
EMPLOYED BY THE COURT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DURING THE PANDEMIC
PROCEEDINGS WERE CONDUCTED
REMOTELY AND WITNESSES APPEARED
REMOTELY UNDER THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S EMERGENCY ORDER
PERMITTING SAME MY COURT
REPORTERS EXPERIENCE ATTEMPTING
TO ENSURE THE SANCTITY OF THE
OFFICIAL VERBATIM RECORD UNDER
THESE CONDITIONS HAS BEEN RIFE
WITH PROBLEMS JUST AS WE ALL
HAVE EXPERIENCED IN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN CALLS OR ANY OTHER
TECHNOLOGICAL PLATFORM UPON
WHICH WE RELY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THINGS ARE SIMPLY NOT
WORKING HARDIEST WITNESSES
LAWYERS HAVE AT TIMES BEEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO HEAR COURT
REPORTERS HAVE HAD DIFFICULTY
ALERTING JUDGES TO
TECHNOLOGICAL OR AUDIBILITY
CONCERNS DROPPED LINES AN
ERRANT SHOOTINGS HAVE OCCURRED
BACKGROUND NOISE AND SHODDY
TECHNOLOGY A DEGRADED PATH TO
MONEY TO SUCH AN EXTENT THAT IT
HAS SIMPLY BEEN IMPOSSIBLE TO
TRANSCRIBE THE OFFICIAL
VERBATIM RECORD SHOULD THE
COURT REPORTER CANNOT
TRANSCRIBE EVERY WORD UTTERED
IN A PROCEEDING THE TRANSCRIPT
PRODUCED IS UNFORTUNATELY
UNVIABLE FOR PURPOSES OF FUTURE
USE. OF THE TRANSCRIPT IS
REQUIRED TO EXERCISE ONE'S
RIGHTS ON APPEAL THE
UNFORTUNATE TRAJECTORY OF
PERMITTING PARTIES AND
WITNESSES TO APPEAR REMOTELY
THAT SUCH PARTY IS MAYBE GIVING
UP THEIR RIGHTS ON APPEAL
WITHOUT. EVEN KNOWING THEY ARE
DOING THAT THIS CAN BE. PROBLEM
WHERE AS HAPPENS OFTEN IN MY
COURT THE BRIDGE. ORDER PARTY
IS NOW A- FOR. BUT INSTEAD IS
THE JOINT PROCEEDING WITH AN
UNDERLYING CRIMINAL PROCEEDING.
THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS TO
PROTECT AGAINST THAT FIRST
REQUIRE AN OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTER EMPLOYED BY THE COURT
SHOULD BE IN THE COURTROOM.
ALONG WITH THE PRESIDING
OFFICER ANYTIME THERE IS A
REMOTE APPEARANCE. TO REQUIRE A
JUDICIAL ADMONITION FROM THE
PRESIDING OFFICER ADVISING
PARTIES OF THEIR RIGHTS AND THE
POTENTIAL IMPLICATIONS TO THOSE
RIGHT. AND THE OFFICIAL
VERBATIM RECORD WHERE A PARTY
OR WITNESS APPEARS REMOTELY AND
FINALLY THREE. A LIMITATION OF
AUTHORIZATION FOR REMOTE
APPEARANCES TO ONLY THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE THE RESTRAINING
ORDER IS A STANDALONE
PROCEEDING. WE ARE HOPEFUL THE
AUTHOR WILL CONSIDER SUCH
AMENDMENTS TO THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM- THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE CLARITY ASKED THAT OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. OPEN UP THE
LINES OPERATOR TO ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
NOTHING WOULD LIMIT THEIR-
OPPOSITION TO THEIR NAME. AND
ORGANIZATION WE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. AND OUR FIRST
COMMENT WILL COME FROM LINE UP
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE- CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE-
PROCEDURAL ISSUES RELATED TO
REMOTE CAST PARTY. THANK YOU.
HOW MUCH IS FROM EIGHT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS AMY KOCH KO COREY
PORTER FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION WE ECHO S. YOUR
USER CONTENT AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED REGRETFULLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HER NEXT COMMENT IS
FROM EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SANDY
WALDRON AND PAST PRESIDENT FOR
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION. AND I'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS WHICH ARE
NOT HEARING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AMADOR ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WILL NOW COME TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO-
YES. MEMBERS YEAH I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST TO SEIU IN THE COURT
REPORTERS THAT THE WAY TO FIX
THIS. IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS GOOD TECHNOLOGY THERE
ARE YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
ATTENDING TO MISS YOU SO
MEETINGS FOR A YEAR. I HEAR THE
PEOPLE JUST AS WELL ON SOON AS
I WOULD IF THEY WERE IN PERSON.
YOU ALSO HAVE THE OPTION OF
RECORDING THE WHOLE THING-
THAT'S JUST. YOU KNOW ONE
OPTION- YOU JUST PRESSED
SOMETHING AND IT RECORDS SO I
JUST DON'T SEE THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY OF A COURT REPORTER
IF THERE IS RELIABLE
TECHNOLOGY. ARE HEARING THIS
AND I THINK THAT THE PROPER
SOLUTION TO THIS WOULD BE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS PROPER
TECHNOLOGY IF THERE'S NOT.
PLEASE CONTACT ME AND I'LL MAKE
SURE I RUN A BILL TO MAKE SURE
OF THAT NEXT YEAR THANK YOU.
AND I SUPPORT YOUR BILL 100%
WE'VE ALREADY MOVED IT AND SO
I'LL BE VOTING NINE. OKAY NOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL
FIRST I JUST WANT UP YOU DON'T
KNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS OF A CA
YOU- I DON'T WANT TO DISMISS
SOME ANTI WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE
YOUR THEIR CONCERNS BUT- AS
STATED THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A
LOT OF COUNTIES WHO'VE ALREADY
GONE REMOTELY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND- AS ALL OF US
ZOOMING THROUGHOUT. THE YEAR
WE'VE LEARNED HOW TO GET BETTER
AT IT BUT THE GOAL IS TO MAKE
IT JUST EASIER FOR VICTIMS TO
COME OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THEY CAN-SPEAK UP IN FRONT OF THEIR
ABUSER. BUT I WANT TO MAKE TWO
POINTS CLEAR NUMBER ONE THIS
DOES NOT ALTER DUE PROCESS AND
ANYWAY THIS IS JUST ABOUT
CREATING ACCESS AND NUMBER TWO-
AND I HAVE TO SAY THIS YOU KNOW
EVERY DAY FOR A VICTIM TO BE IN
FRONT OTHER ABUSERS MAY BE
THEIR LAST SO THIS IS CRITICAL.
SPEAKING WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL THANK YOU. WELL I
CLEARLY IN APPRECIATIVE OF
THIS. MEASURES I'M A CO AUTHOR.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE CHAIR IS
ALSO RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE
WITHOUT WILL GO AND TO CALL FOR
THE QUESTION. AN SB FIVE THREE
EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY I BARAKAT
BARAKAT HAD HI LEE. LEE I CORK
BY CORK I SANTIAGO. C. R. TWO
C. R. TWO I WICKS.
CONGRADULATIONS THAT MEASURE
PASSES KATHY. I THINK WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR SKINNER AND
STERN IPHONE. WE ALSO GOT
LEADERS HE WOULD SHOW UP AND.
YEAH YEAH YEAH. YOU KNOW I
DON'T. SO SHOULD WE CALL STERN.
BURKE YEAH- THE PROPOSAL.
NUMBER FOUR SECURITIES WITH
SOME REQUEST THE WHOLE. THREE
ONE. SO WE WEREN'T REALLY SURE
YEAH. THE FIRM.
YEAH.
THREE
WELL.
THIS DEGREE OF.
I'M
MEMBERS- FIRST WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US AND I
JUST WANNA SAY I FOUND THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS EXTREMELY
THOROUGH AND INFORMATIVE
PARTICULARLY IN TALKING ABOUT
THE SCIENTIFIC- FOR- FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
BENEFITS OF PSYCHEDELICS AND SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THEIR
ANALYSIS AND WE ARE- HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE- PROPOSED AMENDMENT
IN ANALYSIS- REMOVING CADMIUM-
FROM THE BILL CAN I MEAN
THERE'S HUGE BENEFITS IN TERMS
OF TREATING SEVERE DEPRESSION-
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT IT IN
ADDITION TO CAN BE PRESCRIBED-
BY A PHYSICIAN SO WERE WILL BE
MOVING OUT FROM THE BILL- IN
ACCORDANCE WITH- OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE.
AND THEN THERE ARE SOME OTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ARE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT- AS WELL I
COLLEAGUES- SB FIVE NINETEEN
WILL DECRIMINALIZE THE
POSSESSION- AND PERSONAL USE
OF- PSILOCYBIN PSILOCIN AND DNA
LSD DMT MESCALINE AIBO GAMES
ARE ONLY. FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE.
ONLY FOR WHO ARE TWENTY. AND
OLDER THE BILL IS NO
APPLICATION TO ANYONE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE. AND WE MODEL
THAT STRUCTURE OVER THE
APPROACH. TO CANNABIS. SO WHAT
DO YOU MEAN BY THE CRIMINALIZES
BEEN SOME QUESTIONS AND PEOPLE
SOMETIMES HEAR THE WORD. AND
THEY DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT
MEANS. WHEN WE SAY THEY
CRIMINALIZE WHAT WE MEAN IS
THAT UNDER SB FIVE NINETEEN. WE
WILL NO LONGER ARREST PEOPLE
AND INCARCERATE THEM. FOR THE
SIMPLE PERSONAL POSSESSION. OF
PSYCHEDELICS FOR PERSONAL. OR
SHARED USE SO THAT'S REALLY THE
QUESTION HERE- DO WE BELIEVE.
THAT WE SHOULD BE ARRESTING
SOMEONE. BECAUSE THEY POSSESS
PSYCHEDELICS. FOR PERSONAL USE.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD FRANKLY
I THINK MOST PEOPLE DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD BE DOING THAT. THE
BILL DOES NOT DECRIMINALIZE THE
SALE OF PSYCHEDELICS THAT WILL
CONTINUE. TO BE A CRIME. TO
PROMOTE SAFER USE THE BILL ALSO
DECRIMINALIZE IS DRUG TESTING
KITS SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY TEST SWAB ANTESTOR
PSYCHEDELICS TO CONFIRM THAT
THEY ARE NOT CONTAMINATED THAT
IS SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
PROMOTING FOR ALL DRUG USE
PARTICULARLY WITH A FENCE IN A
LOCKED THEM BACK. IN TERMS OF
MATH AD HER WHEN THAT'S BEING
LACED BUT HERE WHERE
SPECIFICALLY THE CRIMINALIZING
OF FOR PSYCHEDELICS. SB FIVE
NINETEEN ALSO CONVENES AN
EXPERT WORKING GROUP. UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING POTENTIAL FUTURE
STRATEGIES. AROUND SAFE USE
THAT CETERA OF PSYCHEDELICS.
SINCE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THIS BILL
AND I SUSPECT YOU WILL HEAR
SOME OF THAT IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY FRANKLY SOME
OUTRAGEOUS MISREPRESENTATIONS
AROUND THE BILL. JUST TO
CLARIFY THE BILL DOES NOT
DECRIMINALIZE THE SALE OF
PSYCHEDELICS. IT DOES NOT
DECRIMINALIZE. IN ANYWAY GIVING
OR SHARING OR OTHERWISE
PROVIDING PSYCHEDELICS TO
ANYONE UNDER TWENTY ONE. ALL
THAT WILL REMAIN ILLEGAL. WHAT
SB FIVE NINETEEN DIES IS ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS WITHOUT
BEING A CRIMINAL. TO SUBSTANCES
THAT ARE LITERALLY FIXING
PEOPLE'S BRAINS. LITERALLY
ENDING MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION DIAGNOSES NOT ONLY
IMPROVING CONDITIONS BUT
ACCORDING THIS RECENT
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES FOR EXAMPLE
AROUND MDMA. MAKING IT TO THE
PEOPLE WITH PTSD NO LONGER HAVE
A PTSD DIAGNOSIS. BUT SOMEONE
ADDICTED TO HEROIN IS NO LONGER
ADDICTED TO HER OR NOT JUST
IMPROVING. DOT TO BUT SITUATION
WHERE PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE
LITERALLY TRANSFORMS BECAUSE OF
THESE SUBSTANCES. FOR FAR TOO
LONG THE ONLY REGULATIONS THAT
WE KIND OF THESE SUBSTANCES IS
THE SAY IF YOU POSSESS AND USE
THAT YOU'RE A CRIMINAL AND YOU
MIGHT GET ARRESTED AND PUT IN
PRISON. RATHER THAN PROPERLY
EVEN TRYING TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN DIFFERENT DRUG
SUBSTANCES. WE JUST TREAT
EVERYTHING AS SOMEHOW MORALLY.
IN GENERAL HAS BEEN A FAILURE
WE WERE TRYING TO ARREST OUR
WAY OUT OF DRUG USE AND
ADDICTION FOR FIFTY YEARS AND
IT HASN'T IMPROVED ANYTHING
WHATSOEVER PEOPLE ARE STILL
USING- PEOPLE ARE STILL GETTING
ADDICTED NOT TO PSYCHEDELICS
BECAUSE THESE ARE GENERALLY NOT
ADDICTIVE BUT OTHER DRUGS. AND
ALL WE'VE DONE IS FILL UP OUR
PRISON WITH DRUG CRIMES AND
WE'RE NOT SAFER AND WE JUST
SPENT A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY- THE
FAILED WAR ON DRUGS. HAS BEEN A
HUGE BURDEN ON TAX REVENUES
TORN COMMUNITIES APART IT HAS
DRAMATICALLY HARM BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES AND HAS DONE
NOTHING TO MAKE THE COMMUNITY
SAFER. OR TO MAKE PEOPLE SAFER
IF THEY'RE USING DRUGS IN FACT
IT'S MADE US LESS SAFE BECAUSE
PEOPLE USE IN THE SHADOWS THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE COMMITTING A
CRIME AND SO THEY DON'T GET
INFORMATION. AND EDUCATION.
THAT COULD LET THEM BE SAFER.
IT'S TIME THAT WE STOP OUR
FAILED POLICY OF MASS
INCARCERATION IN THE KNOWLEDGE.
THAT NOT EVERY SUBSTANCE IS
HARMFUL. JUST BECAUSE- A
HUNDRED OR FIFTY YEARS AGO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECLARED
THAT A PARTICULAR SUBSTANCE. IS
SOMEHOW BAD AND THUS ILLEGAL.
THE SUBSTANCES IN THIS BILL
HAVE BEEN FOUND NOT JUST BY
POLITICIANS OR ADVOCATES BY
SCIENTISTS BY SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES INCLUDING AND IN NEW
ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
STUDIES AFFILIATED WITH THE FTA.
BUT A MYRIAD OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES INCLUDING ANXIETY
ADDICTION DEPRESSION INSOMNIA
EATING DISORDERS PTSD SMOKING.
CAN BE DRAMATICALLY IMPROVES
WITH PSYCHEDELIC THERAPY.
VETERANS AND MANY OF YOU ARE
PROBABLY I HOPE MATTER HEARD
FROM OUR VETERANS ARE
SPONSORING ORGANIZATIONS OR TO
ORGANIZATIONS OF COMBAT
VETERANS WHO WORK WITH VETERANS
WHO HAVE GONE TO WAR FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND BEEN HARMED AS A
RESULT AND COME BACK WITH PTSD
WITH SEVERE DEPRESSION WITH
OTHER. DISORDERS AND YOU
TREATMENT TRADITIONAL TREATMENT
HASN'T WORKED. AND PSYCHEDELIC
THERAPY HAS ALLOWED THEM TO GET
THEIR LIVES BACK AND YET WE
FORCED THEM TO GO TO PERU OR
MEXICO OR TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
TO GET THIS TREATMENT AFTER
THEY FOUGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE MADE IT ILLEGAL HERE.
EIGHTEEN VETERANS COMMIT
SUICIDE EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
THIS COUNTRY EIGHTEEN EVERYDAY
COMMENSURATE SIDE. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM AMONG
OTHER NOT JUST VETERANS AMONG
OTHERS. ACTUALLY TURN THEIR
LIVES AROUND. THESE IMPACTS
HAVE BEEN FOUND BOTH IN A
CLINICAL SETTING. IT ALSO IN
NON CLINICAL SETTINGS AND IT'S
TIME WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
BENEFITS OF THESE SUBSTANCES
EVEN OUTSIDE OF A CLINICAL
SETTING. I WANT TO BE CLEAR I
SAID THIS EARLIER THAT
PSYCHEDELICS ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
NOT A DETECTIVE. AND PEOPLE CAN
USE THEM SAFELY. BUT IT'S
HARDER TO USE THEM SAFELY IF
PEOPLE ARE CRIMINALIZED FOR
DOING SO. BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN THAT LAST NOVEMBER OREGON
VOTERS. VOTED TO DECRIMINALIZE
NOT TO PSYCHEDELICS BUT
POSSESSION OF ALL DRUGS. EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM. THE MAIN
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE THINK WE
HAVE TO GO TO THE VOTERS FOR
THESE THINGS THE MAIN HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES JUST VOTED TO
DECRIMINALIZE THE POSSESSION OF
ALL DRUGS A WEEK OR TWO AGO.
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING EVEN
THOUGH I SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS
AND I HOPE CALIFORNIA GETS
THERE IN THIS BILL WE'RE
PROPOSING A MUCH NARROWER
SUBSET. OF THOSE STOPS. WE KNOW
THE PORTUGAL DECRIMINALIZED
POSSESSION. AND WHAT TYPE THERE
ARE ALL SORTS OF GLOOM AND DOOM
PREDICTIONS ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IN PORTUGAL. WHAT
HAPPENED IN PORTUGAL. OVERDOSE
DEATHS. WENT DOWN HIV
INFECTIONS WENT DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY. BECAUSE THEY
STARTED TO TREAT DRUGS AS WHAT
IT IS IT'S A HEALTH ISSUE NOT A
CRIMINAL ISSUE. I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF FEAR THAT
COULD SPREAD ABOUT
PSYCHEDELICS. PEOPLE YOU KNOW
GO BACK TO THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
IT'S LIKE THE PSYCHEDELIC
EQUIVALENT OF REEFER MADNESS
THAT THIS IS GONNA LIKE DO ALL
SORTS OF HORRIBLE THINGS. AND
THAT IS JUST NOT TRUE ANY
SUBSTANCE CAN BE MISUSED. I
COULD GO HOME TONIGHT AND TAKE
TOO MANY SLEEPING PILLS. AND
HARM MYSELF YOU COULD TAKE TOO
MUCH COUGH SYRUP. AND HARM
YOURSELF YOU TAKE TOO MANY
TYLENOL AND HARMS OF ANY
SUBSTANCE IN THE WORLD CAN BE
MISUSED AND THAT'S WHY I WANT
TO GET PEOPLE HELPING EDUCATION
INSTEAD OF ARRESTING THEM. BUT
WE NEED TO BE CLEAR THAT
PROHIBITION DOESN'T WORK IT
DIDN'T WORK WITH ALCOHOL HASN'T
WORKED IN THE WAR ON DRUGS AND
SPECIFICALLY IT DOESN'T WORK
WITH PSYCHEDELICS SO COLLEAGUES
I ASKED FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD-
TAKE A HEALTH BASED BASED
APPROACH TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE- WITH ME TODAY TESTIFIED.
HARD ADJUSTING RULED WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF THE
HERO CARTS PROJECT- A COMBAT
VETERANS ORGANIZATION AND A CO
SPONSOR OF SB FIVE NINETEEN.
AND DR ROBERT GRANT A PROFESSOR
OF MEDICINE AT UC US OFF. THANK
YOU. YES SIR YOU MAY PROCEED AT
THE MIKE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JESSE GOLD
AND I'M THE FOUNDER PRO CARDS
PROJECT WHICH IS CO SPONSOR
CALIFORNIA BILL SB FIVE ONE
NINE. I COULD NEVER IMAGINE
BEING IN THIS POSITION TODAY
ADVOCATING FOR PSYCHEDELIC
MEDICINE BUT I'VE ALWAYS
FOLLOWED MY HEART AND INTUITION
THAT HAS CONSISTENTLY LED ME ON
A LIFE OF SERVICE. BEFORE THE
MILITARY I WAS IN FINANCE ON
WALL STREET BUT I DECIDED TO
ENLIST IN THE ARMY TO GIVE BACK
AND SERVE THIS GREAT COUNTRY. I
FOUND COMMUNITY IN PURPOSE AS
AN AIRBORNE RANGER AND I
DEVELOPED AS A LEADER AS A
NONCOMMISSIONED OFFICER OVER
THREE COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS. I
MADE A PLEDGE TO LEAVE NO
SOLDIER BEHIND. THE FIRST FOUND
PSYCHEDELIC MEDICINES OUT OF
NECESSITY. HAVING TRIED ALL
THAT WAS OFFERED TO ME BY
MILITARY MEDICINE I WAS BARELY
HOLDING ON. I TURNED TO
PSYCHEDELICS AS A LAST DITCH
EFFORT TO SURVIVE. AND
FORTUNATELY IT WORKED AMAZINGLY
WELL- CARDS PROJECT WAS CREATED
EDUCATE AND CONNECT MY FELLOW
VETERANS TO THESE EFFECTIVE
OPTIONS. THIS WAS NEARLY FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS AGO AND SINCE
THEN I'VE BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE VETERAN SUICIDE
EPIDEMIC THAT SENATOR WIENER
RECENTLY MENTIONED. NEARLY
EVERY DAY MY TEAM RECEIVES
MESSAGES FROM VETERANS WHO HAVE
FALLEN THROUGH THE CRACKS OF
THE SYSTEM OR FROM THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE EXHAUSTED AND
DESPERATE BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF OPTIONS. IT IS HARD TO PUT
INTO WORDS HOW MUCH THIS CRISIS
HAS DECIMATED THE MILITARY
COMMUNITY MY COMMUNITY. THE
WEIGHT OF IT ALL HAS FALLEN ON
INDIVIDUALS AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS MANY OF WHICH ARE
AT A BREAKING POINT. JUST LAST
MONTH ANOTHER FRIEND OF MINE. A
VETERAN TOOK HIS OWN LIFE. HE
WAS DOING HIS BEST TO SAVE
OTHERS BUT IT CAME AT THE
EXPENSE OF HIS OWN MENTAL
HEALTH. VETERANS SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO FACE THIS ALONE AND IN
THE SHADOWS. BUT THEY ARE DOING
THAT RIGHT NOW. THE CRIMINALITY
IS NOT AFFECTED THEIR ABILITY
TO GO THERE THEY ARE EITHER
HAVING TO GO TO OTHER COUNTRIES
OR FORMING THEIR OWN GROUPS
PURELY TO SAVE THEIR OWN LIVES.
AT THE VETERANS SUPPORT.
PSYCHEDELICS HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT OUR LIVES.
JUST RECENTLY THE DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
HEALTH PRETTY PSYCHEDELIC
POTENTIAL AS A THERAPEUTIC
TREATMENT. A SENTIMENT HAS BEEN
ECHOED BY THE FDA AS WELL AS
PROMINENT UNIVERSITIES LIKE
JOHNS HOPKINS. THE VETERANS ARE
DYING TODAY RIGHT NOW. SB FIVE
ONE NINE IS A COMPASSIONATE
STEP FORWARD AND PROVIDES A
MEASURE OF HOPE IN A TIME FRAME
OF MONTHS NOT YEARS TO THOSE
ARE BARELY HOLDING ON RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM OR LIKE I JUST FIND
SUPPORT AT LEAST DR GRANT IS ON
THE PHONE HE'S ARE UTTERLY WHEN
US OKAY. A. T. T. OPERATOR IF
WE CAN- OF MR STYLES. ON THE
PHONE GOT TO WRAP. HE IS
AVAILABLE YES THERE WE THOUGHT
HE WAS WITH PATIENTS BUT NOW
APPARENTLY HE'S ABOUT OKAY DR
GRANT WOULD BE GOOD. YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FLEXIBILITY
BY THE. AT&T OPERATOR WE NEED
TO SPEAK TO A DOCTOR ROBERT
GRANT OF THESE ON THE LINE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
DOCTOR ROBERT GRANT YES WE CAN
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY OKAY- YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF- SENATE BILL OF FIVE
NINETEEN- PSYCHEDELIC THERAPIES
HAVE EMERGED AS AN EXTREMELY
PROMISING- APPROACH TO A
VARIETY OF MENTAL ILLNESSES
INCLUDING PTSD DEPRESSION
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS- THESE-
MEDICINES ARE BEING EVALUATED
INTENSIVELY AND CLINICAL
STUDIES AND ARE INCREASINGLY
BECOMING AVAILABLE FOR A
PEOPLE'S USE FOR- CONDITIONS
INCLUDING PTSD DEPRESSION
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO IT IS LAUNCHING A
PSYCHEDELIC- MEDICINE RESEARCH
CENTER IN AUGUST OF THIS YEAR
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF A NEW
FACULTY RECRUIT- ROBIN CARHART
HARRIS. WHO HAS PUBLISHED
EXTENSIVELY ON HOW THESE
MEDICATIONS- HAVE BENEFIT SHOW
AFFECTS ON THE BRAIN- SO- YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THESE MEDICINES TO BECOME
MORE READILY AVAILABLE IN
POPULATIONS AND CERTAINLY
PEOPLE- SHOULD NOT BE
INCARCERATED FOR- SEEKING A
HEALING PATH WITH THESE
MEDICATIONS. SO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ON
BEHALF OF THIS- BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK- IN SUPPORT OF
THE REBEL. DIANNE HOLDS. STAND
GOLDSTINE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION
PARTNERSHIP REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE THOUSAND CURRENT FORMER
AND RETIRED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROFESSIONALS. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ANTHONY MONNING ON
BEHALF OF DECRIMINALIZED NATURE
AND SUPPORT AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE WHO
ARE NOT ABLE TO ATTEND TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAKIN SUPPORT THAT IS
OUTSIDE. HEARING NONE AT AND T.
OPERATOR OF WE COULD OPEN THE
LINES FOR PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
MEASURE PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
ONE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. OUR FIRST TIME-
COMPLAIN A NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
CAME FROM TV NEXT I STRONGLY
OPPOSED. SB FIVE ONE NINE.
THANK YOU. AGAIN THE USER
EXPERIMENTALIST TO BE CALLS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IS A REMINDER
THOSE ONLINE THESE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE JUST WAS IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. CONNECT
COMMENT IS FROM LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MEXICO TWO LINES
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
NOW THE HIGHEST FROM CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LAST
COMMENT IS FROM NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOSHUA TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SACRAMENTO TRAMLINE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR IF
THIS GO AHEAD. GREETINGS JAMES
MCCONKEY- REPRESENTING A
DECRIMINALIZING YOUR SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE PSYCHEDELIC
SMALL BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE OWNER OF THE KIDS
TEACHERS SHOP IN THE COMPLETE
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CONNECT COMMENT
IS FROM NINE NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
COMMITTEE THIS IS A GREGORY
STYLE WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BUT I NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO MARK ABOUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I NINE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
THE WHOLE BREED YOU CAN'T JUST
GO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU SENATOR
WARNER THANK YOU. NEXT LINE IS
NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ZACKS STYLES
THE VETERANS CLINIC DIRECTOR AT
UC BERKELEY'S CENTER FOR
PSYCHEDELIC SCIENCE STRONGLY
SUPPORTING SB FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. COMATOSE
FROM ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL LITTLE AND THAT THE U.
S. ARMY VETERAN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE NINETEEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
CONNECT COMMENT IS FROM NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI AM GIULIANA MERCER
SIXTY NEAR MARINE CORPS VETERAN
CALIFORNIA NATIVE. HERKST CARTS
PROJECT IF THE COURT SB FIVE
NINETEEN ALSO I WAS JUST YOU
KNOW WE LIKE TO REGISTER THE
SUPPORT OF NEW APPROACH
ADVOCACY FOR THE RECORD. THANK
YOU. COMMENTERS FROM NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
COURTNEY CRAMER AND I'M CALLING
LOS ANGELES- YAMA STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
BY NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS A SMILEY
ACTING POLICY DIRECTOR AT AND
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT RESEARCH AND
EDUCATIONAL ORGANIZATION THE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY ASSOCIATION
FOR PSYCHEDELIC STUDIES CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THE HAMLEY CHAND- 100%
DISABLED VETERAN TIMES THIS
GOAL VETERANS COMMISSIONER AND
HIGHLY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE NINE HUNDRED
AND TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DR LARRY NORRIS I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT
AND EUGENIC RESEARCH
INTEGRATION EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT OF DECRIMINALIZING
SICKER PLANTS ASSEMBLY FUNGI IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK. YOU. NINE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A LOT OF
REPRESENTING THE WITH DOCUMENT
AFFECTED OUR COMMUNITY BASED ON
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BUT COMMITTEES
FROM NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DR REGINA MOORE CO FOUNDER
OF THE THANK YOU NOTE FROM
FIFTY XIN AND COFOUNDER OF THE
PSYCHEDELIC SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION VOICING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER WAS DECRIMINALIZED
NATURE IN TEMPERATURES GO. AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR STEFAN
CONTENT CO FOUNDER OF THE
MYCOLOGY CONSCIOUSNESS
INSTITUTE INTER TRIBAL MEDICINE
ABOUT THE- AND TRANSPERSONAL
CHAIR IN BY THE EPA AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE. I NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR ALI OF
BILLIONS TIME I AM A BOARD
CERTIFIED FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN AT A MEDICAL
RESEARCHER FROM BERKELEY. AND
MEDICAL DIRECTORFOR THE
NONPROFIT MULTI DISCIPLINARY
ASSOCIATION FOR PSYCHEDELIC
STUDIES I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL FIVE ONE NIGHT
BECAUSE LEGALIZATION AFFECTED
ALEX NEWPORT AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUE. WHEN A CALAMITOUS
FROM NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS CHILLED ME AND THEM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION HOUSE FALL SB
FIVE NINETEEN IT'S A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE AND ALSO I WANTED
TO SHARE ONE COACH FROM THOMAS-
ARE STILL WELL WITH- WITH THE
SENATOR- NANCY SKINNER- GIVE ME
ONE SECOND LET ME EAD IT.
HELLO ONCE AGAIN SORRY IT'S
BASICALLY SAYING THAT
POLITICIANS ARE MAKING THINGS
WORSE AND STOP THE FORTY CAN
MAKE THINGS BETTER- LET ME-
IT'S RIGHT HERE LET ME SHARE IT
AND ADDRESSING TO- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SENATOR NANCY SKINNER.
THERE'S NOTHING SO GOOD THAT
POLITICIANS CANNOT MAKE IT THAT
AND NOTHING SO BAD THAT
POLITICIANS CAN'T MAKE IT WORSE
CRIME IS BAD BUT POLITICIANS
HAVE MADE IT WORSE BY GOING
EASY ON CRIMINALS THANK YOU
SKINNER WISELY. I MEAN YOU
YOU'RE LIKE A FAILURE OKAY.
LET'S GO ON TO THE NEXT CALL.
SEVEN ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
NOW WE'RE WE'RE GOING HERE. WE
JUST TO SUPPORT WOMEN DO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FRANKLY THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
DRUGS BY PHONE AND JOHN LOVELL
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS. I DON'T
SEE MISTER LIU NEAR ME YES WHO
IS THIS. YEAH THIS IS JOHN
LEVEL HI JOHN YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY HI HOW
ARE YOU GOOD- YES- BUT FIRST OF
ALL LET ME SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT ALONG. THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
IS NOT ABOUT INCARCERATING
PEOPLE FOR POSSESSION IN FACT
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW NOW WITH
PROPOSITION THIRTY SIX WITH A
WHOLE HOST OF DRUG COURT
INTERVENTIONS AND TREATMENT-
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD PATHWAY
FOR- FOR- POSSESSION. WELL
ISSUES BUT I WANT TO JUST TALK
ABOUT TWO ISSUES VERY QUICKLY-
THE FIRST FEELS WEIRD- LSD-
THE- PROBLEM WITH THE CHALLENGE
WITH LSD. IS THAT IT IS MARRIED
TO FLASHBACKS AND THAT'S A
CONSTANT- KILL YOU ONE QUICK
FAMILY STORY A FAMILY MEMBER OF
MINE- WHEN SHE WAS EIGHTEEN.
WAS GIVEN LSD SURREPTITIOUSLY
SHE WASN'T AWARE OF THAT. AND
SHE WOUND UP BEING HOSPITALIZED
AND RAN FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
SHE HAD FLASHBACKS. YEAH BEFORE
THIS BILL WAS HEARD I ACTUALLY
CALLED HER AND I SAID WHEN WAS
YOUR LAST FLASHBACK AND SHE
SAID TO ME JOHN I STILL GET THE
I DON'T GET THEM AS OFTEN BUT I
STILL GET THEM. AND THIS IS IN
FLASHBACKS ARE NOT WELL JUST
ONE FAMILY NARRATION- TODAY I'D
ACTUALLY- GOOGLE- FLASHBACKS
BECAUSE BY L. A. B. AND I GOT
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ENTRIES ON THE ON THE INTERNET-
AND- WE BELIEVE IT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE. TO PUT SOMETHING
OUT THERE THAT YOU KNOW TRACK
IS A TRIP PEOPLE CAN HAVE FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES. THE
OTHER ISSUE WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT USING SOCIAL SHARING. WE
ARE VERY CAREFUL THAT WE ARE
NOT INTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE TO
INCREASE. OVER THE METALLIC-
OVER IN THE SENATE EARLIER THIS
YEAR THERE WAS A BILL DEALING
WITH. OPIOID OF CALORIES OR FAT
NOW- THE CALORIES THERE WERE
ONE HUNDRED PARENTS WHO CAME TO
TESTIFY ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN
WHO HAD DIED NONE OF THEIR
CHILDREN FOR DRUG USERS THEY
NEEDED A KILL FOR SOMETHING.
AND IT TURNED OUT TO BE WRONG
AND THE PERSON DIED WEEKLY.
PREP SO THE SOCIAL SHE SHARING-
CREATES WE'LL- POTENTIAL FOR-
ON. BUT THINK THAT'S WHAT GONNA.
AND WE'RE ALL VERY CAN. ABOUT
pLSD WHEN THE REALITY IS THAT
LST COLUMNS WITH. FLASHBACKS
AND- FOR THAT REPORT WE ARE WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL BASED
ON BOTH PROVISIONS- IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
OKAY THANK LEAVING CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST TRUCKS IT
BILL KATAMON MAY BE TAKEN OFF
OF THE LEASE ON THE FIVE
NINETEEN THERE ARE STILL MANY
DANGEROUS ILLEGAL DRUGS
INCLUDING APPEAL. THEIR
ACCOMPLISHED ON KEEPING
FIGHTING OF SPAIN SHOOTING THAT
THESE DRUG BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
THE POSSIBLE HARM SB EIGHT
SHOULD HAVE ALREADY REMOVED
THEM FROM THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE ABUSED FACT THAT.
THEY HAD NOT SAYS IT ALL.
HOLDEN SAYS PEOPLE WAIT- AT THE
TO APPROVE DESTRUCTS AND THE
TICKET NOW. BUT THERE'S NO
BETTER DANTE FDA FDA LEADERS
TO. FOSTER WE FOLLOW THE FDA
GUIDELINES. IN ADDITION TO
PROPONENT DID NOT COME UP WITH
ANY STATISTICS TO PROVE THAT
THANK A BENDIX CAN REALLY HELP
PEOPLE TO AVOID SERIOUS. DUST.
THIS IS NOT A VENN UPON. AND
THE FACT THAT LEADERS OF MORE
WORK TO HIGH JUST THE CLOSEST
INSTEAD. EVEN G. AGAINST BILL
LAST EIGHT TO A WITH LOCAL FEET.
WE FAXED THE STATE MY- VETERANS
WERE TO BE. IS I BELIEVE. IS
ALSO MISLEADING TO SAY THAT
THIS OFFICE. THE BILL SPENDS A
THAT THE COMMISSION BFF. TO
REGULATE THE TRUCKS. I SETTING
UP AND SHOULD BE LEFT GETTING
IN THE WAR CRITICAL. SB ONE
FIVE NINE NINE ALSO AUTHORIZES
THE SOCIAL SHARING OF THE
TRUCKS RESPECTIVELY KEEPING THE
POPULACE. IN DEFENSE IT ALSO
KEEPS THE DOOR WIDE OPEN FOR
EVEN TO OPENING OFF PRIVILEGED
TOPIC CONSUMPTION ARE LESS
DESTRUCTION. EVEN THOUGH SHE
WAS BEING SUPPRESSED SB FIVE
ONE NIGHT CITIZENS HAVE NO ROOM
TO COMPROMISE BUT YOU I WILL WE
JUST HOPE YOU CAN ASK FOR
LEGISLATORS TO DO THE SAME. FOR
THE BETTERMENT ABOUT THE SIDE
DE ESPECIALLY OUR. FUTURE
GENERATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT ARE THERE ANY ONE IN
THE ROOM POSITION NAY EVEN
ORGANISE. YOU MAY COME TO THE-
YES GREG BURKE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. MISTER SHERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WOULD
LIKE TO CONVEY OUR APPRECIATION
TO THE AUTHOR FOR REMOVING-
KEVIN- UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THIS TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
FLINTSTONES MOVIE COMING EARLY
WITNESSES. THAT ARE IN THE
OUTSIDE IN THE- GO. SEE NON
PARTY WITNESSES ON THE FLOOR I
MEAN IN ON FIVE THEY MAY NOW
SPEAKING OPPOSITION. TWO SB
FIVE OR NINE. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD NAME
AN ORGANIZATION ALONG. FIRST
TIME- COMPLAIN OF NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHELLE CONNOR.
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS AS
OUTLINED IN A LETTER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER THIRTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'VE LINE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN ANY
SHOOTER BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
OF THE COMBAT VIETNAM VETERAN
AND WE'RE BOTH STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SB FIVE NINETEEN. THANK YOU.
TWO NINE EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR THE
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS TO
RESET GAVE THE COCA COLA
COMPANY DID PUBLIC CENTER WE
HAVE LIKE FOUR HUNDRED THAT
MEMBERS AND WE ALL IN A POST ON
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU. I NINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS MERI LEE SCHNEIDER DIRECTOR
RIGHT TO LIFE OF KERN COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
ONE NINE ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE. NINE SEVEN EIGHT
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
THE PEOPLE. BUT WITH THE RIGHT
HOME FOR THE NEXT. IN LINE NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ANY HERRINGTON CALLING FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A. LAMBERT
WITH CRIME VICTIMS UNITED AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WELL HELLO VERY. HI MY
NAME IS LI EMILY I AM A U. S.
ARMY VETERAN AND NOT ONLY THAT
I ACTUALLY WORK IN THE PHARMACY
FIVE YEARS IN YOUR ARMY YOUR
ORGANIZATION PHARMACY. MY NAME
IS BREANNA LIMIT I HAVE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO MEMBERS OF
THE UNITED WE STAND BOTH OF MY
MEMBERS DO NOT SPEAK ENGLISH.
ONE FIVE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE SPOKE HELLO THE
APPLE STORE. GET ANY BLACK
METAL I'M OPPOSED TO SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU SIR. ONE
EIGHT ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
ELEVEN IN MY CURRENT YES YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
OKAY MY NAME IS KATHERINE HOW
CAN I- COME FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FIVE NINETEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HELLO. HELLO YOUR
NAME YES YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. OUR ADDED
ON THE EVE OF THE TO ENTER I'M
JOHNNY COUPLE COMPOSED APPEAL-
SB FIVE ONE NINE. THANK YOU.
ONE EIGHT FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MANY YOUNG I'M FROM
BUSINESS AND HOUSING NOT
NETWORK AND STAY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE POINT
NINE. THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MICHELLE WAGNER FROM
XFACTOR COUNTY I'M A MOM OF
THREE ADULT CHILDREN WHO AREN'T
THAT MARRIAGES AND FAMILIES AND
I'M AND SHAUN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU JUDY
ISSUE BOARD CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN
IN INTERNAL MEDICINE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. NEIGHBORHOOD YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. HELLO
HELLO. WHAT'S YOUR NAME. THEY
MAY NOT BE ON MY TERMS YES IT'S
YOUR TURN WHAT'S YOUR NAME
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
MY NAME IS LISA SAN FRANCISCO
WALDRON STRONGLY OPPOSED ON SB.
FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU HAVE. ONE EIGHT SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
NANCY CARLSON I'M A MEMBER OF
THE WITNESS TO LIFE KERN COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE
BILL FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE NINE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK. I CAN
I'M A FOUNDER OF A TRADITION OF
A BIBLICAL VALUES FOR NEXT
GENERATION REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF ASIAN AMERICANS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
ONE NINE. THANK YOU. ONE NINE
ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS TONY ROSE ALLAH COULD
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CORPORAL KAMAL ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR MEXICO FROM THE MOTHER OF
TWO SONS I'M A COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE AND I DO NEITHER I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE NINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS JONATHAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION OKAY
THANK YOU. ONE NINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JEANNIE I'M FROM SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
FIVE NINE FIVE ONE NINE. THANK
YOU. ONE NINE THREE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY DRIVER LONG
TERM CENTRAL I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIVE ONE NINE. BECAUSE NINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO. AND LET
THEM PLANNING BECAUSE AND I
COULD DIE. I'M A GREAT STUDENT
YOU MENTAL HEALTH HELP COOLEY
TRUMP OR A. FIVE ONE NINE.
EXCEPT IT THERE ARE- THEN.
YOU'LL GET NEED TO END THE CALL
TRIAL OPERATOR MEXICO. LINE
NINE SIXTY PLEASE GO. HI MY
NAME IS A ONE PM I AM PRISON A
BILL FOR TWELVE HUNDRED NATION
NUMBER MEMBERS AND I STRONG
BELIEVE OPPOSE AT EACH SITE
NINETY THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MISTER LOW FROM COUNTY
COMPARING- OKAY. LIKE ARE NOT-
OF MANY PEOPLE YOU LIKE ALWAYS
GET YOU THE- OMAHA THIS ORDER
ONE WE. I SUPPORT. ONE NINE SIX
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S JEFFREY NUMBER OF
DECORATIVE IN I'M ON AN OLDER
THERE FOR AND THAT WHATEVER
HUNDRED PEOPLE I'M CALLING TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE NINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINE SIX EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL. ONE NINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YET I'M
AND HOW LIFELONG APPLE SB. FIVE
ONE NOT THANK YOU. YOU. MR HERE
WE HAVE NO FOR THE COLORS IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN WILL.
WE'LL BRING YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER SAID
SAID THERE ARE TWO WILL BE
FIRST. AND MISS WITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS IS IF THE SALE OF THE
SUBSTANCES IS ILLEGAL HOW ARE
THESE PEOPLE GOING TO COME INTO
POSSESSION OF THEM WITHOUT
PARTICIPATING IN AN ILLEGAL
TRANSACTIONS. WHAT IT PEOPLE
WILL OBTAIN- THE SUBSTANCES
FRANK OF THE SAME WAY THAT THEY
DO NOW IT IS BUYING A DRUG. IS
NOT ILLEGAL IT'S THE POSSESSION
AND USE AND THE SELLING IS A
SEPARATE CRIME- SO I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THIS IS NOT LIKE A
GLOBAL. CHANGE EVERYTHING ON
SECOND DOCSIS IS ADDRESSING ONE
PIECE THAT THE POSSESSION FOR
PERSONAL USE WILL NO LONGER BE
CRIMINALIZING CALIFORNIA- BUT
PEOPLE SOFT FIND A WAY TO GET
THE DRUG. RIGHT I HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH THIS- YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH A LOT OF THE
DEPRESSION DRUGS ARE OUT THAT
ARE OUT THERE TO HELP PEOPLE
THAT SUFFER FROM DEPRESSION
CORRECT- NOT ALL OF THEM BUT
YES IN GENERAL YEAH THERE'S A
LOT OF. HOWEVER THERE ARE
ALWAYS- ADMINISTERED UNDER THE-
WELL THEY NEED TO BE
ADMINISTERED. UNDER THE
WATCHFUL EYES OF PHYSICIANS.
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE REACT ONE
WAY TO DOES. AND SOME PEOPLE
REACTED COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
WAY. AND THAT OTHER WAY IS TO
ACTUALLY EXACERBATE THEIR
SITUATION AND THEY WIND UP
COMMITTING SUICIDE- WHEN THEY
WEREN'T NECESSARILY SUICIDAL SO
THESE TYPE OF SECOND THESE TYPE
OF CYCLE- SECOND OF PSYCHEDELIC
DRUGS- ANYWAY THE ONES THAT
WOULD THAT OPERATE ON YOUR
PSYCHE- HAVE DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT EFFECTS ON DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THOSE EFFECTS ARE SO. YOU KNOW
I HAVE EVERY SYMPATHY IN THE
WORLD. FOUR YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
OUR VETERANS WHO HAVE PTSD. AND
I AM ALL FOR ANYTHING THAT CAN
HELP THEM- TO- HELP THEM TO
DEAL WITH THAT. I'M OKAY WITH
HOWEVER IT HAS T BE DONE IN A
CLINICAL SETTING HAS TO BE DONE
NOTHING UNDER THE WATCHFUL EYE
FOR. A PHYSICIAN. BECAUSE
ABSENT THAT- WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS OPENING THE DOOR TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE SAME
ISSUES WITH DEPRESSION DRUGS.
WHERE THEY CAN BE AFFECTED IN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT WAYS AND I
HAVE HEARD FROM VETERANS. WHO
ARE ARE SAYING THAT HEY YOU
KNOW WHAT THESE DRUGS RUINED MY
FRIEND'S LIFE AND HE KILLED
HIMSELF. SO A. L. HOW DO YOU
CONTROL THAT IF YOU'RE JUST
GOING TO OPEN IT UP AND SAY HEY
IF YOU JUST HAVE IT GOOD NO BIG
DEAL. WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SOME EMERGED REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT AND FRANKLY THE
REASON WERE IN THAT SITUATION
IS BECAUSE OF THE WAR ON DRUGS.
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF TAKING A
RATIONAL HEALTH BASED APPROACH
TO DRUGS INCLUDING PSYCHEDELICS
AS WE KNEW. IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES THIS IS NOT NEW
INFORMATION THERE'S A LOT MORE
SIZE SEVEN THERE WAS. BUT WE
KNEW IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES. I
TO GOOGLE LST HEALTH BENEFITS
YOU'RE GOING TO GET BY MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND HATS.
WE KNEW IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
THAT THESE DRUGS COULD BE
HUGELY BENEFICIAL TO PEOPLE'S
HEALTH AND WELLBEING. AND IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAME IN.
AND SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN AND
RESCHEDULED ALL THE DRUGS AND
SAID YOU'RE A CRIMINAL IF YOU
POSSESS THEM. AND SO WE HAVE
LOST FIFTY YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
THEN FOLLOWED SUIT LIKE WE
WERE. WE WERE MASS
INCARCERATION HAPPY IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES AND
CRIMINALIZED EVERYTHING. AND SO
DIE IT'S BECAUSE OF THE WAR ON
DRUGS THAT WERE IN THIS
SITUATION THAT PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
THE PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY NEED
TO USE IT AND THE SHADOWS.
WHICH MAKES IT MORE LIKELY THAT
PEOPLE MIGHT USE IT IN THE
WRONG DOSAGE WERE IN THE WRONG
WAY I WANT TO BE CLEAR. I WOULD
LOVE IT IF THE FDA ACTUALLY GOT
AROUND TO RESCHEDULING-
DISSIPATE. CALAMY HAS BEEN
RESCHEDULED ONE OF THE REASON
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE WERE
OPEN BUT I DON'T WANT TO. BUT I
HEARD PEOPLE WERE SAYING ONE OF
THE REASONS WE TOOK IT OUT. IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE SEVERE
DEPRESSION AND KELEMETE IS
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BREAKTHROUGHS IN DEPRESSION
TREATMENT IN A HUNDRED YEARS.
YOU CAN GO TO A DOCTOR AND
GETTING A FUSION ACADEMY YOU
CAN'T DO THAT RIGHT NOW WITH
ANY OF THESE OTHER DRUGS. IT
WOULD A DOCTOR WILL LOSE HIS
LICENSE. IF YOU'RE SHE TRIES TO
GET THIS YEAR. AND SO I WANT
THE FDA TO DO IT. I DON'T KNOW
IF THE FTA WILL EVER GET AROUND
TO IT OR IF IT'S GOING TO BE IN
THREE OR FIVE OR SEVEN OR TEN
YEARS. BUT WHAT I DO KNOW IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE HURTING AND
DYING NOW- I THINK WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF VETERANS
WHO ARE COMMITTING SUICIDE
BECAUSE OF UNTREATED. MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. I MORE TO. A I'M
GOING TO BE MY LIFE. THE THAT.
ANYONE WHO'S COMMITTING
SUICIDE. BECAUSE THEY TOOK A
PSYCHEDELIC THAT IS NOT AN
EPIDEMIC. THE EPIDEMIC IS
UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION. LIKE THE SEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO DIED LAST
YEAR IN MY COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO. OF OVERDOSES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ADDICTED TO
HEROIN OR FENTANYL. OUR BATH
AND IT'S ILLEGAL FOR THEM TO
ACCESS. THIS TREATMENT SO I
HOPE THE FTA GETS AROUND TO IT.
BUT YOU KNOW. IN MY COMMUNITY
WERE ALSO LOSING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. FROM AIDS. AND IT WAS
A LEGAL TO USE CANNABIS EVEN
THOUGH CANNABIS COULD KEEP
PEOPLE HEALTHIER. AND ALLEVIATE
THEIR SYMPTOMS. AND EVEN TODAY
THE NUMBER OF SENIOR CITIZENS
WHO ARE USING CANNABIS. FOR
THEIR ARTHRITIS. CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS SENIORS. WHO ARE
USING CANNABIS FOR THEIR
ARTHRITIS. AND THE FDA HAS
NEVER RESCHEDULED OF DOCTORS
CAN LOSE THEIR LICENSE. IF THEY
PRESCRIBE. SO I WANT THEM TO DO
THAT BUT I KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
HURTING NOW- AND I WANT TO HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND THAT AND- A. D.
TELL ME. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THAT OFF THE LIST
CAN MEANS DATE RAPE. THAT'S WHY
THAT IS I JUST DON'T WITH A
CONSTITUENT. WHO IS IN THE SAD
CIRCUMSTANCE OF HAVING THAT
HAPPEN TO THEM. AND THEY
COULDN'T GET THE HOSPITAL TO
GIVEN THE TEST IT'LL LET THEM
KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED-
SO TERRY. THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THAT OFF THE LIST BECAUSE I WAS
REALLY THAT WAS A REAL RALLY
KILLER WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT
THIS. AS IF THERE WEREN'T
ENOUGH OF THE OTHER ONES- WHEN
I TALKED THE HIGHWAY PATROL.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER IS OF
HIGHWAY. INCIDENTS ARE ON THE
HIGHWAYS RIGHT NOW. 70% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN AN
INCIDENT ON THE HIGHWAY ARE
UNDER SOME KIND OF INFLUENCE OF
SOME KIND OF DRUG. AND SO I
DON'T SEE HOW THIS HELPS THAT
OUT ANY. AND ALSO UNDER DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THESE. OUT OF THE HANDS OF
OUR UNDER TWENTY ONE
POPULATION. BECAUSE THIS WILL
BE JUST LIKE BEER YOU JUST GO
GET THE TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD TO
GIVE YOU THE STUFF. AND EVEN
THOUGH IT'S ILLEGAL THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO GET IT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE ACCESS TO IT
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A
MARKET FOR IT. SO THAT THE
ILLEGAL DRUG TRADE WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPLY THEM. ALL THESE
PEOPLE THAT WANT THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ALL WITH PTSD
SOMEONE JUST WANT FOR
RECREATIONAL USE THERE WAS A
LOT OF THAT IN THE SIXTIES. AND
SO I I'M NOT SURE HOW WE'RE
GOING TO CONTROL ALL OF THAT.
AND ON TOP OF THAT. KEEP OUR
YOUNG KIDS FROM TAKING OUT ONE
PILL OF ECSTASY. IT JUST
HAPPENS TO BE LACED WITH
FENTANYL. BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THOSE DRUG DEALERS ARE DOING
THESE DAYS. IS A RELAXING
EVERYTHING WITH IT AND ALL
BECAUSE THEY WANT THEIR DRUG.
TO HAVE AN EXTRA KICK SO THE
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO BUY. SO I
THINK THIS IS. ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE YOU'RE PUTTING THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE. I THINK
IF THE FDA FINDS THAT THIS IS A
DRUG. THAT IS ARE THESE DRUGS
ARE BENEFICIAL FOR A CERTAIN
POPULATION. THEN I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE REGULATED. ON
REGULATING IT IS NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. J. THAT YOU
BROUGHT THE BILL- THOSE ARE MY
CONCERNS I. APPRECIATE SOME
EVENT I SAY ALL OF THE BAD
THINGS HE'S A SAID I AGREE.
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE IS
BAD. GIVING DRUGS TO KIDS IS
BAD. THAT IT IS ALL HAPPENING
NOW. AND THAT IS IN THIS BILL
DOESN'T CHANGE THAT. BUT THAT
IS ALL HAPPENING NOW AND THE
QUESTION IS. IF WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT ARRESTING
PEOPLE IS GOING TO PREVENT THAT
CLEARLY IT DOESN'T. COST FIFTY
YEARS LATER IT'S ALL STILL
HAPPENING. AND I DO JUST WANT
TO SAY YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO
LOST MY AUNT TO A DRUNK DRIVER-
I YOU KNOW I IF WE GOT THE DATA
FROM CHP IN TERMS OF WHAT.
THEY'RE UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF-
I'VE LEARNED ABOUT MY LUNCH
AGAIN THAT IS OVERWHELMINGLY.
ALCOHOL AL CAPONE OR WANNA
ALCOHOL AND ALCOHOL WHICH BY
THE WAY. AND WANT TO TALK ABOUT
A DATE RAPE DRUG. IT'S NOT
PSYCHEDELICS IS NOT CAN I MEAN.
ALCOHOL MONTHS. SCARED OF ME.
ALL RIGHT. WHICH WHICH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST TO
THANK AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. I THINK IT'S A
VERY CRITICAL CONVERSATION WE
NEED TO DECRIMINALIZE-
POSSESSION OF THESE SUBSTANCES
FOR PERSONAL USE- I DO BELIEVE
THAT THEY- CAN OFFER
THERAPEUTIC VALUE FOR PEOPLE- I
AGREE WITH YOUR COMMENTS A
HUNDRED PERCENT- YOU KNOW- WE
FREELY DRINK ALCOHOL AND ONE
COULD SAY THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
A MUCH MORE SUBSTANCE. THAN THE
SUBSTANCES WERE TALKING ABOUT
HERE- IN THIS BILL AND THE
OTHER PIECE OF THE EQUATION
HERE IS THAT WHO'S ACTUALLY
GETTING ARRESTED FOR POSSESSION
IT'S KIDS OF COLOR AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR MORE SO THAN. WHITE
FAMILIES AND WHITE KIDS AND
FOLKS WHO ARE USING THIS WE
HAVE TO HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT ABOUT THIS
WAR ON DRUGS. AND WHAT IT
ACTUALLY MEANS AND ITS IMPACT
ON PEOPLE'S LIVES- SO I WILL
MOVE THE BILL HASN'T MOVED
ALREADY I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER LUCKY. YES SIR I'M NOT
GOING TO BE LABOR THE POINTS.
OF OBJECTION THAT I HAVE TO
THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE I KNOW
THAT YOUR- YOUR INTENTIONS. ARE
SURPRISINGLY NORMAL- BUT I
REALLY REALLY. TAKEN OBJECTION.
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THE HURTFUL
IMPACTS OF. WHAT THESE
PARTICULAR DRUGS- AND THEY ARE
VERY VERY HURTFUL NUMBER
THREATENING IN MANY WAYS TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THEMSELVES AND
MAYBE EVEN OTHERS AND I THINK
BY- LEGALIZING THE SUBSTANCE
THOSE TRAGEDIES ARE GOING TO
INCREASE OLD THAT'S REALLY
WHERE I'M COMING FROM AND I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT SO I'M NOT
GOING TO BE INSULTING OR- OR BE
NASTY OTHERS. WILL TELL YOU
THAT I THINK IT IT'S MISGUIDED
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THE OTHER
SIDE OF THESE DRUGS AND IT'S
VERY VERY. HEARTBREAKING THAT'S
ALL I GOT. THANK YOU MR CLARK-
SO I'M ALREADY A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU- LOOK AS HE AS SO
ELOQUENTLY STATED BY THE AUTHOR
WARRANT DRUGS HASN'T WORKED. BY
MAKING THESE THINGS TOTALLY
LEGAL IT'S MUCH EASIER THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SELLING THEM TO
SELL THEM TO MINORS- WE OUGHT
TO BE LEGALIZING POSSESSION
PERIOD- HOW DOES IT HELP PEOPLE
TO BE ARRESTED PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT'S PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE WHO ARE-
DISADVANTAGED BY THIS YOU KNOW
WHEN I WENT TO SCHOOL AT
COLUMBIA- ALL THE KIDS TO TRIED
LSD AND- CANNABIS AT CETERA. NO
ONE WAS EVER ARRESTED FOR
ANYTHING AND- YOU KNOW A HALF
MILE AWAY IN HARLEM BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE WERE BEING
ARRESTED ALL THE TIME WE HAVE
TO STOP THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE ANYMORE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY CLOSE. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN YOU
WERE HERE EARLIER I JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS MY THANKS TO YOU AND
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US- FOR PRAYER VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS ON MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO BOTH
OF YOU I KNOW- WE ALL COME FROM
A GOOD PLACE ON THIS AND I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL ARE VERY
OPEN AND CANDID AND I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT ON THIS AND I
HONOR THAT DISAGREEMENT. ABOUT
COLLEAGUES I THINK THIS IS A
BILL THAT IS LONG OVERDUE- AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
TO FOR A TICKING COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS ESPECIALLY IN
OF JOIN. ME TO SEROTONIN
PICKING UP. KIDDING ME IT. DID
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT WOULD. JUST COME. VIEWS
WHAT YOU ULTIMATELY WANT TO GET
ACCOMPLISHED. I WITH THEIR
TEACHERS RECOMMENDED I CALL THE
ROLL. THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY
MENTIONS ON SB FIVE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI
GENSER HI LACKEY. LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAD. LEE LEE HIGH
COURT HI CORK HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I SEE YOUR TO KNOW
THEY ARE TURNOUT WICKS.
MEASURES ARE CALLED ONE MORE
THING YOU VERY MUCH COLOR MUCH
OF. THANK YOU. I WAS SKIN.
ITEMS NUMBER THIRTEEN. BILL
NUMBER SB SIXTEEN ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN S. B. EIGHTY ONE AND
ICE MY UNDERSTANDING. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO START WITH S. B. EIGHT
ONE. YES BECAUSE MY WITNESSES
THAT. TIME HAS TIME CONSTRAINTS.
I HAD THE- OR HALF A GREAT
HONOR TO SERVE ON THE COMMITTEE
ON THE REVIEW OF THE PENAL CODE
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED FIRST
CONCEPTUALLY BY GOVERNOR BROWN
BUT THEN THE APPOINTMENTS WERE
MADE BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND I
SERVE ON ACT WITH A DEAN OF A
LAW SCHOOL TO OF ONE OF OUR
JUSTICES ARE SUPERIOR COURT
JUSTICES IN ART ONE OF OUR
JUDGES- AND- THE ACADEMIC FROM
STANFORD. WHO FOCUSES ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING IS TAKE HAVING
X. VERY LONG MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDER INPUT ABOUT VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE PENAL CODE. AND
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF SESSIONS
ON THE CONCEPT OF ENHANCEMENTS.
AND AS YOU KNOW WHAT AN
ENHANCEMENT IS A SENSE IN HANTS
MEANT IS THAT IT ADDS TIME TO
THE BASE SENTENCE OF THE FACE
CRIME. AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ON THE BOOKS- MY
APPROACH WITH SB EIGHTY ONE
WHICH WAS DEVELOPED BY. THE
JUDGE AND THE JUSTICE ON OUR
PENAL CODE COMMITTEE. WAS TO
PROVIDE JUDICIAL GUIDANCE
BECAUSE BOTH OF THESE- PEOPLE
THAT SERVE ON THE BENCH.
POINTED OUT THAT WHILE THERE IS
SOME DISCRETION IT THEY ARE
VERY IT'S UNCLEAR UNDER WHAT
CONTEXT MAY DAY EXERT THAT
DISCRETION IN RELATIONSHIP TO
THE SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS AND
WE EVEN HAD DE ACE TESTIFIED
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THE TRIAL
ENDS UP BEING A DISCUSSION ON
THE ENHANCEMENTS RATHER THAN ON
THE CRIME ITSELF. SO WHAT SB
EIGHTY ONE DOES IS PROVIDES
GUIDANCE TO OUR JUDGES SO THEY
HAVE SOME CRITERIA TO USE WHEN
THEY ARE DETERMINING AT THE
SENTENCING HANDSOMEST AT THE AT.
SO IT PROVIDES THIS CLEAR
GUIDANCE AND- THE COMMITTEE AND
I FEEL THAT THIS WILL IMPROVE
FAIRNESS IN SENTENCING AND
ENSURE THAT THE PENALTY
REFLECTS THE TRUE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE CRIME- I WOULD LIKE MY
WITNESSES NOW TO- PRESENT AND
THEY ARE JUDGE PETER ESPINOZA
ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE PENAL
CODE REVIEW COMMITTEE WHO
HELPED TO DEVELOP THIS POLICY.
AND PROFESSOR MICHAEL ROMANO
FROM STANFORD WHO IS THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE. YOU MAY OPEN UP
LINES AT T. OPERATORS FOR.
PROFESSOR ROMERO OVER FOR-
PETER ESPINOZA FORMER JUDGE.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU TO BOTH OF
THEIR LINES ARE OPEN TO SPEAK
AT THEIR DISCRETION. THE ROMANO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO FOR WHAT
YOU WANT TO GO. ALL SURE I'LL
GO FIRST- MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MONO I TEACH AT STANFORD LAW
SCHOOL THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME-
I AM THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
ON THE REVISION OF THE PENAL
CODE AND I HAVE THE GREAT
PLEASURE OF SERVING LYNCH-
SENATOR SKINNER. AND JUDGE
ESPINOZA AMONG OTHERS- I JUST
WANNA MAKE A FEW QUICK POINTS
OF SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY ONE- WE
HAVE A AS A COMMITTEE LAST YEAR
HAD OVER- FIFTY HOURS A PUBLIC
HEARINGS WE HEARD FROM FIFTY
SIX EXPERT WITNESSES INCLUDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT VICTIMS
ADVOCATE CHILL RIGHTS LEADERS
THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
PUBLIC LEGAL SYSTEM. WE ALSO
RECEIVED EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN ALMOST EVERY-
SESSION THAT WE HAD THAT ONE
WAVERLY ANOTHER WISH- SHOULDN'T
SHOULD HANDS NEXT. WHICH AS THE
COMMITTEE CERTAINLY KNOWS
RESULT EXTREMELY LENGTHY
SENTENCES- OF COURSE THERE
OFTEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
APPLIED AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THEY
HAVE LITTLE OR NO IMPACT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY- TRIFECTA
SPECIFICALLY TO SB EIGHTY ONE-
DID MANAGE PENAL CODE- THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. WHICH ALLOWS
JUDGES TO DISMISS CERTAIN
ENHANCEMENTS QUOTE IN
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO
STATUTORY DEFINITION OF WHAT
THAT PHRASE MEANS AND THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
SAID IS THAT IS A QUOTE
AMORPHOUS CONCEPT. ON QUOTE AND
AS. A RESULT- IT DIDN'T UTILIZE
IN- IN IN A COULD JUST AND ARE.
WELL PERHAPS NOT ARCHER
ANYTHING. AND YOU CAN JUST ARE
THE STATE. OF CALIFORNIA. HAD
SOME LIMITS OF MULTIPLE KANSEN
BUT LEGISLATURE PROPOSAL AWAY
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN- WE
BELIEVE THAT SB EIGHTY ONE IS A
GOOD WAY TO- INFORM JUDICIAL
DISCRETION. BUT STILL PRESERVES
AND PRIORITIZES- THE ABILITY TO
JUDGE TO- IMPOSE SENTENCES TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. WE ALSO
HELP TO HELP MINIMIZE. SOME OF
THE- UNINTENDED. OF IT AND- THE
LAST THAT WE WILL SAY THAT
AMONG OUR WITNESSES WORK FORMER
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN WHO TOLD
THE COMMITTEE QUOTE WE SHOULD
GET RID OF ALL THE
ENHANCEMENTS. SANTA CLARA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN
SAID ENHANCEMENTS HAVE BECOME
THE TAIL THAT WAGS THE DOG
QUOTE- AND TRIALS AND LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY
GEORGE GASC ON WHO I TESTIFIED
THAT ENHANCEMENTS RESULT IN
EXCESSIVE SENTENCES AND HAVE NO
CONNECTION TO PUBLIC SAFETY- SO
WITH THAT I'LL HAND THE CALL
OVER TO MY COMMITTEE MEMBER-
PETER ESPINOZA AND OF COURSE
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS IF THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. THANK YOU
MICHAEL MY MR AUSTIN ALL SUMMER
WITH JUDGE OF A LOS ANGELES
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE OF THE
PERSONAL. WHEN YOU. CONSIDER S.
B. EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED AND
SENATOR SKINNER HAS REFERRED TO
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE ALREADY
OVER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
ENHANCEMENTS IN ALBANY
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE A
CANADIAN SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX OVER 80% OF PEOPLE
IN PRISON ARE SERVING THE TERM
ONCE AND B ENHANCEMENTS AND
MORE THAN 25% OF PEOPLE IN
PRISON ARE SERVING SENTENCES
EXTENDED BY THREE OR MORE
ENHANCEMENTS. WHEN THE
COMMISSION PENAL CODE- YOUR
VISION WAS PUT TOGETHER ONE OF
THE THINGS WE ARE ASKED TO DO
AS NON CONSIDER HOW THE PENAL
CODE CONTRIBUTES TO RACIAL
DISPARITIES WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM LOOKING AT THE
PENAL CODE AND ENHANCEMENTS
THROUGH A RACIAL JUSTICE. ON
RACIAL EQUITY LANDS. PORTANTINO
THAT 9% OF IN PRISON WITH A
GANG. OF PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND
89% OF PEOPLE IN PRISON- WHAT A
GUN ENHANCEMENT ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND I JUST WANT TO
REINFORCE- PROFESSOR LEMANIS-
SORT OF OVERVIEW OF WHAT THE
DISK THIS BILL DOES AND DOESN'T
DO IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE.
ANY ENHANCEMENTS FROM JUDGES TO
NOT LOSE THE ABILITY TO IMPOSE
ENHANCEMENTS- THE GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE AS TO WHEN
JUDGES SHOULD THIS MESS BY
SCAVENGING THE PRESUMPTION THAT
THEY DO STONE CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT THIS SHOULD ONLY BE DONE
ALWAYS BEGUN CONSIDERATION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY- AND THE JUDGE
HAS THE ABILITY TO IMPOSE-
ENHANCEMENT DEPOSITION PORTENTS
TO PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY.
CALIFORNIA PREVIOUSLY HAD A
LIMITATION ON STACKING MULTIPLE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WAS
ELIMINATED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NOW GOING TO THE
ROOM ARE WOULD SINCE. OF THE
MAKEUP TO THE RIGHT. AB EIGHTY
ONE I MEAN SB EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS A LITTLE. WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO GIVE ME TOO
ON BEHALF OF SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOW WILL GO TO THE- I'LL TRY.
FRAZIER ANYONE THE ONE SPEAK. I
WILL SAY NO THEY WILL GO TO THE
LINE AT T. OPERATORS FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY ONE. SKINNER. CERTAINLY
FOR DOES NOT CURRENT DOES IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW IF YOU
ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE IT
MAY BE HELPFUL IF THE HANDSET
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FIRST WE HAVE LINE NINE EIGHT
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
EMMA BAKES I AM A LONG TIME SAN
FRANCISCO AT. PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WITH NEXT WE HAVE LINED NINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MATEO ALONG SO KRISTIN
KEY I'M A MEMBER OF THE
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE FOR JUSTICE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU.
NINE NINE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARCO POLO HOOKERS AND HE
AND I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE WHERE DOES
THIS. AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
TAT SHE EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU.
SEVEN NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE NINE
NINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNON CHAIR AND MEMBERS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. ONE NINE NINE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S LEVINE RIDDICK- I'M
LONGTIME BAY AREA RESIDENT AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE FRIENDSHIP
CIRCLE FOR SUPPORT I MEAN
PROJECTED AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHTY ONE. NINE
NINE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF- ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN STRONG. NINE EIGHT
NINE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
MAY BE TRANSFERRED ON BEHALF OF
THE S. E. I. U. CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. WHITE NINE ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
GREG REPUBLICAN ISSUE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY
ONE. NINE NINE SIX ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI ONE AM I AM- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT.
EIGHTY ONE. WAIT TILL I GET ON
THAT LAST LINE NINE EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY I'M
GRAHAM WILLIAMS- RESIDENT THERE
PRINT THAT GO IN A MEMBER OF
FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE FOR JUSTICE
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE NINE EIGHT
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHT
NINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO MY NAME IS YOLANDA FONG.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU NAME OR LOCATION. MY NAME
IS YOLANDA FONG I'M A PRIVATE
CITIZEN I'M ATTORNEY AND A
MOTHER OF TWO BOYS AND I AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
THANK YOU. NINE NINE FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE NINE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
NINE NINE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOSH SHOULD BE BAY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROUD CALL CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE NINE
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ARTI STRAND I
AM A MEMBER OF FRIENDSHIP
STRUGGLE FOR JUSTICE AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF SB. ONE AND WE
HAVE NO FOR THE CALLERS IN CUBA
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU I GUESS.
WE CAN NOW BRING YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE. THANK OUR SORRY
SORRY OPPOSITION. BEEN A LONG
LONG DAY ROBERT MESSED MESSED
MEANT FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. BY
PHONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ADA ROBERT MASS MEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE- I'D LIKE
TO NOTE THAT- MOST ENHANCEMENTS
ARE WHAT ARE KNOWN AS SPECIFIC
OR CONDUCT MASON HARASSMENTS
THEY ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE CONDUCT AN INDIVIDUAL
ENGAGES IN DURING A CRIME. A
DEFENDANT SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ENGAGING AND
AGGRAVATED CONDUCT DURING THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME INCLUDING
FOR USE OF A WEAPON OR FIREARM
INJURY TO A VICTIM OR MULTIPLE
VICTIMS AND COMMITTING A HATE
CRIME. I READ ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT QUOTE
PHILIPSBURG COMMITTEE IN THE
SAME CRIME SOME INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE ONLY THE FACE SENTENCE
WHILE OTHERS HAVE FIVE TEN OR
MORE YEARS ADDED TO THEIR TIME
UNQUOTE. THAT IS AN INACCURATE
STATEMENT IT IS NOT THE SAME
CRIME A ROBBERY COMMITTED WITH
THE USE OF A WEAPON OR FIREARM
FOR WHERE THE VICTIM IS INJURED
IS DIFFERENT THAN JUST A
REGULAR ROBBERY THOUGH THE BASE
CHARGE PENAL. CODE SECTION TWO
ELEVN IS THE SAME. TD IS
OPPOSED S. EIGHTY ONE FOREVER
OF REASONS. FIRST THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY UNDER EXISTING LAW
JUDGES HAVE DISCRETION AND
FLEXIBILITY DETERMINING WHETHER
TO IMPOSE OR DISMISS AN
ENHANCEMENT THIS BILL ACTUALLY
TAKE DISCRETION AWAY FROM
JUDGES ARE IN THE BEST POSITION
TO EVALUATE THE FACTS OF THE
CASE AND THE PARTICULARS OF THE
OFFENDER. THERE ARE MULTIPLE
STATUTES RULES OF COURT AND
CASE LAW THAT GOVERN HOW COURTS
ARE CONDUCTED SENSING SENSING
HEARING WHT FACTORS TO
CONSIDER AND WHETHER TO IMPOSE
OR DISMISS AN ENHANCEMENT. I
JUDGES IN THE BEST POSITION TO
DETERMINE AN APPROPRIATE
SENTENCE AND WHAT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. INSTEAD OF
SIMPLY LISTING ADDITIONAL
CRITERIA FOR THE COURT TO
CONSIDER AND PROVIDING GUIDANCE
AS THE COMMITTEE ON THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
SUGGESTS. WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY
ADDRESS A MAJOR CONCERN OF THE
PARK BILL'S PROPONENTS
CONCERNING LACK OF CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY SB EIGHTY ONE
ACTUALLY TIES THE HANDS OF
JUDGES. THE BILL WILL
ESSENTIALLY PROHIBIT
ENHANCEMENTS IN MULTIPLE
CIRCUMSTANCES BY CREATING A
MANDATORY PRESUMPTION. WITH AN
UNREALISTICALLY HIGH BURDEN OF
PROOF CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE OF RISK TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. THAT MEANS A JUDGE
COULD DETERMINE THAT IT'S MORE
LIKELY THAN NOT THAT DISMISSAL
OF ENHANCEMENT WOULD ENDANGER
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT STILL BE
REQUIRED TO DISMISS IT LET ME
REPEAT THAT A JUDGE COULD
DETERMINE THAT IT'S MORE LIKELY
THAN NOT. THAT DISMISSAL
ENHANCEMENT WOULD ENDANGER
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT STILL BE
REQUIRED TO DISMISS IT. THAT
MAKES NO SENSE THAT'S WHAT THIS
HIGH BURDEN OF PROOF. CLEAR
CONVINCING EVIDENCE WOULD DO.
AND UNLIKE THE REST THE PENAL
CODE SECTION THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THAT ALLOWS THE JUDGE TO
STRIKE IT THE ADDITIONAL
PUNISHMENT SB EIGHTY ONE
PROVIDES NO SUCH DISCRETION FOR
THE COURT. A JUDGE MUST DISMISS
THE ENHANCEMENT IN ITS ENTIRETY
IF THE MAIN CONCERN OF THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS OF THE OF
THE BILL IS THE ADDITIONAL
PUNISHMENT ASSOCIATED WITH
ENHANCEMENTS THAT AT A MINIMUM.
THIS ASPECT OF THE BILL SHOULD
BE AMENDED TO ALLOW STRIKING
JUST THE PUNISHMENT UNDER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SUBSECTION
B. THERE ARE ALSO NO EXCLUSIONS
BILL. THE BILL WILL APPLY TO
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OFFENSES
INCLUDING MURDER RAPE CHILD
MOLESTATION DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HATE CRIMES
EXCEPT YOUR- FINALLY MANY OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES LISTED IN SB
EIGHTY ONE THAT PRESUME THAT
ENHANCE COULD BE DISMISSED HER
TROUBLING INCLUDING MULTIPLE
ENHANCEMENTS IF A DEFENDANT
ENGAGES IN VARIOUS CONTACT THAT
RESULTS IN MULTIPLE
ENHANCEMENTS. SUCH AS USE OF A
WALK. OF SEVERAL WEAPONS OR
INFLICTION OF SERIOUS INJURY
MULTIPLE VICTIMS HAD MULTIPLE
ENHANCEMENTS MAY BE WARRANTED.
ANOTHER CRITERIA THAT THE
OFFENSES CONNECTED TO PRIOR
VICTIMIZATION OF CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA UNLIKE TO. THE PROVISION
CONCERNING MENTAL ILLNESS IT IS
UNCLEAR WHAT THE TERM CONNECTED
MEANS AND THE DEFINITION OF
PRIOR VICTIMIZATION IN
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA IS SIMPLY TOO
BROAD INCLUDING EVEN CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA EXPERIENCED BY A
HOUSEHOLD MEMBER. IN OTHER
WORDS I DEFENDED WHO NEVER
EXPERIENCED CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
WOULD QUALIFY UNDER THIS
PROVISION. ALSO CONVICTION UP
PRIOR CONVICTIONS THAT ARE FIVE
OR MORE YEARS OLD THIS MEANS
THAT A SIX YEAR OLD PRIOR RAPE
CONVICT CONVICTION OF A SERIAL
RAPIST SHOULD BE DISREGARDED
WHAT IF THE INDIVIDUAL HAD BEEN
CURSORY DID OVER MOST OF THAT
PERIOD. OR THE INDIVIDUAL IS RE
OFFENDED MULTIPLE TIMES OVER
THAT PERIOD THESE FACTORS ARE
NOT CONSIDERED UNDER THE BILL.
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO TALK
ABOUT- ONE CASE THAT SHOWS AN
EXAMPLE OF SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS AND THAT'S THE
RECENT CASE OF EIGHT AND LEO'S
SIX YEAR OLD BOY WHO WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED IN A ROAD
RAGE SHOOTING ON THE FIFTY FIVE
FREEWAY. WITHOUT THE
ENHANCEMENT FOR INTENTIONAL
DISCHARGE OF A FIREARM RESULTED
IN DEATH THE DEFENDANT WOULD BE
RELEASED POLICE. TO SAN.
SHOOTING INTO AN OCCUPIED
VEHICLE HE WOULD BE RELEASED
UNDER FIVE YEARS VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER RELEASED UNDER
EIGHT YEARS AND EVEN IF HE WAS
CONVICTED OF SECOND DEGREE
MURDER HE'D BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE UNDER TEN YEARS. THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR THE
SENSELESS KILLING OF A SIX YEAR
OLD BOY. CDA WOULD BE MORE THAN
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND OTHER SPONSORS OF THE BILL
ON ON THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
BUT ADDED KERR IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED WE MUST BE OPPOSED TO
SB EIGHTY ONE AND ASK YOU TO.
OPPOSE IT WITH A NO VOTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NORTH SORRY
THERE'S NO OTHER. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SCHEDULED WILL GO TO
ROOM. ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. SB
EIGHTY ONE SKINNER GOOD
AFTERNOON PATRICK DESTINOS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SEEN NONE WILL GO TO
THE OUTSIDE. ARE THERE ANYONE
OUT IN THE- LAWN AREA SEEING
NONE. WE NOW GO TO THE PHONES
FOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
EIGHTEEN T. ONCE AGAIN JUST A
REMINDER IS. ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO APPEAR
FOR OPPOSITION LET'S GET ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FIRST WE HAVE
LINE NINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITH. NINE FOUR FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THAT ME.
YES RIGHT RIGHT. AND I'M A
REGULAR THERE FRANCISCO A
MOTHER OF TWO SONS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. EIGHT ONE
ONE THANK YOU. NINE NINE THREE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI.
SERVICES CALLS FROM YOUR PHONE.
AB. ONE NINE ONE THOUSAND
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
DRUGS STRONGLY OPPOSING TO SB
EIGHTY ONE WHICH IS DISASTROUS
THANK YOU. NINE NINE EIGHT
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN- HALF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. NINE NINE SEVEN NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER KENNEDY I'M
AN ATTORNEY IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY NINE NINE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MATTHEW GRECO- REPRESENTING THE
SAN DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME
URGING A NO VOTE ON SB EIGHTY
ONE WHICH SEVERELY UNDERCUTS
THE JUDGE'S. DISCRETION THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FIVE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. STEPHANIE AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION I'M WITH
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED. YOU. ONE
ONE THOUSAND THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMPANY AND THE THEIR SYSTOLIC
WENDY AND I PRAY FOR PRESENTING
TWELVE HUNDRED- ASIAN AMERICAN
MEMBERS AND EXCELLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY ONE.
EIGHTY ONE IT'S GOING TO TURN
CALIFORNIA INTO SOUTH AFRICA
STOP. ONE EIGHT FIVE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO.
DAVID ORGANIZATION PLEASE. OKAY
CAN YOU HEAR IT. YES GO AHEAD
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. I MEAN I
YOUNG FROM SAN FRANCISCO MOTHER
TO STRONGLY OPPOSING. S. B.
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THOUSAND FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHY THE LOOPING GONZALEZ.
CONDITIONAL DISTRICT FIFTY
SEVEN L. A. COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSITION OPPOSITE- OPPOSE
THANK YOU. STRUCTURE WE HAVE NO
FOR THE COLORS CUTE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS ABOUT
CHAIR I'LL MENTION THAT I AM
TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU BEFORE I
GO ICE AT THE CORNER OF MY EYE
I SEE RYAN SHERMAN IN A ROOM HE
LOOKS LIKE HE WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT. NAME AN ORGANIZATION
THOSE ARE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE RANCHER
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND THE POLICE
OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS OF
CLAREMONT. PALS FORTIES UPLAND
INGLEWOOD CORONA NEWPORT BEACH
SANTA ANA. ARCADIA POMONA
BURBANK RIVERSIDE CULVER CITY.
ALL IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NOW WILL
BRING BACK MR LACKEY I THINK
YOU BEGIN FIRST. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND CENTER
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT I'M I'M VERY MUCH
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL TO YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD HERE I THINK IT
GOES WAY BEYOND GUIDANCE AND
IT'S MY OPINION THAT IT'S
EXTREMELY BIASED. AND IT'S
APPROACH AND- YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS TO YOUR GOAL WAS
FAIRNESS. BUT IN MY OPINION OF
FAIRNESS SHOULD NOT BE DEFINED
BY JUST A REDUCED SENTENCE. I
HAVE HERE. A BOOK THIS BOOK IS
SOLELY CRIMINAL SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS AND YOU YOUR BILL
WILL ESSENTIALLY MAKE ITS
CONTENTS OBSOLETE. BECAUSE YOU
YOUR BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
DESTROYS JUDICIAL DISCRETION AS
IT RELATES TO- SENATE'S
ANNOUNCEMENTS. AND SO I WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT. AND
I'D I'M SORRY THAT- THAT'S MY
POSITION BUT IT IS A VERY
STRONG POSITION. THANK YOU.
MISTER LEE. I THANK CENTER FOR
BRING US FOR IT'S A GREAT
PLEASURE TO BE SERVING ON THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE ON THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE WITH
YOU AS WELL AFTER OF PLACING
NOW CENTER COLLAR ON IT BUT IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
WITH SUPPORT AT THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S MISCONSTRUED AS THE
IT'S CLARIFYING. OF THE ABILITY
TO FOURTEEN JUSTICES TO DISMISS
ENHANCEMENT IN THE FURTHERANCE
OF JUSTICE AND THAT'S THE KEY
PHRASE IN THE FURTHERANCE OF
JUSTICE IF THAT PHRASE SOUNDS
VAGUE TO YOU RIGHT NOW THAT OF
COURSE IMAGINE IT AT THE COURT
LEVEL AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS BILL AND
I SEE IT'S ALSO PERSPECTIVE SO
DOESN'T YOU RETRACTABLE THAT
PEOPLE- SOME OF THE- OPPONENTS.
KIND OF. MESSAGE ABOUT. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
AND YOU KNOW AS THE EVEN THAT.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF MINE
COUNTY HAD. TALKED ABOUT. AND
THE COUNTIES CLARA. SANTA TAXES-REALLY HAVE BECOME THE TAIL
THAT WAGS THE DOG IN MANY CASES
AS- I ALSO PRESENTED A BILL
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE PEOPLE SERVE
A LONGER SENTENCE FOR. ADULTS
FOR MANDATORY ADD ON'S AND THEY
DO FOR THE PRINCIPLE CRIMES AND
IF OUR SYSTEM IS ABOUT.
EDUCATING THE- NUANCES OF A
CRIME OR EDUCATING WHAT A
DETAILS ARE ABOUT IT SHOULD BE-
THE CRITICAL JUST ASSUME SHOULD
BE HINGED. ON JUST THAT GIANT
BOOK OF A HUNDRED SIXTY
ENHANCEMENTS SO. I THINK THIS
IS A VERY CLEAR. AND SIMPLE
BILL ABOUT IT THAT IT'S WHICH
HAS WRAPPED UP A LOT OF
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT IT. AND IF
THERE IS A TIME TO BE AT HONEST
CO AUTHOR OF LOVE TO JOIN YOU
AS WELL CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU. MR CLARK- YES I SUPPOSE
THIS BILL AS WELL HASN'T BEEN
MOVED YET. NOW I'LL MOVE THE
BELL- AND I'M VERY GLAD THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE IS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND THAT HE HAS TAKEN
TO THIS COMMITTEE LIKE A DUCK
TO WATER AND IT'S VERY VERY
GLAD TO HAVE HIM ON HERE- LOOK
THE POINT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS TO MAKE LIFE
SAFER FOR ALL OF US. I DON'T
THINK PUTTING AWAY A PERSON FOR
TWENTY YEARS INSTEAD OF TEN
MAKES MY LIFE SAFER. FRANKLY
THE SOONER SOMEONE CAN GET A
GET OUT THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE TO BE RETURNED TO- NORMAL
LIFE IS SUPPOSED TO A LIFE OF
CRIME SO I JUST DON'T SEE THE
POINT OF THESE LONG
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THIS RESEARCH
SAYS THAT THEY DO NOT DETER
PEOPLE FROM. COMMITTING CRIMES
SO I'M VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SEA OTTER THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK THE POINT
OF. OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS ACTUALLY TO PROVIDE JUSTICE
TO VICTIMS A LOT OF TIMES- IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT- THAT JUST
SENTENCE- WE JUST HAD A RECENT
COURT CARTER RECENT CASE THAT
WAS WAS SETTLED- WELL
PUBLICIZED. IT HAS BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF MUCH ANGST OVER THE
LAST YEAR. AND THAT IS THE
TRIAL OF- DEAR CHILDREN. AND
DEREK SHERMAN WOULD HAVE HAD A
TWELVE YEAR SENTENCE HAD IT NOT
BEEN FOR ENHANCEMENTS. I DON'T
THINK A TWELVE YEAR SENTENCE
WOULD HAVE- APPROPRIATELY
ADDRESSED THE OUTRAGE AND
CONCERNS OVER HIS CONDUCT- OR
THE OUTCOME OF THAT CONTACT.
AND IF YOU THAT WERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHAT HE WOULD
GET. AND ACCORDING TO THIS. AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF JUSTICE- I
THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT
AND HE SENATE'S ENHANCEMENTS.
ARE KIND OF IN LIEU OF- TRYING
THEM ON EACH EACH DIFFERENT
COUNT OF WHICH WERE BLACK HAIR
BAND. USED TO DOING. AND THAT'S
THE JUDICATA BY THE JUDGE AT
THE END AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN THAT TRIAL.
HISENSE'S TWELVE YEARS. AND
ENDED THE JUDGES ABLE TO ADD ON
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS FOR
OPERATING OF THE COLOR OF
AUTHORITY OR MISUSING HIS
AUTHORITY. AND AND THEN BUT I
FORGOT WHAT THE OTHER ONE WAS.
THE ADDED TEN YEARS AND TWENTY
TWO AND A HALF YEARS SEEMS MORE
LIKE A JUST SENTENCE. TEN
TWELVE. IF YOU'RE OUT IN EIGHT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DO GOOD TIME.
GOING OUT NAY. I WOULD OFFERED
AND I DOUBT VERY MUCH THAT MR
CHAU VAN WOULD DO ANYTHING TO
ANYBODY IF WE RELATE. IS NOT IN
JAIL FOR THAT IS NOT IN JAIL
BECAUSE WERE AFRAID HE'S GOING
TO DO SOMETHING TO SOMEBODY
ELSE IS IN JAIL BECAUSE WHAT HE
DID. AND THAT'S WHAT I SEE AS
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
WORKING CORRECTLY. AND WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT CONTINUES
TO WORK CORRECTLY IN THE FUTURE
I DON'T THINK THIS HELPS. SO
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY ON THIS
BILL I CANNOT SUPPORT YOU KNOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I NEED A
FEW MORE COMMON FOR. YOU MAY
CLOSE I'M THANK YOU CHAIR- WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE MANY BILLS
REGARDING ENHANCEMENTS THAT
COME BEFORE US AND- THE END
THERE ARE MERITS TO ALL OF THEM
THE APPROACH AS THE WITNESSES
WHO TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT.
EXPLAINED THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
TAKE IN THIS ONE IS RATHER THAN
ELIMINATING THE ENHANCEMENTS.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY ONE COULD
MAKE A GOOD ARGUMENT HE PER
CLIENT FOR ANYONE OF THE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY. IT WAS TO BE
ABLE TO. PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
THE JUDGE NOW OBVIOUSLY THE
DA'S ASSOCIATION BILLS IT TIES
THEIR HANDS HOWEVER WE DID HEAR
FROM JUDGE ESPINOZA WHO ALONG
WITH JUSTICE CARLOS MORENO
JUSTICE CARLOS MORENO WAS
FORMER CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE. BOTH TO SERVE ON THE
COMMITTEE AND BOTH TO HELP TO
DRAFT THIS THEY FELT THAT THIS
WAS THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO GO
FOR JUDGES. AND WHEN WE LOOKED
AT ENHANCEMENTS THIS WAS THE
KEY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MADE VERSUS MANY
OTHERS THAT WE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CONTEMPLATE. AND THEY
BELIEVE THAT IT DID STILL
PROVIDE DISCRETION TO THE
JUDGE- BECAUSE IN THE IF I WANT
TO USE THE DIRECTOR OF AN
EXAMPLE AND IT'S HARD BECAUSE
I'M NOT THE JUDGE IN THAT CASE
NOR WAS I THE JURY SO I CAN'T I
CAN ONLY PURPORT. TO SAY WHAT I
THINK EITHER HIS CHARACTER IS
OR HIS MOTIVATION HOWEVER. THAT
JUDGE. MAY DETERMINATION RIGHT
SO IN IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES WITH
THIS BILL IF THE JUDGE IN SUCH
A CIRCUMSTANCE FELT THAT IT WAS
THE FURTHERANCE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY TO ADD ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE SENTENCE OF SOMEONE LIKE MR
CHILDREN HE WOULD BE ABLE TO-
SO THAT'S REALLY THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL AND- WHAT I WOULD NOTE
IS THAT. THE DA ASSOCIATION IS
OPPOSED TO EVERY ENHANCEMENT
BILL THAT IS ON THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED THIS YEAR AND HAS BEEN
IN THE PAST- I WOULD WELCOME
SOME CONSTRUCTIVE SUGGESTIONS
HOWEVER AND I'M NOT LOOKING.
THEY HAVE A CERTAIN ROLE- SO
WHAT THEY ARE YOU KNOW. WHETHER
THEY WOULD CONSTRUCT SOMETHING
VERY DIFFERENTLY OR EVEN
ENTERTAINED SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THIS I CAN'T REALLY SAY HOWEVER
IT IS BEEN MY EXPERIENCE HAVING
BEEN CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
FOUR YEARS IN THE SENATE. AND
SERVED ON IT FOR MANY MANY MORE
YEARS IT IS NOT EVER BEEN
THERE'S NOT BEEN A SINGLE. BILL
REGARDING ANY ASPECT OF
ENHANCEMENTS MEANING TO EITHER-
AB PUT GUARDRAILS ON THEM
ELIMINATE THEM OR OTHERWISE
THAT I'VE SEEN THE DA
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT- AGAIN THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY- INDICATE
THE MERIT OR NON MERIT OF THEIR
ARGUMENT ANYONE CASE I JUST
MEAN THAT IT IS. IT WOULD BE
MORE HELPFUL FOR MANY OF US IF
WE HAD KEPT THE CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTIONS- BUT I THINK THE
BILL IS SOUND AND AS I
INDICATED I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES MMS. AND I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. IT THANK YOU
AND- THE DISHES THIS IS
INTERESTING I USED TO BE ABLE
TO SAY. THAT I'M PROBABLY THE
LONGEST SERVING MEMBER IN THE
LEGISLATURE DAN DID I SEE YOU.
AND I HAVE TO STAND CORRECTED
SOMEONE WHO SERVED WITH YOU IN
THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS COMMITTEE
YES- WE REMEMBER BACK WHEN I
KNOW WHEN I CAME IN TWENTY
TWELVE. WE'RE VERY SUSPICIOUS
OF JUDGES BECAUSE THEY HAD BEEN
TO THREE STRIKES MANDATORY
MINIMUMS AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
GAVE UP THEY GAVE IT OUT LIKE
CANDY AND POPCORN JUST JUST
GIVING IT AND WE DID TRUST.
JUDGES HAVE DISCRETION. I THINK
WE WERE VERY HARD. TO KIND OF
CHANGE THE ATTITUDE IN THE MAKE
UP OF JUDICIAL SYSTEM. TO PROVE
THAT LOOK WHERE WE ARE NOW
YOU'RE- YOU'RE TRYING TO GIVE
JUDGES MORE DISCRETION. SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT TO DO. AND
AS I READ HERE THE BILL. HAS
WHAT IT SAYS THIS BILL WOULD
EXCEPT AS SPECIFIED. REQUIRE
COURT DISMISSED AN ENHANCEMENT
IF. IT IS IN THE FURTHERANCE OF
JUSTICE TO DO SO. THE BILL
WOULD CREATE A PRESUMPTION THAT
IS IT IS IT IS IN THE
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE TO
DISMISS AN ENHANCEMENT IS
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES. THE
BILL WITH STATE. THAT THIS
PRESUMPTION IS ONLY OVERCOME
UPON A SHOWING BY CLEAR. AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT
DISMISSAL OF THE ENHANCEMENT
WOULD ENDANGER PUBLIC SAFETY SO
IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC IS NOT IT
YOU HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO HAVE
BECAUSE IN REASON AND FOR THAT
REASON I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL-
I THINK IT DEMONSTRATES WHERE
WE ARE TODAY. AND THE FACT THAT
OTHERS DO NOT WANT TO GIVE
JUDGES WERE AFRAID TO GIVE
JUDGES DISCRETION- SHOWS YOU
HOW SUCCESSFUL WE'VE BEEN. OVER
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME TO TRY TO
CHANGE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AT THE JUDICIAL LEVEL
AND WE JUST STILL HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO WITH THE REST OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO THE
JUDGE RECOMMENDED I BOOKED. THE
BILL'S BEEN PROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED ON SB EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MISSION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. HI GENSER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOW BARRICADE HAN. LI LI
I WORK OUR- WORK I SANTIAGO. C.
A. R. TO KNOW THEY ARE TO A NO
WICKS FIVE WEEKS I. IT MEASURES
ARE CALLED NEEDS ONE MORE HERE
MAY NOW TAKE UP SB SIXTEEN
PEACE OFFICERS RELEASE OF
RECORDS ABOUT THE BILL SECOND.
THANK YOU AND I WILL NOT
PROLONG THE DISCUSSION SINCE
THIS IS PRETTY MUCH THE
IDENTICAL BILL THAT WENT OFF
YOUR FLOOR WITH FIFTY FOUR
VOTES- LAST SESSION BUT ON ITS
WAY TO THE SENATE BECAUSE OF
THE TIME DEADLINE. IT WAS WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO TAKE IT OFF SO
I'VE RE INTRODUCED IT AND- I
THINK I WOULD JUST LET MY
WITNESSES AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF NATASHA MINSKER FROM SMART
JUSTICE NCP'S JOHNSON. EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR WHENEVER. EITHER OF
THE WITNESSES ARE READY AND
SUPPORT TO BEGIN. CERTAINLY
THERE LINE FOR US. THIS IS AN
ATTACHMENT THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SB
SIXTEEN OF A MODEST PROPOSAL
BUT ADDRESSES THE PROBLEMS
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC
HAVE ENCOUNTERED IN ACCESSING
POLICE MISCONDUCT RECORDS UNDER
SENATOR SKINNER'S LANDMARK BILL
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE. FOR
FORTY YEARS RECORDS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT BY POLICE WERE KEPT
SECRET AND HIDDEN FROM THE
PUBLIC. CENTER SKINNER'S BILL
RESTORED THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
KNOW ABOUT SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
BY POLICE. IMMEDIATELY FAMILY
MEMBERS REPORTERS AND THE
PUBLIC REQUESTED RECORDS AND
IMMEDIATELY THEY ENCOUNTERED
SERIOUS ROADBLOCKS. DEPARTMENT
DESTROYED RECORDS WHICH THEY
ARE LEGALLY PERMITTED TO DO
UNDER CURRENT LAW. DEPARTMENTS
USE ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
TO PREVENT THE FACTUAL
DISCLOSURE THAT DISCLOSURE OF
FACTUAL STATEMENTS BY WITNESSES.
FAMILIES WERE CHARGED THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS FOR QUOTE COPYING
FEES FOR RECORDS THAT ARE KEPT
IN DIGITAL FORM THAT CAN BE
EASILY DUPLICATED. OFFICERS
RESIGNED TO BLOCK DISCLOSURE.
RIGHT AWAY FOR WEEKS MONTHS
EVEN MORE THAN A YEAR BEFORE
DISPOSING RECORDS. SB SIXTEEN
ASSEMBLY REMOVES THESE
ROADBLOCKS AND MAKE MEANINGFUL
THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO KNOW
ABOUT SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BY
POLICE AS THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED. SB SIXTEEN ALSO
PROVIDES A MODEST EXPANSION OF
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT RECORDS SPECIFICALLY
AT THE SIXTEEN ALLOWS PUBLIC
ACCESS TO SUSTAIN TO COMPLAINTS
OF BIAS AND PREJUDICE BY AN
OFFICER. FIFTEEN COMPLAINTS OF
ILLEGAL SEARCHES OR ARRESTS.
AND COMPLAINTS OF EXCESSIVE USE
OF FORCE WHICH ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE.
SB SIXTEEN IS A MODEST PROPOSAL
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO INFORMATION. AND IS
ABLE TO ASSESS WHETHER POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ARE TAKING
MISCONDUCT SERIOUSLY. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD TO
BUILD TRUST BETWEEN COMMUNITIES
AND POLICE ON BEHALF OF BOTH
MARKUPS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AYE URGING AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT. C.
A. L. I AM THE- I AM FREE TO
TALK ABOUT THE X. JOHNSON CO
FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
UNITED PROJECTED A NETWORK OF
IMPACTED FAMILIES OF POLICE
FIND AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM ALSO IMPACTED
BY MEMBER MYSELF I'M THE
OCTOBER AFTER GRANTWHO WAS A
YOUNG FATHER OF A BEAUTIFUL
FOUR YEAR OLD DAUGHTER NAME
TATIANA GRANT WHEN HE WAS
MURDERED. AFTER GRANT WAS
MURDERED BY BART POLICE OFFICER
JOHN AS WELL AS THE AT
DIFFERENT BART STATION ON
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINE.
POLICE OFFICER MEDLEY WHY THIS
BILL IS TWELVE YEARS LATER THE
ONLY CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICER
IN THE HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO EVER BE
CONVICTED. FOR NON BILL THE
SHOOTING OF A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT. JEFF OSCAR GRANT'S
MURDER. AND CONVICTION OF
JOHANNESBURG'S THE FOR THAT
MATTER. THERE HAVE BEEN OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS
KILLED BY THE POLICE IN THE
STATE. NOT A SINGLE POLICE
OFFICER HAS BEEN CONVICTED
PUBLIC KEVIN. NO OTHER STATE IN
THE UNITED STATES HAVE COME
CLOSE TO THE NEARLY KILLING US
SENATE CHEN THANK CALIFORNIANS.
AVERAGING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PER YEAR FOR THE PAST TWELVE
YEARS. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIVE
OF THE TOP FIFTEEN CITIES WITH
THE HIGHEST KILLINGS IN THE
COUNTRY RESIDED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE DEADLIEST
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY IS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA KERN
COUNTY. CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE LEGISLATION AB
SEVENTY ONE YOU SUPPORT DATA
COLLECTION PASSED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN GIVE THE STATISTICS OF
THIS MURDER STATE. THAT CANNOT
BE DISPUTED. CALIFORNIA IS THE
MOST EGREGIOUS POLICING STATE
IN THIS COUNTRY. WE HAVE
CITIZENS AND YOU A CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATOR SHOULD BE APPALLED
AT THESE NUMBERS. AB SEVENTY
ONE WAS PASSED BECAUSE
LEGISLATORS WANTED TO KNOW
WHETHER IT WAS AS BAD AS WHAT
WE HAVE CITIZENS HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR YEARS. THAT'S JUST
DISTRICTS WOULD THE TRUTH.
HANDING CALIFORNIA'S MOST DIET
THE HAVE THE POLICE. WHO OUT OF
ALL GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL HAS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITY
THE RIGHT TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
THIS RESPONSIBILITY MUST BE
GUIDED BY COMMONSENSE
LEGISLATION THAT PROTECT HUMAN
RIGHTS. AND SAVING MY LIFE.
OFFICER MEDLEY HAD TEN YEARS OF
A COMPLAINT FILED AGAINST HIM
IN HIS TWO YEARS AT THE
BARCLAYS DEPARTMENT BEFORE HE
MURDERED OPTED GRANT. THE LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY ALLOWED HIM TO
GO UNCHECKED UNTIL HE MURDERED
LINEUP. SB SIXTEEN WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED THE MURDER OF THE
GRANT. IN THIS TIME OF
RECKONING WHICH IS A CRITICAL
TACKLE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS
TELLING THE POLICE REPORT YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO. THE
BILL TRUST BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S POLICING
AGENCY. YOU CAN'T CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES OF PARENTS OF THE
TRANSPARENCY LAW THE FOURTEENTH
TWENTY ONE WHAT THE PACKING UP
SB SIXTEEN. TRANSPARENCY AND
ATHLETE WITH PROVEN TO BRING
LONG TERM SUCCESS.
TRANSPARENTLY CREATES TRUST
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AND POLICE
OFFICERS. IT WILL HELP IMPROVE
MORALE AND LOWERED JOBS RELATED
STRESS WHILE INCREASING.
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
BOASTING TRACK TRANSPARENCY IN
A MARRIAGE IS KEY TO THAT
MARRIAGE MARRIAGE THAT.
TRANSPARENTLY IN POLICING IS
KEY TO IT BEING TRAPPED YEAH
YOU CAN BUILD THAT TRUST THANK
CALIFORNIA LINE BY VOTING YES
ON IT SIXTEEN. I FELL OFF THE
GRANT MANY OF THE FAMILIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING. AND WE
ASK THAT IS. TO CLOSE THOSE
LOOPHOLES SO THAT FAMILIES CAN
ACTUALLY BEGIN. SELLING
ENCLOSURE. THERE ARE FAMILY
MEMBERS DAM MARKER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL GO ON TO
OPPOSITION- I'M SORRY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
THE- IN THE ROOM. AFTERNOON
SHARE NUMBERS A LITTLE WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT SHINO
OTHER MEMBERS IN A ROW WOULD GO
TO THE LAWN AREA DOES ANY OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. C. NONE
WOULD NOW GO TO A T. T.
OPERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IN WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
IMMEDIATELY. FIRST WE HAVE TO
LINE UP NINE EIGHT FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS GABRIEL
GARCIA POLICY NINETEEN MANAGER
FOR YOU TO LIVE IN THE JANITORS
DISTRICT IMPROPER SUPPORT
THAT'S P. SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
ONE EIGHT NINE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE LADY PANTHERS ON
BEHALF OF S. E. I. U.
CALIFORNIA AND FROM THE PORT.
NINE NINE ONE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS ERIC HARRIS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI LINE ONE THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY XABI
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BE SURE ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
AUTHORIZED TO STATE THAT THE
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
ONE ZERO ONE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
THANKS FOR BEGINNING THE LAST
NAMES ARE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORTED AT
THE SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE ZERO ONE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DR TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THOUSAND ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS NOT A HIGHER FROM
THE CCL A CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY GROUP AND WE
ARE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE THOUSAND
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'LL HAVE THAT WITH
THE WIDENING GROUP WORKING FINE
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE NINE EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR NUMBERS
JONATHAN FELDMAN THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU. THANK.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS LESLIE VASQUEZ
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MR HERE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE'S CUTE IN SUPPORT.
OUR GO TO OPPOSITION OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IS WILSHIRE MUCH
LATER CALIFORNIA LAW%
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
RECORDS SUPERVISOR AND COREY
CELLS ARE LOW CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I AM BOTH
BY PHONE. FOR LET'S START FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
RECORDS TO PROVIDERS- AND I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL. SIXTEEN THAT'S
REPRESENTATIVE OF FOR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE- WE
HANDLE A HIGH VOLUME OF PUBLIC
RECORD. ACT REQUEST UNDERGOING
FINANCIAL STRESS SB SIXTEEN
WILL CREATE A SUBSTANTIAL
BURDEN ON RECORDS MANAGEMENT
PERSONNEL TO COMPLY WITH A VERY
LABOR INTENSIVE AND COST
PROHIBITIVE TASK EVEN AS RISING
COSTS AND INADEQUATE REVENUES
HAVE TIGHTEN OUR RECORDS
MANAGEMENT BUDGET. UNDER
CURRENT LAW AGENCIES RETAIN
OFFICER AT PERSON OFF ON A FULL
FIVE YEARS AFTER THE OFFICE AT
LEAST AGENCY FOR ANOTHER AGENCY
OR RETIRES. UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO RETAIN PERSONNEL
RECORDS OF THE PEACE OFFICER
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS FOR THE. SAME
FINDINGS OF MISCONDUCT. YEAH
CAN PLAY BY ITS SIX. H. A. WILL
BE. TO THE SYSTEM OF STORING
PERSONAL RECORDS WITHOUT ANY
THOUGHT TO BUDGETING OR
LOGISTICS PROPERTY TO BE VERY
CLEAR IT'S NOT JUST ACTUALLY
OPPOSED SENATE BILL SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY CELLS L. O. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION RECENTLY
MOVING FROM OPPOSED TO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS THUS FAR
TO CRAFT THE BILL- WE WOULDN'T
KNOW THAT- SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE MADE SPECIFIED RECORDS
AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC DISCLOSURE
BUT MAINLY LIMITED THE SCOPE OF
WHAT COULD BE RELEASED. TO
RECORDS RELATING TO USES OF
FORCE THAT RESULTED IN DEATH OR
GREAT BODILY INJURY OR OTHER
SITUATIONS IN WHICH A COMPLAINT
OF WRONGDOING HAD BEEN
SUSTAINED. SB SIXTEEN EXPANDS
THE RECORDS ON USE OF FORCE
ALLEGATIONS THAT CAN BE
RELEASED TO INCLUDE COMPLAINTS
THAT ALLEGE UNREASONABLE OR
EXCESSIVE FORCE. FURTHER THE
BILL LANGUAGE PROVIDING THAT
THE ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
SHALL NOT BE ASSERTED TO LIMIT
THE DISCLOSURE OF FACTUAL
INFORMATION IS UNNECESSARY. AND
COULD UNDERMINE EFFECTIVE
REPRESENTATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BY THEIR COUNSEL.
UNDER EXISTING CASE LAW
GENERALLY SPEAKING INFORMATION
THAT IS NOT OTHERWISE PRIVILEGE
DOES NOT BECOME PRIVILEGE
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT IS
COMMUNICATED TO AN ATTORNEY.
ADDITIONALLY PERMITTING
DISCLOSURE OF BILLING RECORDS
LITIGATION UNFOLDS KALAU PLAN
IS TO DETERMINE WHERE THE
ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING THE
MUNICIPALITY IS FOCUSING HIS OR
HER EFFORTS ON DEFENSE.
INCLUDING WHAT SERIES OR
DEFENSES THEY INTEND TO PURSUE.
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TO REMOVE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO CIVIL
FINES IN THE ABILITY TO SEE
COSTS AND ATTORNEYS FEES. AND
IF THE BILL WERE FURTHER
REMANDED TWO ONE LIMIT THE NEW
USE OF FORCE PROVISION
DESCRIBED ABOVE. TO PERMIT
DISCLOSURE OF RECORDS RELATING
TO AN INCIDENT INVOLVING A
SUSTAINED FINDING EXCESSIVE
FORCE. AND TO REMOVE THE
LANGUAGE RELATIVE TO THE
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE CSSA
WOULD REMOVE ITS OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NOW COME TO THE COMMITTEE
RUMORED ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE GOING TO.
I'LL TRY TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE I
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR NOW
OPENING IT UP FOR SB SIXTEEN
ANY OPPOSITION. I CERTAINLY AND
SHOULD OPPOSITION YOU CAN QUEUE
UP WITH ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
IMMEDIATELY ONCE AGAIN A ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO FIRST WITH
THE LINE ONE THOUSAND NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT ACTUALLY
CHAIR MEMBERS PERSONAL KID OFF
ON THE HAVE THE PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I NINE SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE NINE SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE EIGHT
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT
LEAST OUR CITY ACCOUNT- WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT
TAKEN BY THE OP BY THE AUTHOR
BUT REMAIN OPPOSED. YOU SHOULD
BE ACTED TURNED OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH. TRANSACTION. CALLING IT'S
SHOWING NO FOR THE LINE QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION AS CHAIR.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
DISCUSSIONS MISTER QUESTIONS
YEAH I. I'D LIKE THIS TO BE A
VERY- DIFFICULT BILL FOR ME TO
WORK THROUGH- BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT WANT TO LOOK LIKE I'M
TRYING TO PROTECT. UNSCRUPULOUS
AND- PROBLEMATIC. AND OFFICERS
WHO HAVE- ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT
BUT I STILL HAVE A FEW CONCERNS
THAT WERE. EXPRESSED BY SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION. SO I'M GONNA
LAUGH TODAY AND HOPING THAT YOU
WILL WORK WITH THOSE PEOPLE.
AND GET THE AMENDMENTS TO WHERE
I THINK. IT'S ACCEPTABLE SO
THAT IT'S NOT UNFAIRLY.
TARGETING OF PEOPLE WHO DON'T
DESERVE TO BE UNFAIRLY TARGETED
AND SO. I'LL BE LAYING OFF
TODAY IN HOPES THAT I MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GET TO WHERE I COULD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN MORE.
THE QUESTION IS A QUESTION. YOU
YOU MAY CLOSE Q. I KNOW YOU'VE
HAD A LONG DAY WHICH IS WHY
DIDN'T EXPLAIN A LOT OF THE
BILL BUT BASICALLY IT'S- A
LIMITED EXPANSION OF. PUBLIC
ACCESS TO SOME RECORDS ON A SET
OF- CONDUCT BY OFFICERS WHICH-
THE- ARE WITNESSING SUPPORT
ARTICULATED AND THESE ARE IN
ALL CASES BUT ONE SUSTAIN
FINDINGS. SO THEY MUST BE THE
OFFICERS CONDUCT MUST HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED AND SUSTAIN BEFORE
THESE RCORDS WOULD BE
RELEASED. NO MY THE BILL WHEN
IT PASSED LAST YEAR. HAD VERY
HIGH FINES ON WEEK BECAUSE WE
EXPERIENCED WHEN FOR AFTER
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WAS PASSED
THAT MANY CITIES REALLY
DIRECTOR FEET THERE ARE STILL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE NOT
RELEASED RECORDS. SO WE ADDED
SOME FINES AND WE'RE GOING TO
ADD ATTORNEY'S FEES BUT WE
REMOVED TO THOSE. IN THE SENATE
APPROACH BECAUSE WE REALIZE
THAT. WHILE WE WANT TO INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT IT WOULD STILL
REQUIRE SOMEONE TO TAKE THE
JURISDICTION OF COURT AND SO
REALLY WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO DO IS ACHIEVE GOOD WELL. AND
WE KNOW THAT- WHAT HAPPENED
WITH FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE IST
WHEN IT WENT INTO EFFECT THERE
WAS A FLOOD OF REQUESTS RIGHT
IN THE BEGINNING OF JANUARY AND
IT WAS A LOT OF WORK FOR THE
JURISDICTION SO IF YOU NOTICE
WHAT OF. THE AMENDMENTS I ALSO
TOOK IS THAT I'VE DELAYED. THAT
THERE'S NO TIME LIMITATIONS ARE
PENALTIES BETWEEN. TWENTY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IN JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SO THAT AGENCIES HAVE A
FOUR YEAR DEAL GET THE REQUEST
OPTED TO REQUEST WILL COME IN
IF THE BILL SIGNED. THE
REQUESTS FOR THESE RECORDS WILL
GET SUBMITTED HOWEVER THEY
DON'T HAVE TO JUST TURN AROUND
AND THIRTY DAYS. AND RELEASE
THEM SO WE FELT THAT THAT WAS
MORE THAN FAIR. AND MOST
RECORDS ARE NOW DIGITAL SO MANY
OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STORAGE WE HAD LESS WE FELT
WERE NOT AS GREAT OF MERIT.
AND- THE IS WHY THE POLICE
CHIEFS NOW SUPPORT AND MOST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL NOT A IN
OPPOSITION AND IF WE COMPARE
THAT TO THE FIRST SET OF
RECORDS WE TRIED TO THE FIRST
BILL. THERE WAS GREAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPPOSITION SO I
THINK WE'VE MOVED. A LOT NOT
JUST ME BUT ALSO. PARTNERS AND-
OUR PUBLIC ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT
I'VE REALLY APPRECIATED I
REALLY HAVE ENJOYED WORKING
WITH THEM. AND I THINK I WILL
CERTAINLY WAY THE- FOR EXAMPLE-
THE SHERIFF'S. LETTERS ONLY
RECENT SO I'LL CERTAINLY WAY
WITH THEY'VE RAISED- BUT FOR
TODAY I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I THINK THE BILL'S VERY
SOUND. AND I'M TAKING THE
COMMITTEES- THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT I'M ACCEPTING OR THE
WHISTLE BLOWER CLARIFICATION
AND REQUIRING THAT THE
MISCONDUCT REGARDING BIAS AND
PREJUDICE MUST BE SUSTAINED THE
RECORDS CANNOT BE RELEASED
UNLESS THAT CONTACT. WAS
INVESTIGATED INSISTING. WE'LL
HELP YOU WITH. WE DON'T HAVE
BEEN MIXED UP WHY IS IT SAY
THAT. IS IT IN BLIGHTED SMILE
WHICH BRIDGE GO FROM HERE. FOR
ME TO CHECK MY THANK YOU
MANAGING JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WELL MAYBE IT'S FOR DEEP DISH
THOUGH IT SAYS PS LET ME ASK MY
STAFF. ABOUT A COMMITMENT TO IT
IF YOU COULD CALL NINE.
IT MAY
BE THAT THE- SO IT'S NOT ANY
MENTION THIS COMMITTEE SO THEY
MAY HAVE PUT IN THE JUDICIAL SO
POLITICS. POLITICS THANK YOU
SHARES RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE
PRINCIPALLY CALDERON THE BILL'S
BEEN PROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED SB SIXTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JOHN SIR A LACKEY
LACKEY NOT VOTING BARRICADE HAN
LI LI HI CORK CORK I SANTIAGO
C. R. TELL THEM C. R. TURNOUT
WICKS HI WICKS I. MEASURES ON
CALLED NEEDS ONE MORE THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE WE'RE DOWN TO OUR
LAST. SENATE BILL COULD YOU ADD
ONS FOR READING SB THREE ONE
SEVEN STERN- HOPEFULLY HE GETS
HERE. RIGHT NOW COME TO PUT
COME TO RUSSIA YOUR TURN. MOVE
THE BILL THANK. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE NEED THE-
WHITE THINGS DOWN IN. OKAY
GREAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'LL BE BRIEF- I DON'T THINK
THIS BILL IS GOING TO FIX THE
ENTIRE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
GOING ON- FOR INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS I AM NOT UNDER.
ANY ILLUSION THAT- THERE'S
GOING TO BE ONE OF SILVER
BULLET TO SOLVING THESE CRISES
BUT- IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES- AND WITH OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS I THINK THIS BILL
PRESENTS. A REALLY IMPORTANT
FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
DEFENDANTS WHO ARE JUDGED TO BE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
THEN ESSENTIALLY CIVILLY
CONFINED DURING THAT PROCESS
AND HOSPITALIZATION OR OTHER.
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THAT THAT'S
NOT COUNTED AGAINST THEM- THOSE
FACILITIES INTO ACCOUNT AND
HOPEFULLY- WE CAN FIND BETTER
WAYS TO USE THAT KIND OF
TREATMENT- AND NOT TRY TO DO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN OUR JAILS
WE'RE JUST NOT WORKING- I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. I KNOW
THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT-
SCOPE- AND CLARITY- IN TERMS OF
THE- WHAT THE- THEIR WHAT WHAT
KIND OF- TRIALS THIS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR- WE WANT TO
CLARIFY IN THE BILL THAT THE
SERVICES CAN ONLY BE ORDERED IF
THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ALREADY HAVE
SERVICES AND ARE WILLING TO
ACCEPT THE DEFENDANT. WE ALSO
WANT TO AUTHORIZE THE COURTS TO
REFER. INCOMPETENT DEFENDANTS
TO A UP TO ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT. UNDER LAURA'S LAW.
AND PROVIDING SOME KIND OF
MIDDLE GROUND BETWEEN ST
DIVERSION AND THEN
CONSERVATORSHIP- AND THEN ALSO
TO INCLUDE TIMELINES THAT
ENSURE SPEEDY ACCESS TO
TREATMENT AND LIMIT. UNDUE
PERIODS OF INCARCERATION FOR
PEOPLE CHARGED WITH
MISDEMEANORS WHO ARE COMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR MEMBERS THIS IS. INTENDED
JUST TO BE ABOUT MISDEMEANORS
HERE WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT-
OTHER CRIMES SO- IF THAT'S
NEEDED TO BE CLARIFIED AS WELL.
I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT- AND I
RICARDO GARCIA HERE L. A.
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER AND A
CONTRA COSTA PUBLIC DEFENDER
STEPHANIE REGULAR. STEADFAST
RAP. THANK YOU AND YOU EITHER
WANT TO MAYBE GET IT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. EVERY YES HELLO OKAY
GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON AND- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. AND THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO BRING GREATER
DIGNITY AND EQUITY TO THE JERRY
VOLATILE POPULATION. I AM
RICARDO GARCIA THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER. BRADLEY
READ THE LARGEST AND OLDEST
PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICE IN THE
NATION. AND I'VE BEEN WITH OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS- MY CAREER
DEFENDING THE VERY PEOPLE THAT
THE BILL WOULD SEEK TO PROTECT.
THE MODEL NUMBER THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTEEN.
WILL ENSURE THE PRESUMED
INNOCENT PEOPLE WHO WERE
DETAINED IN THE STATE HOSPITAL
FOR OTHER MANDATORY DETENTION
BECAUSE OF MENTAL ILLNESS. ST
CUSTODY CREDITS. PER UNIT IN
PEOPLE. INCARCERATED IN COUNTY
JAIL. CURTAIN ALL CONDUCT
CLINICS PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLUNTARILY CARS GRANT
PRETRIAL. CREDITS ARE OFTEN THE
ONLY BENEFIT OF COMPOUND
INCARCERATION. HOWEVER EACH
YEAR APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
THIS TWO THOUSAND PRESUMED
INNOCENT PEOPLE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS WHO ARE DETAINED
PRE TRIAL BECAUSE OF THEIR
MENTAL ILLNESS ARE NOT AWARDED
THE SAME CREDIT. REPORTER ON
SECOND. FOR THE LOG TODAY
PUNISHES CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING
FROM A MENTAL ILLNESS MORE
HEAVILY USED SEVERELY THAN
THOSE CORE NOT ONLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE MENTALLY ILL. BECAUSE
PRACTICE FURTHER PUNISHES
CONDUCT THAT IS THE PRODUCT OF
MENTAL ILLNESS. TO RESPOND JUST
AND HUMANE. WE MUST CREATE AND
HELP PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS NOT PUNISH THE-
THEY SHOULD NOT BE KEPT IN A
CAGE. HOWEVER IF THE MENTALLY
ILL ARE HELD AGAINST THEIR WILL
THEY SHOULD RECEIVE THE SAME
CREDITED PEOPLE HELD WITHOUT
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS. SORRY
AFTER STUDY SHOWS THAT JUGGLING
THE MENTALLY ILL AND DANGEROUS
IMPACT ON MENTAL HEALTH.
INCARCERATION CAUSES PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS TO BE
COMPENSATE AND FACE MORE SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS INDICATIONS AND
LIVES INCLUDING THE INCREASED
LIKELIHOOD OF A REAL SENSE. THE
CURRENT LAW IS ALSO FISCALLY
IMPRUDENT. TAXPAYERS IN
CALIFORNIA MUST PAY THE EXTRA
IN CONSULTATION COST FOR
MENTALLY ILL PERSON SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT GET THE
SAME CONDUCT CREDITS AS OTHERS.
SB THREE ONE SEVEN WILL CLARIFY
THE COMBAT CREDIT STATUTE. TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO BECAUSE
OF THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS SPEND
THEIR PRE TELL TIME
INCARCERATED IN STATE HOSPITAL
OR OTHER AS I SAID MENTAL
MANDATORY RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITY RECEIVED THE SAME
CREDITS AT EVERYONE ELSE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS IN VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WHOSE CONDUCT IS
THE PRODUCT OF THEIR MENTAL
ILLNESS. WE MUST TREAT PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WITH THE
SAME CARE AND COMPASSION WE
TREAT ANYONE WITH A MEDICAL
CONDITION. PERHAPS EVEN MORE SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE REGULAR AND A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDER ASSOCIATION A
CO SPONSOR SB THREE SEVENTEEN.
I'VE ALSO BEEN A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER MENTAL HEALTH UNIT FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS. DESPITE
INNOVATIVE REFORM EFFORTS BY
THE LEGISLATURE. TO DIVERT
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS FROM CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM. THOSE WERE
CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANOR. FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
REMAINER JAILED IN STATE
HOSPITAL THAT. I THINK THE SAME
PEOPLE YEAR AFTER YEAR AND I
THINK THE CALL THAT
HOMELESSNESS REPEAT
INCARCERATIONS AND ENACT IN
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO TREATMENT
HAS ON THEIR PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH. UNDER EXISTING
LAW THE COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR INDIVIDUALS
CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANORS WERE
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. IN THE COUNTY PRESS
DEDICATE THEIR ONLY. TO COMPANY
COMPETENCY RESTORATION. THESE
RESTORATION SERVICES RANGE FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY WITH A FOCUS
ON SHORT TERM STABILITY RATHER
THAN LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. I'M
COUNTY USE THEIR COSTLY
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC BEDS FOR
RESTORATION. OTHER COUNTIES
COMMITTEES AND VIGILS CHARGED
WITH MISDEMEANORS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
DESPITE THE FOURTEEN HUNDRED
PERSON WAITLIST AND DAILY COST
OF SIX HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
DOLLARS BUT THAT. AND MANY
COUNTY HOW THESE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE JAIL AND HOW THEY REACHED
THE END OF THEIR COMMITMENT.
WHAT IS STABILIZED AND COUNTY
INPATIENT BAD. RESTORED AND THE
STATE HOSPITAL ARE MAXED OUT IN
THE COUNTY JAIL. IN THE END
THESE PEOPLE ARE ALL TYPICALLY
RELIEF TO THE STREET. WITH NO
CONTINUITY OF CARE. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY POINT OH ONE AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. DID NOT
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS. BUT THIS BILL
CAN. THIS BILL AUTHORED COURTS
TO FLEXIBILITY TO EXISTING
DIVERSION PROGRAM ALLAFRICA
COURT AND OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT OPTIONS TO TREAT
RATHER THAN INCARCERATED
HEARTRATE MISDEMEANOR OFFERING
SOME SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND THIS BILL ALLOWS CHINESE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
FOCUS ON EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SOLUTIONS. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I PULL IT
OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOUBLE
MOVED TO ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM- IN SUPPORT. YES SIR.
BONTA ONE FOR THE DAY A LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER LITTLE. HE
HUNG IN THERE ALL DAY- THE NOW
TO THE- AB SIDE WHICH IS
PROBABLY HOTTER. DID INSIDE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER I. DON'T CA
NINETY WILL GO TO- THE
TELEPHONE A. T. T. OPERATOR.
CERTAINLY IN NEED LIKE TO QUEUE
UP PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IMMEDIATELY THIS. WE HAVE
A NINE ONE ZERO TWO FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REMEMBER DON'T YOU
DON'T FROM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE NINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BE
SURE HER EIGHTY ON THE
CALIFORNIA ACTION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE ZERO TWO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS COLIN SWEARS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FOR THE COLORS
CUTE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE'LL GO TO
RUMORED OR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN. IN THE ROOM.
WE'LL GO TO THE OUTSIDE. SHE
TREATED ME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND NOW WILL GO TO
THE TELEPHONE DTT OPERATORS
AREN'T ANY WITNESSES AND
OPERATE IN OPPOSITION. AND TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
IF YOU'RE SHOWING DOING QUEUING
UP IN OPPOSITION. THANKS TO A
MOVE TO THE DIASPORA QUESTIONS
COMMENTS YES MR LACKEY. WELL
FIRST OF ALL I'M I'M QUITE
SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS
BILL AND I DON'T THINK THESE UP
PROPOSED PROCEDURES ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR FELONS. AND IT
WOULD RAISE CONFUSION ABOUT HOW
THE NEW LANGUAGE INTERACTS WITH
OTHER LAWS THAT THEY APPLY IN
FELONY CASES. WHAT I'M WANTING
TO KNOW IS. IF YOU'RE OPEN TO
AMENDING THE BILL AFTER IT
LEAVES COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY
THAT- SECTION THIRTEEN SEVENTY
POINT ZERO ONE ONLY APPLIES. IF
THE DEFENDANT IS CHARGED WITH
COMMITTING A MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSE. EIGHT YES I AM. THEN
I'LL BE WILLING TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE. OKAY THAT WAS EASY SO
MANY OTHER COOKBOOKS. CA NINETY
EIGHT CLOSE MISSED SENATORS I
WON'T TALK PASSED YES THEY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL- JURORS
RECOMMENDED I- WITH THE
AGREEMENT THAT WAS MADE HEARING
COMMITTEE. ON SB THREE
SEVENTEEN THE BILL'S BEEN
PROPERLY MOVED AND SECONDED BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SIR HI LACKEY LACKEY HI POWER
CAN BACKING I BELIEVE. WE ARE A
CORK CORK HI SANTIAGO. C. R.
TELL NUMBER C. R. TURNOUT
VOTING WICKS WICKS I. AT
MEASURE PASSES GRADUATION THING
MR. NEXT WE WILL DO ANY ADD ONS
FOR BOTH. CHANGES INCLUDING ALL
THE BILLS ARE CALL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE GO THROUGH ALL
THE MEASURES TAKEN UP TO DATE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BAUER
CAN'T BARRICADE HAD AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. I
REMEMBER ONE SB FOUR TWO BY
SENATOR CAN SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
REMEMBER TO THIS MEASURE WITH
ON CALL SB SEVEN TEN BY SENATOR
BRADFORD POWER CAN BARRICADE
HAD ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES. I DON'T
NUMBER THREE SB TO THIS MEASURE
WAS PULLED BY COMMITTEE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
BY SENATOR BRADFORD SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIGURE TO THEATER NO
WICKES WICKES HI HAT MEASURE
PASSES ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO
HI WICKES WICKES HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES. ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB THREE TWENTY WITH ON CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB THREE FIVE
EIGHT BY SENATOR JONES JONES
SAWYER NOT VOTING JONES SAWYER
NOT VOTING AT LEAD. LEE I THAT
MEASURE PASSED THAT MEASURE
PASSED EARLIER BY PARTIES S. B.
I REMEMBER EIGHT SB TWO FIFTEEN
WITHOUT CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB TWO NINE NINE THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES. I DON'T NUMBER
TEN S. B. TWO NINE SIX WITHOUT
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S.
B. TWENTY THREE RUBIO WITHOUT
CONSENT. ITEM FIVE THREE EIGHT
BY SENATOR RUBIO JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER ICE AND THIAGO
SANTIAGO HI WICKES WICKES I
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB SIXTEEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL POWER KEY HAND.
BARRICADE HANNAH HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I AM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB EIGHTY
ONE THIS MEASURE WAS ALSO ON
CALL BACK OUR KAYHAN BARRICADE
HANNAH HI SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN SB THREE
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR STERN
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I REMEMBER
SIXTEEN SB FIVE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR WIENER THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALLED OUR QUE HAN BARRICADE
HAD NO WICKS WICKS HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE WOULD LIKE
TO FOCUS ON WHAT ON ONE-
GESTURING BY. ON S. ON SB THREE
FIVE EIGHT JONES LEE. I NOT.
LEAVE I TEND NOT VOTING. ANYONE
ELSE. THIS CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.